[Music]
welcome everyone it's a beautiful day in
St Louis and a hugely important day for
the world of Chess as it is the first
round of the US men's championship and
the US Women's Chess Championship it's
going to be a fantastic event in the US
Open Championship we have three of the
top 10 players participating the US
Women's Championship has never been so
strong we expect fireworks over the
board we expect absolutely great chest
it's going to be a very very important
couple of weeks for this participants
and of course we have your favorite
commentary team joining us it's Jen
Maurice and Yas over at the
studio thank you
Alejandro hi Jennifer nice to have you
back welcome welcome thank you and
welcome everybody to our coverage which
is going to span over two weeks of the
2016 us chess championships and US
Women's chess championships I think
we're in for a real treat these next
couple weeks um I we certainly excited
absolutely I can't wait for the games to
begin yeah we got three of the top
players in the world competing here in
the US chess championships it's so
exciting last year we talked about
Fabiano Caron and moving federations and
now here he is playing in our
Championship let's take a look at the
pairings and in his first one first
championship at that and he's going to
be playing against a ver aian in the
first round we've also got Sam Shanklin
against our us Junior Champion aot
Shandra Wesley so got kamski that's a
big one and our defending Champion
hikaro Nakamura against Alex lender Alex
shabalov he's back against a Grandmaster
Ray Robson meanwhile Alexander onook
against a Jeffrey Jang um Jang is to be
a very exciting player in this
Championship as well so let's take a
look at the Women's Championship big
news here we've got Anna zensky back in
the field um we've got tatev abrahamian
against a AATA batv we've got Jennifer
Yu vers ashria asaran Carissa Yip vers
aita gorti Nazi pidi is playing against
Anna and Karina neova against our
defending Champion Arena Crush Sabina
fer versus Lissa mikina now you might
not be familiar with all of those names
because we got a lot of young new blood
in the women's absolutely yeah it's
really nice to see such a a fantastic
field in a youthful field uh Jennifer
I'm really stunned at how young uh the
women's championships are and here are
some of them Nazi is uh setting up to to
play and as we wait more players um to
begin round one let's go over to
Grandmaster Mor actually nahal Famer
congratulations and he's got the key
match ups of the day well thank you so
much Jen well this is what it's all
about the 2016 US championship and US
Women's Championship about to start the
strongest field ever on the US Open
Championship side I mean it's incredible
when you think about Bobby fiser having
played in this tournament the opposition
has never been as heated as Fierce as
this one as we see the great Champions
come in got tosky used to be one of the
top two players he's won this
Championship five times already and he's
not even in the top three in this list
lineup so it's going to be an incredible
tournament let's take a look at a couple
of the head-to-head matchups that we
will will be following quite intensely
first of all welcome back Fabiano
caruana born here in the United States
he played for Italy for several years
but now here he is back in the US
playing in his first championship ever
he will face off against the veteran
vuan akobian who is the only player
within the 30s he's 32 years old in this
event we have three 40y olds everybody
else under 30 this should be a very
interesting matchup right off the bat
but of course we have to follow this one
Hikaru Nakamura four-time Champion
chasing goddess five he will look to
cement himself as the country's best
player although favano is nipping at his
heels he'll face off against Alexander
Lenderman who's acquitted himself quite
well in these championships before they
last met in 2012 the Game ending in a
draw and on the women's side well the
name that rings from the hill she will
be a future Hall of Famer unquestionably
Grandmaster Arena crush the seven time
champion of this event facing off
against Karina mova who in her first
championship last year came in third
place a really good player this matchup
will be a difficult one for arena with
the black pieces we'll see how she acits
herself and round one about to start in
what should be an epic championships
we're going to have fun with you guys
over the next two weeks for sure back to
you jenas thank you Maurice that's right
now let's take a look at our tournament
format we've got a 22 player around
robins and that means there's 11 games
90 minutes for the first 40 moves
followed by 30 me second minutes 30
seconds for the remainder of the game
car would be good at that tournament no
but it's actually 30 minutes followed by
30 second increment so it's sounds long
but those end games can get pretty hot
and heavy right no third time control
just two and you get your bonus with
each move you make starting from move
one now the Women's Championship has
their highest price Fund in history
$100,000 and the US Chess Championship
which is open to men and women and I
feel the Open Championship actually yes
exactly and as we see some of the really
young women in the Women's Championship
that might become more than um
theoretical absolutely some years but
the uh the championship prize fund is
almost $2,000 50,000 for first place for
the women we've got
$25,000 for first place
and in both competitions we've got the
Bobby Fisher award so if you sweep the
field and get 11 all and either
competition you will get an additional
64,000 so somebody could walk away from
St Louis with
$114,000 how long do you think that
record is going to remain feasible well
uh going with a perfect score is
virtually unattainable because the
players are just so much stronger the
opposition to BU Fisher was good but
nothing like what we're seeing today so
I think it's only theoretical I'm
guessing maybe as long as four rounds
before the Bobby Fisher prize is safe
you think four four in the championship
what about the women yeah for for both
events like I think that it ends after
four yeah well that's I mean somebody
starting 4 Z is really remarkable it is
in fact I think many um betting women
would take the under on that line but
okay I I I still think that um I still
think that you know you never know
what's going to happen I mean remember
we had we were lucky enough to witness
Fabiano Carana almost sweep the uh the
sinkfield cup which would have been even
more remarkable exactly so we do like to
watch that uh come in so we've got tat
vaman here setting up she's um on a a
good streak so far she's been playing
well she had a really good result in
Iceland recently and she's playing one
of the newcomers to the event um
you see gotsky he got inducted into the
Hall of Fame last night along with
Grandmaster Mari asley a very emotional
uh ceremony yesterday wasn't just the
drawing of the Lots but uh in in
particular Maurice's speech in front of
his mom sister and daughter that was a
very very special moment and I think we
were all deeply touched it was great
exactly I think there there there are
some tissues being passed out I know
Maurice came to me later and said you're
going to have to move over on that Hall
of Fame you got to make a little room
for me I said oh boy welcome welcome
welcome Maurice so it was very very nice
got a speech of course brevity is the
soul of way yeah I know thank you very
much it's great to be with the big names
uh just uh about the opening ceremony
yesterday of course there was the
drawing of lots which means since
there's an odd number of rounds
somebody's going to get one extra white
and so drawing the uh the uh numbers 1
through six you get the extra right what
was especially telling for me was that
the three favorites on paper in the open
section Wesley Hikaru and Fabby all Drew
an extra white that's pretty tough for
the rest of the field it's bad enough
that you're an underdog but then you get
an extra black so I'm thinking that that
really push matters and one of those
three players is going is a heavy
favorite to win the US Championship
I
I agree and let's go up to Tony Rich the
executive director here at the chess
club who is going to kick off the
proceedings
here hello everyone and welcome to round
one of the 2016 US championship and US
Women's Championship I'm Tony Rich I'm
one of the organizers of this event I
have to say we we couldn't be more proud
to be hosting this event right now all
of these great players all of this
amazing chess that we're about to see a
lot to look forward to just a couple of
quick announcements before we begin
uh reminder that tonight is the poers
shares tennis series uh the shuttle will
leave from the chase at 6:15 p.m. uh
there's a signup sheet up here now uh
feel free to sign up for that if you
would like to go uh the tennis match is
expected to go until 9:45 but the
shuttle will run continually so if you'd
like to leave earlier than that so you
can prepare for tomorrow's game you're
welcome to do that as well um when your
game's finished if you if you would
prefer uh we'll have the the signup
sheet down at the front desk as well all
the normal announcements um please make
sure uh no talking to each other uh no
talking amongst the players uh
Spectators no talking or noise of any
kind please um if you have a camera or
uh such a recording type of device
please make sure any beeps are turned
off or anything like that as
well ah a big thanks to uh Ed gonz who
also prepared the uh stats and figures
uh updated from his previous efforts uh
each of you should have a thumb drive on
your table with everything about the US
championship and Women's Championship uh
since the very
beginning uh the last announcement I
have is please make sure you turn in
your tax forms I would love to pay all
of you and I need that tax form in order
to do
so ah thank you also a reminder that the
confessional Booth is open and available
I encourage all the players to use it um
you're welcome to go in there when you
sit down at the chair wait 5 seconds and
then start talking um it can be about
the position it can be about your uh
mood or or thoughts going into the game
or anything else uh but I do encourage
you to please use that the spectators
love
it us want to go in and please make sure
you let the Arbiters know that you're
headed there just in case somebody's
already in there as well it uh so the
confessional Booth right in here and
back in the kitchen it's the closet in
the kitchen yep so the door will be open
to that closet it's set up as a sound
booth it's soundproof so everything will
be which was yesterday today I had no
trouble opening it all right
and that is all the announcements I have
I'm honored to be joined by Dr Jeanie
singfield uh she and her husband Rex
founded the chess club and are uh the
folks responsible for putting on the the
championship so thank you all very much
appreciate being here will you do us the
honor of ringing the bell absolutely
let's get it you're not finished yet
you're not finished yet I don't want any
cups or drinks on this side of the board
interferes with the cameras okay and no
no bottles or anything else like on the
table they go on the table on
please make sure you use the drink
tables on the sides we'd like to get
some great photos and until Coca-Cola
sponsors the US championships I'm not
letting them get in our pictures all
right now that's all without further Ado
Dr Genie singfield will start the round
it doesn't mean
okay thank
you we are the two the
2016 US championships are now underway
and yes we've got a Fabiano kowana vers
veran agobian that looks like an E4
these two have never actually played
before which is is pretty surprising and
usually you would expect the French from
VAR right I think we just saw a
Scandinavian Oh I thought it was a
sicilian yeah well a Scandinavian this
uh opening is a centuries long opening
but to I'm wondering at the US
Championship when last somebody
uh trotted out the Scandinavian pretty
remarkable question I mean it's not
popular at the highest level so varujan
a Cobian the first to the surprise one
of the pre-tournament favorites I'll be
really looking forward to seeing how
Fabiano treats us CU I got to tell you
Scandinavian it's a great opening to
play in Blitz cuz you like oh you get
your queen out you queenside castle and
you start you start attacking me with
Bishop D6 E5 so um I know Fabby very
well a parent player um we'll have to
see how that goes now speaking of Blitz
we've got uh the uh perhaps the best the
best bullet player in the world hikaro
Nakamura not no perhaps on that one
Jennifer he is an
extraordinary Blitz player for sure
number one in the world but I suspect
he's the greatest blz uh bullet player
of the world has ever seen yes but I I I
did I did call him that in an interview
today that he was the best ever
um of course Blitz is a little different
a lot of comptition minutes but one
minute he is simply extraordinary and
today he plays against Alex Slenderman
uh they've had uh matchups in the past
uh I believe that it's two draws and one
win for hikaro in their matchup and
Queen's Gambit declined by Alex
Lenderman
um and he car already looking stressed
out play yeah like
like this isn't a Sur so one of the
things iaru is thinking about of course
is just what Pathways he can take the
game does he want to play conventionally
with Knight C3 he could go into a
Catalan and uh the third the third L uh
there are a lot of very different
branches of play here for
white now one interesting stat that um
Ed Gonzalez who uh Tony actually just
mentioned in the the pregame alerted me
to is that there's actually a a hot stat
that could be broken today um Sam
shankland needs to win his game if he
doesn't want to be the player who hasn't
won game one of a US Chess Championship
in eight years so if he doesn't win
today he's going to tie with Sadi for
that not exactly auspicious record right
Oopsy Daisy although I mean you know of
course a lot of those games were surely
draws so it's not necessarily that bad
to get a slow start and probably depends
on how many blacks you get and whatnot
but he um will be trying to win this
game probably has no idea that that
record actually exists and just wants to
win the game so this is his eth event
and he's never won the first round
exactly and here he is playing against
the lowest rated player in the field the
very talented akat Chandra who's
multi-talented not only a great chess
player at such a young age but also a
really good writer yeah so I've read
some of his articles is pretty
extraordinary for such a young man and
to be so good at chess as well like
obviously he's um keeping up with his
studies as well so that's a quest to GM
and we're going to be getting well
acquainted with oot throughout the
tournament absolutely we go to
Maurice well you guys were talking about
bullet chess well Nakamura had an
unusual way of preparing for the
championship according to chess.com he
played A8 hour bullet match eight hours
against Grandmaster Eric Hansen and his
score in bullet
234 and a half
234.567
against our colleague Grandmaster Eric
Hansen who plays a lot of bullet chess
himself but I can't imagine you play
bullet for eight hours Eric said that he
couldn't feel his hand after he was done
after eight hours of play and Nakamura
using that as his way of warming up his
mind for this event I mean he must know
something we don't because I would not
have recommended you do that to prepare
for the US Championship which is clearly
not bullet I mean he's already in
thought in this position the other
position of interest you guys talked
about it's not even a Scandinavian
anymore on this board vuan is thrown out
this funky line after the move e takes
D5 he played Knight F6 traditionally you
take back with the the queen on D5 and
black goes for a slightly worse but
solid position but this line with Knight
F6 Bishop B5 Bishop D7 Bishop C4 this
could have been opted for on the first
move now Bishop to G4 it is clear that
vuan knows Fabiano Carana is one of the
most well-prepared players on the planet
period do not give him a good opening
position that he knows and he clearly
had something ready for var's French and
he was looking to destroy it so VAR said
let me surprise you first and already
he's got the great far Fabiano Karana
one of the Great greatest theoreticians
we know thinking on move four well at
least now it's his move five that's got
to be a plus for him a big start to this
game the lines are supposed to be better
for white coming out of this variation
but probably Fabiano hasn't looked at
these variations in forever I mean after
all he's not expecting this to come from
his 2800 colleagues uh we'll see what he
prepared or what he can come up with now
knowing that he is the one who's fallen
into the
Trap and on boards as well we can see
some starts Sam Shanklin actually has
started in a French defense with akat
Shandra very solid position here for the
black pieces as you can tell black has
gotten a good game uh but still a long
way to go we know Sam to be a great
theoretician as well so he'll handle
that one hikaru's position has proceeded
a pace here and we see that they have
actually transposed into a looking
structure happening on that board and if
we go down the horn we see that G and
Wesley they are playing a standard
Spanish we'll see whether or not g
Wheels out a Berlin G the fellow honorie
as inducted into the Hall of Fame I
remember he was calculating we were
sitting next to each other after we got
our Awards and everybody got their their
numbers drawn and God was trying to
calculate wait a minute I'm Number 10 so
who do I play I play number four and
then he thought oh no that's Nakamura in
round one already and then when Carol
jki the Arbiter said uh that he was
actually paired against Wesley so he
looked over at Naka and said what what
confused and Naka said well listen it's
12 players that's why the that's the way
it is and he's oh okay and then he
stopped and he said well it doesn't
really make a difference actually cuz
now he's got to play Black against
Wesley so definitely has his hands full
I think he thinks himself as an underdog
in this event despite the fact that he
has won five times Wesley has never won
the championship he played just once
last year so we'll see how this one
proceeds because this is a heavy weight
matchup you could see something like
this at the very top of Chess but it
should be
interesting all right indeed and uh I I
think that uh G often understates his
Ambitions he wants to win this
tournament even of course he does and
for G he always you know lowballs
expectations but believe me he's got a
belly full of fire and he's still
determined uh to be the best player in
the United
States let's take a comparison at gak
CSK last year and this year changing up
the fashion got to keep him guessing I
like it
got you we see that a lot in the Women's
Championship people changing their hair
their their style but um God that's a
big change that's a big change yeah very
nice do you like the long hair um well
I'm more it's not it's not nothing
against G but I'm not as into long hair
most people I like I like like the
shorter the shorter Cuts usually all
right but I do I I appreciate the the
switching it up yes indeed kind of
switch it up and uh in their game uh
Wesley so by the way has a very nice
record against G they've played three
games two wins for Wesley only a single
draw and in last year's us Championship
Wesley won with black today he is
playing white and uh they're playing the
most uh well-known uh opening in chess
the ru Lopez and the players have they
they they they slow balled it at the
start but then they sped up to a very
well-known uh position which got lot of
experience in exactly and the Brer
defense is really the centuries old well
Century old yeah well it's one of the
oldest uh the the night on um C6 is
actually not very well placed and it
reroutes itself self we'll understand in
a second from the D7 Square the Knight
there we go protects the E5 pawn and as
we'll see in one further move after
Bishop B7 the bishop has an open view
against the E4 pawn and that forces
white to drop back with his Bishop the
bishop on
C2 uh steps up the defense of the Pawn
on e4 but on the B3 Square it was
eyeballing Black's King so black has
forced to retreat as POS Bishop to a
slightly more passive Square all of
these Maneuvers are very standard and uh
the most standard move uh that I'm aware
of is A2 A4 and Wesley thinking about
that usually the line goes
A4 uh Bishop G7 Bishop to D3 and many
many hundreds of games this is almost
kind of a tabia uh a starting position
for these top players yeah very
principal
Roy Lopez Maneuvers here with the Knight
coming to G3 trying to to eye the F5
Square black responding with his G6 fan
ketto which usually isn't that popular
in E4 E5 variations but it works out
quite well here within white with using
this long winded maneuver to get his
Knight to a strong Square exactly so
yeah just super principal and it's
really good for those of you who are
trying to pick up the Roy Lopez to pay
attention to this game because these
type of Maneuvers with A4 Knight G3 the
fen Kettle they up in pretty much um
every closed Roy exactly and you said it
well just a moment closed Ry in a closed
position you see a lot of maneuvering
and by closed position I mean positions
where there are seven pawns for each
side or more on the board and that
allows for these uh long winded
Maneuvers uh anat karpo made a career
out of playing KN D2 to F1 to G3 uh a
very handsome one I might add yeah I
like I I love playing that in Blitz it's
like if you play that maneuver in Blitz
and then you get your KN on F five they
they lose every time yeah we just feel
good about it don't you so let's uh
continue our look around the board just
a second and oh just an update instead
of the traditional move A4 as mentioned
before um Wes instead of the A4 move
which I know much better than Bishop J
G5 uh Bishop G5 H6 Bishop D2 has been
played
well okay I would imagine that Wesley's
idea is that with Queen C1 King H7
interesting a moment ago I put the
bishop on the bishop was on B3
eyeballing uh Black's King Now The
Bishop's on C2 doing the same thing in
can try to play for H4 and uh nibble
away a little bit at uh I mean of course
that weakens the D4 square but I'm
trying to play H5 and re regain the F5
Square there you go because if you ever
take on H5 of course that would leave
the F5 square one one of the uh
treatments that Boris basy made famous
as black is he often would play H5 and
not King H7 in these partic this
specific uh type of position so again
very big theoretical contest going over
on that one I want to jump back for a
second to this game of verian akobian
because I just find it
remarkable uh that VAR has made a pawn
sacrifice quite frankly VAR is known as
a kg Wy veteran doesn't like sacrificing
material much rather sacrifice his
opponent's material solid sacrifice his
opponent's material I like that yeah and
he's he's given a pawn early to uh Fabby
with this maneuver Bishop F5 and Knight
bd7 interesting thing Maurice uh give us
an update what what's all that about you
should should be befuddled yes because
this position has never ever been seen
by any player over
2600 ever this is the first time we're
seeing this variation getting played
this Knight F6 Bishop B5 Bishop D7 line
I've seen I believe an ivanta game
before in the early position but this
line here we're about to go to Bishop to
G4 and now F3 Bishop F5 and black is
aiming to get this Pawn back at some
point but white simply won't let it
happen to easily stting the pawn on D5
and now Knight bd7 searching to get to
B6 and this is the position I was
referring to this has never been seen
the engines are actually saying that
white only has a slight Advantage here
noticing that this Pawn looks like it
will drop at some point although it's
not so easy for black to get at it white
can play very aggressively with G4 here
and that's a very sharp line I should
point out G4 the engines give ignoring
that attack attacking this bishop and
after this bishop drops back back as
best now the move Bishop to C8 not
relegating itself to this square and
again this D Pawn looks like it will
fall the engines like the position for
white after D4 but I think that if black
gets the pawn here uh with just night
takes on this Square the engines also
give the move A5 to me I I don't think
white would ever want a position like
this one this night not being in a good
place and these two pawns not looking
that great either so this position is
very close to what vuan wants and he
looks to he's looking to play this move
move now most players in this position
have played the move Knight G to E2 but
you're going to have to face off against
this move and if you obviously the pawn
on D5 is under attack so if you try to
keep it with Bishop to B5 check in this
position now the bishop drops back to D7
and a trade Queen takes and suddenly the
D Pawn is under Fire and again it's
going to drop so it looks as though
black to me even though the injures oh
not now the engines will start to go
down and say it's more towards equality
and I would absolutely agree if I got
this as BL I feel like I was fine coming
out the opening so I think he surprised
Carana for sure looks as though fabbi
did not play the most critical lines
even though he actually played the most
popular lines and he's not going to get
an advantage any serious Advantage here
not on the board and not on the clock
and not psychological either look at VAR
leaning back saying you fell into my
preparation sir and the body language of
Carana is telling it all he is not happy
he's got white right out the gate no
real advantage that he can find totally
out of his preparation this is a very
significant occurrence right away in
round one of the US championships wow
and talking about significant
occurrences too while Maurice was giving
I didn't realize we're going to get
theoretical novelty so early in the show
uh check out what just happened in the
game between Hikaru Nakamura and
Alexander L Lenderman so this is a very
standard semi slav position uh lots of
players uh the Moscow variation with
Bishop G5 has played and instead Hikaru
went
G3 Alex captured the pawn bishop G2
these are very wellknown Pawn sacrifices
but I have never seen this move B3 in
this specific position why because it
seems to to offer black a golden
opportunity to play to move B4 attacking
the Knight okay let's say you move your
knight I'm not saying it may be a peace
sacrifice but then after C3 essentially
strategically you're lost because black
has a protective pass Pawn on the C3
square and this may be preparation by
Hikaru but boy it better work because if
it doesn't it's just like you're gonna
lose Maurice what's going on with what's
going on here this is crazy first round
it is an absolutely crazy first round
and we have to go quickly to try to keep
up with developments because stuff's
happening everywhere fire on board in
the game between Shanklin and our young
participant akot Shandra the second
youngest participant in the competition
they're playing a wild position and
check this out guys the move Rook to E1
remember I said looks like black has a
nice solid position looking very much
like a a very solid French and he played
the move Queen C7 attacking the bishop
the bishop drops back to F1 looks as
though white has only one real piece
developed and a nice Rook on E1 agreed
but nothing too aggressive here Bishop
to D6 gaining a Tempo on the H2 Pawn
waiting for you to defend it so I can
Castle Shanklin said no I don't think so
time for me to start an attack attacking
the bishop hitting the pawn on G7 of
course you cannot take because of the
pin on the E line so what's up let me
take this Pawn with check and now King
over and let me just make this little
King maneuver King to f8 moving my my
king out of the way looking to chase
this Knight out and then look to
redeploy the bishop what does Sam do you
can have my knight take it if you want
to the youngster said sure what if I
snack on it a queen sacrifice right in
the O right away and black cannot
capture this queen because we smell a
mate right on the board into absolutely
forc down Rook to E8 and mate so after
Queen F6 black though stayed cool and
play the move 86 defending his position
and this is the position we have
currently on the board actually now the
move Queen to D4 has been played I for
some reason I smell a theoretical rat
I'm going to take a look to see if this
line has been seen before but the
engines do believe that despite being
down upon Pawn is white with this H2
Pawn having dropped off the board that
it is white with the advantage The Rook
on the E Line does really leave a good
impression and the King having not
castled and that look on the H file on
h8 doesn't look that good either so wild
chess guys right away this is what we
look for we we long for when we get a
big tournament like this one and already
in round one it looks as though Sam is
trying to break that curse he doesn't
want to do eight in a row not having won
the first round that's right he wants to
win his first first game of the
championship and oot wants to win his
first game very very good um let's take
a look let's take a look and see how
that position looks now of course the
fact that it's so so wild and crazy and
yet they're playing these moves so
quickly means 100% they have analyzed
this at home and it's preparation well I
remember uh having this position as
black against um Leon sham kovich do you
remember sham kovich yeah you wrote a
book in eng s oh yeah well he wrote a
number of books he is a great tactician
a Grandmaster from the Soviet Union who
immigrated to the United States Bishop
takes H2 King over
I was black and I remember this being
shocked by this move Knight takes G7
King takes G7 this later became a very
well heavily analyzed theoretical uh
game because after Queen D2 uh White has
can I bail out with this queen checks
and to take this Knight or queen checks
over here and takes the bishop and if I
bail out I'm just a little worse in the
end game right Bishop F4 two Bishops
you're happy with that yeah but the way
the game uh went was a surprise for me
Queen takes F6 a beautiful Checkmate of
course that Maurice pointed out H6 Queen
came back Bishop uh E6 one of the things
I really notice amongst the elite top
players is they love the initiative
nobody today likes to play defensive
chess and you're seeing a lot of
sacrifices already in this first round
we're seeing Pawn sacrifices by Hikaru
by akobian and now by Sam maybe there
are other sacrifices going on but very
early Initiative for white me I just
like the
material but we're e we so what's the
what's the body count here black up a
pawn right so um I I feel like we need
to develop that dark squared Bishop so
how are we going to do it I would love
to play I would love to figure out a way
to Fe and K so I could thread and
Checkmate maybe you're
just similar idea just put put it on C3
and like you say threatening Checkmate
black for his part will try to develop
and if you put your Bishop on C3 this
doesn't look good and please forgive
me Rook H7 it doesn't look good but at
least I do have a plan I want to go King
G8 and maybe on a good day just trundle
Henry the H Pawn up the board that's
right and so now and so you got to prove
your yeah you got to prove your
initiative you you can still uh you know
kick me around right you've got an early
initiative but yeah you know how to make
your Pawn sacrifice really right work
that's why I'm think I'm wondering what
F's going to play right here I was even
thinking I know it's very weakening so
of course you came up with the idea of
Bishop D2 Bishop C3 but I was also
looking at the fian kettle with B4 just
to Pro just kind of like lock down the
uh the C5 Square I like it I like it
B4 Bishop so it's very similar except in
the previous line I had Bishop C5 your
move B4 basically forces me in this case
to go into a more defensive Shell at the
moment a lot of black pieces uh around
his King so I really can't imagine you
getting a Checkmate against me but on a
good day you may be able to well I don't
think the sacrifice Works immediately
and meanwhile you're threatening Bishop
F6 actually winning material Bishop F6
is on my agenda yeah yeah this there
still a lot for Sam to prove exactly
that's why I think it'll be it'll be
really interesting to see what he comes
up with right here he's probably still
in preparation but probably maybe
reviewing some of his preparations
that's one of the hard things in chess
as you do so much preparation that
sometimes and you're looking at so many
lines that are similar to others and to
remember them is really a great
Challenge and he has played a move so
let's take a look at that and then I
also want to go over to the Women's
Championship speaking of preparation
guess who I saw on her laptop 5 minutes
before the game 10 minutes before the
game just getting that little extra bit
of preparation I can't imagine it's
arena so who was it the youngest player
in the
competition she was there so I I mean I
expect big things from that star of
course oh yeah I don't know her star is
going to shine brightly in the years
ahead she's 12 years she's 12 now and
she beat her first Grandmaster at 9
years years old and you know earlier you
said that Bobby Fisher prize was
impossible one of my favorite Karissa
Yip quotes or any female just player
quotes was anything is possible if you
try hard enough like beating a grandmas
she was nine nine anything is possible I
mean then what did she do go back to the
sandbox and play oh my god there she is
way wow and she's playing against AK
gorti so this is a key game actually
because it's really two youngsters who
um
on um as a wild card Chris actually
getting in by raing and we're going to
really see I think one of these players
shock the field and um maybe this game
will tell us which one but uh meanwhile
Sam Actually played Bishop C4 a move
that we hadn't looked at at all right
which was actually a very good move
because I I this move Bishop C4 we were
just realizing very quickly a moment ago
that if black was allowed to Simply
develop with Bishop E6 and get his Rook
over on A8 into the game he'll be fine
at least with this move Bishop C4
eyeballing the F7
pawn it it actually also means that uh
the E file
remains open and so Bishop C4 I think
that's an excellent move yeah stopping a
really nice prophylactic move I was uh I
was too obsessed with getting a
Checkmate
right with good slow down good Reas all
right let's move uh let me just see
around what else is going on uh we have
the veteran Alexander onuk who's played
in boy I think over 10 Olympiad teams
three World teams for the United States
he's up against Jeffrey uh Jong Jeffrey
the youngest participant in the field
coming in from Dallas uh playing Black
years old that's right
wow uh Queens Gambit accepted with the
move B7 B5 uh normally
uh the players reluctant to play B5
because after A4 this Pawn on
B4 it's often that white gets to play
around the pawn he gets to put his
Knight on B3 controlling the C5 squar
which is absolutely key to
um Black's efforts to break up in the
center so Bishop takes C4 with the very
straightforward obvious threat of Queen
F3 with a double attack against The Rook
on A8 the pawn on F 7 uh protecting
against that Queen F3 anyway provoking
C6 Knight E2 and immediately E4 so we
seeing Alexander onuk jumping all over
uh Jeffrey early but I'm absolutely sure
that that this is still preparation for
Jeffrey because uh B5 A4 B4 uh what was
played earlier these moves by white are
pretty straightforward so we have to
imagine that Jeffrey is prepared for
this position well yeah Jeffrey Jeffrey
should be very well prepared in general
I mean actually I read an article about
him I he was one of the participants in
the US Chest school in Los Angeles where
youngan Guston was the coach and the
entire Camp was about opening
preparation so not as much about a
specific opening as like Yan is a great
theoretician so he would kind of try to
explain to them and go over some of
their openings and how do you prepare
your openings well for this type of
highlevel competition that um you know
some people like Jang and uh Sam seian
are are really gearing towards uh
becoming the next Nakamura or Carana and
try being theor theoretical
theoreticians of opening chess uh
knowledge yeah they need to be really
strong in that area of the
game yes and just one other thing I was
going to say that we're doing something
a little bit different extra special
this year for the US championships we
are inviting telephone callers to come
in give us a call and uh any questions
that you have for me yaser or Maurice
and or all of us um give us a call 314
361 5465 you can also contest Us in the
traditional way via the hash us chest
Champs it's funny that that it's kind of
flipped right I said Twitter is the
traditional way like like a landline
phone only only if you have a landline
please give us a call Maurice what do
you have for us yeah and these days
people don't want to talk to you text
nobody wants to talk email well a very
important game going on on the women's
side we feature this at the very top of
the broadcast between Grandmaster enen
crush and uh Katarina Nima and their
game this game is really interesting and
a moment happened just now that
surprised me and yaser i' I'd love to
get your opinion on this because I
didn't expect it at all first of all uh
they're in the Sicilian here Knight C3
Queen C7 F4 and now A6 typical stuff
Knight takes B takes E6 Bishop D3 and
now the move D5 black is achieving
exactly what she wants to in this line
with this move D5 Knight F6 King to H1 a
nice little prophylactic move along the
long diagonal and now Bishop to E7 Queen
F3 and castles everything so far so
normal Bishop to E3 and the difference
of course black has a very strong
structure of Pawns in the middle of the
board and we see that there white is
looking to do something with these pawns
but any advance any advance too early
could create some kind of stasis for
white that white can't get the attack
rolling so easily and white would like
to play G4 but of course the king is on
H1 and a bishop could end up on B7 which
is what happened next Bishop to B7 now
just somewhat suppressing the idea of G4
in any position and here's where it
happened the move e takes D5 now my
instincts just quickly said capture C D5
what's the big deal but Arena decided on
what looks to me as a controversial
response and the engines are giving it a
slightly worse for black as well this
move e takes D5 now it's definitely
clear if these pawns get moving then
black will be okay black wants to play
C5 and D4 and then black will be fine
but it's this move which I'm not sure if
it has been played yet it has been
played Bishop to D4 this is the one that
concerns you because now the bishop is
on a great Square both Bishops aimed at
Black's King and also if you try to play
C5 then this Knight on F6 will drop and
the D Pawn will drop so it's not so easy
white will try to make it difficult for
black to get the move C5 in but can
white try for it can white make it
happen anyway the engines are give it a
move like Queen to D6 guarding the pawn
and preparing this and after Bishop to
E5 Queen E6 I would think engine play
like this never G to happen on the chess
board there's no way that this is going
to be the decision that Arena makes to
play with her Queen here especially with
this move coming next so that's just
kind of computer play that there's no
way this grandmas is going to play like
this so after Bishop to D4 the question
is maybe a move like Rook to d8 the
engine is giving Rook to E8 but I'm
interested in this move trying to get C5
in at all cost but the engines are
arguing with me and saying Knight to A4
and it's difficult to pull it off
because the move C5 runs into Knight
takes C5 anyway tactics in the position
and if you take here suddenly Bishop F6
gf6 and hello the part is on as you're
going to get mated on the H7 Square so
natural moves do not work so it looks as
though white will play this position
Bishop to D4 and cause a little bit of
consternation to Arena and there she is
thinking about the position that move
beat e t e takes D5 it's bit of a
strange move don't you think yes oh
without question Maurice uh in fact if I
I was giving a a chess lesson I kind of
spanked the hand uh of E6 takes d
Everybody Plays C6 takes D5 capturing to
Wars the center I'm sure Arena had a
specific tactical idea in mind you
pointed out that really nice trick uh
everybody wants to play C5 so Rook d8
you know is an automatic and perhaps
Arena and it's an easy tactic to miss
don't be wrong this is really uh a nice
one night A4 and then suddenly Knight C5
and you go oh dear suddenly my king is
going to be uh denuded on the king side
I think it's also because it's it
actually requires that precise move
order that Maurice picked I think
because if you after C5 Knight C5 Bishop
C5 Bishop F6 gf6 um it's important that
you play this uh Queen F5 move so that
black can't um defend with like F5 and
F6 uhuh see um yeah so after like King
h8 I think like natural move to look at
might be like Queen H5 but then um black
can maybe defend with F5 and F6 so if
you're looking at this like far in
advance you might miss that little tweak
with like the queen coming to the F5
square right which is uh just that that
perfect blocking move no no no question
about it but uh you know it's funny I
didn't see Queen G4 F5 don't ask me why
what I saw was Bishop H7 I'm just so
attuned to this kind of a mating pattern
you know this one the old R and your
King has absolutely no protection so
there is kind of like multiple reasons
that Irena could have avoided this
actually but we already have a phone
call so excited our first US
Championship phone call all right um
yeah hello uh doing a great job as usual
Jennifer love the uh the blonde streak
looking hot there thank you you from I'm
uh John Cisco from upstate New York uh
my question was since there was so much
controversy in the Fay candidates Final
on the tiebreak system what is the Tie
breaks in the US Women's in the US Open
Championship thank you ja wonderful
question I'm very very proud to say we
play playoffs thank goodness because
especially in around Robin it's very
important in my opinion not to use math
die braks unless you're really
constrained by theing of the tournament
sometimes you really have very few
choices even then I prefer some kind of
Armageddon 15 minute anything because
it's around Robin you all play the same
players especially in the candidates
it's even worse because you don't even
have different colors exactly it's a
double round robin I mean you know I I
can believe the head-to-head matchup in
the candidates as being the first
tiebreaker that makes a little sense to
me thereafter playoff yes exactly I
don't even think the head to head but um
I like I like the playoff of course I
felt a little bit more strongly about it
because it was our
guy boy it's one of those things I
didn't even if even if iby had benefited
from it you would have asked me and I
would have said I didn't like the idea
but I would be like well let's take it
you know I mean let's take the spot
right but especially since he was being
damaged by it was particularly painful
cuz it felt it felt kind of injust even
though they knew the rules in advance um
Maurice to jack for that a great
question I got to say even if it was our
guy just personally I think that fair
play says playoffs come on whoever
decides the entire event on some tie
break system that's just completely
ridiculous maybe maybe when you're in
the the the initial stage trying to get
to the playoffs trying to get to the
finals but the entire event based on tie
breaks that's completely ridiculous I
think it was absolutely unfair and I'm
glad we're not doing it for these
championships well another matchup we're
talking about heavyweight matchup Nazi
pidi from last year showed her medal not
losing a game in the entire competition
and coming in second place to Arena
Crush last year's event of course now
she's facing off against a woman who
knows how to win this event in Anna
zonk's won it quite a few times before
Anna I believe has won it four times and
Anna back in the event last year she had
a young child I saw at the opening
ceremony her husband Grandmaster Daniel
fredman and their children he was
playing a daddy role with the two kids
and of course he's also going to be
preparing her round after round they
used to do it long distance while he was
in Germany but he's decided to come here
and she won't be lonely at all kids all
around her family support so she's
looking to make a run at this
Championship they have a very solid
position on the board but expect this to
be a great game because Nazi is known as
a very positional player and able to
hold her own and looks like they have a
solid one on the board as we speak
another position of interest uh with
some a newcomer first of all one of the
potential contenders in this position in
this tournament tatev Abraham Yan She's
Come Oh So Close she's always been the
bridesm made never the bride in this
competition sooner or later she's got to
make her breakthrough but she's busy
facing off against Arena crush and and
Anna Zoni as we mentioned earlier she's
never quite been able to get over that
hump and win the whole thing this is a
player many fans root for hoping that
she'll be able to get those nerves
together get the style together and make
it happen finally winning one and just
add a new name we're kind of getting a
little bit tired of the same two names
all the time you know how the fans are
we're fickle we want to see some change
well anyway she's got a wild position
against a newcomer to the competition
AATA we had Gat kamsky we got AATA On
The Other Side by Kev a 16-year-old
check this out guys this is what I read
about her in the bio cuz I knew nothing
at all who who is this young lady at 16
she's already finish her requirements
for college math she's already got
differential calculus down uh she's
she's like it's ridiculous Super Genius
ready to go to Community College she's
already gone to Community College to get
all that math done so she might end up
finishing College in two years the way
Alyssa mahina did another genius who
who's a lawyer at 23 uh finished the bar
and all that these women are quite
remarkable and here we have a
16-year-old in the competition a wild
position on the board as you see it
started off with this line H3 you guys
remember this line at all this is the
line that took down Fabiano caruana this
is what Sergey kakin played against them
and play this move G4 so I hope that
young Agata has something planned
against the very very aggressive
tatv because she knows how to attack and
she loves to attack so we have this wild
position on the board right now wow
thank you
Maurice remarkable young ladies and I
believe we have a telephone call we do
have another call so uh let's uh let's
find out who's calling and where they're
calling
from hello hello hey hey hey uh I'm
Jason from Atlanta hi Jason hey okay my
question and first off let me say I'm a
big Nakamura fan so I don't want my
question to seem like uh I'm a troll you
know looking to hurt Nakamura at all but
um I find it interesting that there
there wasn't that much uh media
attention to his Jadu like it almost
seems um I know he just lost his mind
for a second and he was like you know he
saw that he was you know basically
stepping into mate there was nothing he
could do and and instantly said you do
but it seemed like I'm not suggesting
that he should you know like be conted
and be crying on the TV or anything but
it does seem like there wasn't that much
media coverage for what he did I mean it
just seemed like such a bush League
thing to do for for such a professional
and for at the time you know the leader
of us chess um big fan of his big fan of
you guys and all hang up and listen to
you all right thank you Jason okay what
uh the caller Jason was referring to is
what took place in uh
Moscow uh the candidates tournament in
Hikaru nakamuro was facing leavon
aronian hararo had been under great deal
of pressure it was a pawn down in a rook
ending he had been defending for hour
after hour and at a certain moment
hikaro grabbed his King touched his King
clearly intended to make the move King
f8 realized who his Horror oh my gosh
that move is losing and basically had
you know the single moment where he sets
you do you're supposed to say should do
before you make the move so he clearly
uh violated the rules and was required
of course to move as king and that it
didn't really get that much prominence
in the media according to Jason it it
Hikaru is an extraordinarily Fair player
I believe he's never trying to disturb
his opponents or to get an edge or
something like that an illicit advantage
and um it was really really out of
character and he just I want to say
cracked under the pressure a bit there
it was just a
momentary thing and um well he wasn't
contrite about it he just said no big
deal it kind of fluffed it off but it
was it was bad for him yeah I mean it's
kind of like if somebody is interested
it's one of those things where if you
cover it you definitely bring more
attention to it and it's like definitely
not making it worse so you kind of have
to be interested in it and think that
it's a really big deal or that it's
somehow like a pattern or a problem so
and it's definitely not a pattern or a
problem definitely not that was just you
know this one time you know cracking
under the pressure what can you say but
he he is right you're absolutely right
that sometimes um because the Chess
World is such a small place it's
possible for um journalism and you know
fans to be the same people and there's
sometimes like a conflict there but I
think one of the great things that's
happening in chess now is that it's
becoming a bit more professional and big
and so you do see like some more
separation of roles and I'm really
excited about that well me too but I I
would even go further and say there's so
many more bloggers who are out there you
know before you had a magazine that had
so much space you could only give so
many opinions and editorial content now
you're seeing a really wide swath of uh
opinions with so many uh chess websites
that things like this really
come to the four if you didn't have the
internet maybe it would never have been
reported in the official bulletins you
would never know anything about it right
so it's uh it's a it's a good and
exciting world right now for chass
nothing is going to go unnotice that's
the point Maurice your thoughts well I
think it was covered I think that it was
covered it was given the kind of
coverage that people thought it was due
uh he ended up losing the game anyway I
think that if he had ended up winning
the game if he had had a positive result
you remember when Gary Kasparov had
something similar happened to him
against Judith pogar there was absolute
consternation by a lot of players uh by
by a lot of journalists and Judith pogar
said you know I don't think it was fair
what happened in the game so there was
more controversy but in this case
because aronian ended up winning the
game it's like okay the guy was under
pressure and he fell into something he
did something wrong and he got punished
for it so it seemed like he got his just
desserts in some way because he end up
losing the game anyway so why Mak such a
big deal about it it didn't seem like
anything dramatically unfair happened as
a result of his actions it all just
actually made him suffer more than
anything else and I don't think for
example like journalists common
journalists who don't know anything
about Chess would ever pick up a story
like that because it just sounds like
about what touch move Jad do what's that
about so different kind of thing now he
has a position against Alexander
Linderman and this is interesting
because he has sacrificed a pawn in the
opening for compensation he clearly has
that he's got a great Bishop along this
long diagonal he's got a centralized
Knight clear lead in development and
looking to make some hay in this game so
this is a nice position for him uh we
the engines are saying that this
position is more or less equal but looks
like the kind of position Nakamura wants
and take a look at this one another
position where a pawn sack has happened
Alexander shabalov who's won this
Championship four times as well he knows
how to sack pawns shaba as we like to
call him knows how to give away pawns
for compensation r Robson is playing
here and this game actually was very
interesting up to this point let's just
back up actually to the opening this
move the pawn sacrifice right on move
five Bishop G2 B5 cementing that pawn
castles developing the bishop but now E4
taking over the center of the board
Bishop to E7 E5 and now Knight D5 Knight
E4 and as the game progressed Bishop to
G5 looking to get this D6 square and
after castles hey my knight goes to D6
anyway you cannot capture it of course
because of this pin against your queen
now Bishop takes G5 Knight takes B7
Queen to E7 then A4 and now just
dropping the bishop back to secure
square a secure Square in 86 opposite
colored Bishops that's one feature we
have to pay attention to this unusual
constellation of Pawns on this side
another I mean well actually it's a
normal constellation with a Pawn on A4
but check out that Knight on B7 it looks
funky just hanging out like hey I'm in
your living room and I'm watching TV
watching a game I'm just here not often
you see a knight sitting there just even
for one more move you would have
expected a knight to back out
immediately after grabbing the bishop
but it's uh it looks kind of comfortable
on B7 of course it can always go back to
D6 so looking for some counterplay is
shabalov in this line and I think that
it's an interesting line shabalov now
the oldest player in the competition and
last I believe it was last year when he
won when he was also inducted into the
Hall of Fame he had that same attitude
that g did he was like well I'm not done
coming to these US championships yet I'm
going to be in the mix and you could
tell shaba is a longtime Gladiator and
he's got his game face on right now
that's right I mean shabalov actually
didn't play last year he just came to
accept his award exactly and um because
it's so difficult to qualify that even
somebody is talented and high rated as
him he he won by virtue of winning the
US Open precisely that's what got him
into the event just so exciting to see
him back here because he's just got such
a very exciting style of play and that's
one of the reasons that even though he
was often not the highest rated player
he he won so many championships when I
was playing uh in the game uh it wasn't
just shabalov or Shabba it was Shabba
the hun because he was a Head Hunter he
would come after you white or black and
he was really noted for his
uncompromising uh play at the board and
he still got that same uh desire of uh
of Victory still got it Go sha he he has
just captured on B5 of course we've got
a lot of local fans here of grandmas Ray
Robson because he is a local Webster
univers U they and a shout out to
Webster for once again winning the uh
national uh Championship uh they won the
final four in New York two week a
weekend ago or so that's right yeah that
was in New York City Arena Crush Was
commentating Susan Polgar was in town
there's a there's a story by Al Lawrence
on the US chess organization website
uschess.org so uh you can check that out
just a great event um we do have another
phone call so it's great you guys are
all calling in so early in the
tournament we hope you'll stay with us
the whole two weeks good questions yeah
hello hi um am I on yes you are you're
on what's your name and where you
calling my name is uh Max from Georgia
I'm big fan of you guys so my question
is uh it seems likely that Asha Chandra
is one of the youngest players and by
far the lowest rated player is going to
be the player that you need to beat if
you want to win the tournament so does
it make more sense for someone like
shanki who's one of the higher rated
players one of the more favored players
to play a sharp opening where the young
player may have some chances to outplay
them at tactical moments or a slow
grinding opening like a closed Catalan
where he having more experience can
outplay the younger player uh thanks for
answering great question once again I
think that this is always the uh the
tough part of the scale of course when
you're a favorite in the in the tour
tournament and you're playing against a
lower rated uh player you are targeting
that player no doubts about it and you
want to win a game where you know you
never give your opponent a chance uh the
problem is that today thanks to the
computer thanks to preparation it's
really easy uh to prepare really well
and get a good defensive position and
then how much risk are you willing to
take well clearly uh to grab the early
initiative uh Sam sacrificed upon and
he's putting as much pressure as he can
on his opponent and it's up to Shandra
to now diffuse the pressure and if he's
up to the task sometimes you just got to
tip your hat and say to your opponent
good game well the other thing is Sam is
just a got to look at his own style if
you're somebody like hikaro Nakamura and
you have a super Universal style and you
can play all sorts of different things
and the question might be more
applicable but I feel like Sam really
does excellently attacking the and
theoretic enj it much more yes yeah he
feels most comfortable that's his game
yeah so take the Young G on his own
territory with the white pieces um I
think Sam's um kind of he seems like the
kind of guy who'd be happy about the
momentum of starting with white against
the lowest rated player in the field and
we'll see if he can live up to that but
um of course expecting great things from
aot not only in this tournament but but
in the future as well and and believe me
winning the US junior Championship these
days is no easy task it's never it's
never been easy but uh to get here he
deserves his place and I hope he feels
that confidence but I know what it means
to have the butterflies in your first US
Championship it's it's it's a big uh
tough test now we do have a question
coming in from the
oldfashioned old school 10 years old
technology the Twitter um actually uh
friend from New York City John Fernandez
he asks it's been a long time maybe
never since we we had three top 10
players in the world in the US chess
Champs how excited are we a shout out to
John uh thank you and again great
question as Maurice was mentioning if
you go back to the 30s and 40s you had
Ruben fine and Sammy rfy those were two
Americans in the top 10 then you had uh
Bobby fiser and Sammy rfy in the 60s two
players in the top 10 in the 90s it was
myself and got kamsky but this is the
first time ever the United States has
had three players in the top 10 with all
three participating in the US
championships making it by far the
strongest us Championship ever and um
yeah I I just think it's marvelous this
is a golden period for chess in the
United States very excited and one of
the cool things about it is that I
always love the US Championship seeing
the new faces and the kind of violent
battles that sometimes result against a
lower rated play against a higher rated
but I feel that the singfield cup was
taking a little bit of the Sun from this
tournament because it was just all the
superstars right so now that we have the
three of the top 10 in the world it
almost feels like a grand PRI doesn't it
you know yeah Grand chest I mean yeah so
I feel like we can get that same
International Market um that we get for
the singfield cup and that's what really
makes it exciting that I think the world
is watching the US Chess Championship
now yeah and Maurice some insights
absolutely some interesting things
happening but none more interesting that
I could find than the game between our
seven time champion and by the way let's
point out Arena Crush not only has won
the title seven times she's won the last
four in a row wow this one is like
putting her stamp on History having won
four titles in a row despite having Anna
Zony in the competition okay last year
Anna wasn't there but she was there in
previous years and arena is saying I'm
making a bit to be the greatest women
player in the history of the Women's
Championship she is actually chasing the
Chella gresser who had won nine titles
in her time but Arena wants to get that
next number and she has made it very
clear she wants 10 she wants to make
sure that she wins it all it's very much
within her reach in the next five or six
years to add another three titles but
today may not be the day that she really
liked so much because she did play that
natural move remember I told you the
engin saw other moves but humans don't
look at those moves the move Rook A8 was
the move in fact that Arena played and
remember I told you this was the move I
saw right away as a natural move because
you want to play for C5 that's a natural
idea and the engines wanted to play a
rook to E8 instead that didn't look very
natural at all from a positional point
of view so enen went for the natural
move but Katarina did not stop this idea
she did not find the move Knight A4 with
the sacrificial Knight C5 concept that
the engines did see and that engines are
giving 84 big Edge however she played
another move before before before big
time oh hold on I hear I hear a
confession of boo in my ear I'm sorry is
that is something happening yes we got
Fabiana oh K is in the confessional
booth and I heard it I'm sorry came
bother me there okay B4 had was played
and similar idea stopping the move C5
but this Pawn is a little bit risky on
this square of course you can't touch
the pawn right now because you just die
I mean we saw this line before with this
check King over and queen here and
that's all she wrote so B4 but Arena
responded with the move C5 now trying to
make it happen and now bc5 has in fact
been played in the game and now you
still can't take on the C5 square but
arena UNC Knight to E4 so down upon Pawn
she is and trying to get get the pawn
back the position has absolutely
exploded very sharp moment what's going
to happen is black going to get equality
or is white going to be able to keep the
edge according to the engines Queen E3
only gives a slight Edge to White here
after Rook to C8 although I'm curious to
know what happens if you try to get your
Pawn back it looks as though there's
going to be some tactical issues No in
fact the injes are not saying too much
after Bishop takes Bishop takes here
because your Bishop is hanging and out
takes on H7 with check King takes Queen
to Queen takes on D4 and down a pawn in
this line yes this line Looks bananas
absolutely white is up a pawn for the
moment you could trade queens and stay
up a pawn you're going have to fight
this bishop against this Knight but I
don't know it looks like white should be
okay here I know you're an old pawn
grubber this line looks good for white
maybe not enough to say clear decisive
Advantage but it looks as though arena
is mixing it up now after having played
a dubious move in the opening takes on
D5 she's going to have to really play
precisely From This Moment forward if
she's going to stay in this game because
white is definitely hunting thank you
Maurice I I I I I I really like the move
night4 by aren I think she's fighting
back very well and the players seem to
miss that little Nuance but uh we have a
very interesting moment Fabiana caruana
the uh number one seed has gone into the
confessional and he had something to
confess let's hear what he had to
say um all right not sure if it's
starting
yet uh I'm actually not here to discuss
my game uh this is a confessional Booth
so I'm here to confess my undying love
for Lawrence
Trent um also a quick shout out to
Alexandra and
uh yeah like position looks pretty good
I think I'm I'm not sure if B3 is Theory
or what it is but it looked very logical
to get the bishop on the diagonal and
um yeah I don't see a clear way for him
to easily develop so I think I have a
bit of an advantage but we'll
see okay what kind of
prop for those that you don't know
understand that Lawrence Tren of course
is the manager of Fabiano and Abby must
have lost a big bat a big b big that he
had to go into the always to State what
he just stated because there's no way he
would have done that voluntarily he
cannot stand Lawrence and losing to
Lawrence in fact they had a bet at
dinner last night right that Lawrence
was so disgusted that that that Fabiano
what was the bet he's he bet something
we were talking politics or I forget
what it was anyway there's a bet
Lawrence was so disgusted at Fabiano for
the bet he he was so sure that Fabiano
was wrong right in this bet that he took
a dollar out of his pocket and threw it
at at fabbi and said here just take the
dollar I don't care that I'm right it's
just just on the principle of it and
these two they argue about everything
it's incredible that that he has him as
his manager because they argue about
everything they're always going at it
clearly it's the kind of LoveHate
relationship and fabbi must have lost a
serious bet if he's going to go in there
and pledgees un dying love to laen
amazing amazing situation we can't wait
to find out from Lawrence what made him
his charge be forced to make such a
statement and then you mentioned
Alexandria which yeah it's disappointing
some of the female
fanss where did she say Alexander do you
you have any insight on that J that was
kind of buried right the undying love
and then it's like then switch the real
f a shout out toand yeah the shout out
like he's trying to he's trying to make
this like outrageous thing and then
slide in the real meaning it's like a
code letter like a letter from you know
letter from prison where well the
confessional two like when when when we
thought up the confessional uh Booth uh
we didn't anticipate that one coming by
the way he mentioned that he thought he
had a better game which is kind of
interesting since uh what varujan did
was so surprising and original uh that
uh he uh Fabby is satisfied with his
position he thought he stood better I'm
not so sure I agree with him I'm going
to have to go with uh Maurice to get
what the chess engine says let's see
against this enterprising setup by VAR
as black VAR has induced white to play
this very weakening move F2 F3 gets in
the way of this Knight on on G1 the game
went Knight B8 D7 G4 another weakening
move on the king side little in between
move there by black so that and this was
the move sorry uh this was the move that
Fabby credited himself with he said like
after B3 he felt good about his position
how did the game continue the bishop
dropped back to C8 so that VAR could
easily recapture this Pawn on
D5 Fabby just continued with his natural
piece development just played the move
Queen E2 E6 very sensibly defending the
Knight on D5 opening up the Bishop on f8
castles and since this bishop on C8
doesn't have a real life we've just seen
the move B7 B6 and this is where we
stand with white to play now I'm pretty
sure that Fabby is eyeballing this
opportunity to play F3 F4 with the very
straightforward idea of you know F5 and
blow open uh the situation in the center
After All Black's King is still in the
Center we're told to to Castle early and
and Tuck the king away Castle early and
often and your idea that if I capture
and just play back to D5 precisely that
was the I'm sure that this is what Fabby
is calculating something along the lines
of Knight takes F4 Queen to E4 the
Knight drops back because of the double
threat uh Knight F3 now obviously I've
got ideas like Bishop B5 check and
Knight E5 on my agenda quite frankly I'm
changing my opinion I really like Fab's
attacking chances I mean there's nothing
about this position that I find
appealing for white uh if I can go to
Maurice this has been a wild has Fabby
gotten his opening
Advantage I think he has and what's
intriguing about this position is this
in this position the engines really
think that white has nothing uh the
engines believe that after the move H5
which is a quite rambunctious move in
this position attacking the pawn the
move G5 looks natural but Knight takes
and now in this position you could trade
off but you've weakened the F5 square
and maybe you don't have much Me And My
Crazy attacking stuff I want to play the
move G6 but the engines are claiming
forget it that's not leading anywhere
although I'd be a little bit afraid of
this Pawn landed on G6 and and sure VAR
is too the move Bishop to B2 Knight
takes on D5 Knight takes Knight takes
Queen to E2 and now E6 and what do I
find interesting about this position yes
after the move castles it sort of
reminds you of another opening doesn't
it it's kind of looking like a French
like like VAR got his French after all
his Bishop came out and went back home
and he buried it with the move E6 and
now he's a little bit of a tempy behind
in the lines of the French where black
does play the move B6 and Bishop to B7
so I think that this line is difficult
for him for sure uh if you're looking at
it widest castles two Bishops aiming
down the board and the engines are also
saying hey this Knight can actually come
to H3 in this position maybe a move like
H4 is a thought maybe a move
like even the move Knight H3 is
interesting no need to sacrifice when
you can just play F4 and and get
everybody in the party and then put your
knight on G5 and just play chess that's
one line and yet another line after this
move is the move you suggested the move
F4 so everything looks like it's lining
up for white right now and black is not
showing anything usually you want to
oppose the Bishops these Bishops this
one is not really doing anything much
but how do you blunt the effect of this
guy this guy's hitting G7 in the long
term how does black develop the pieces
you can bring the Knight back to F6
because G5 is definitely going to happen
at some point this bishop can't develop
I think that VAR has mishandled this one
and against a player like Fabiano Carana
this could be real trouble for him thank
you Maurice and we have another the call
that's right we got another call so tell
us uh your name and where you're calling
from
hello hey how are you
fine wonderful my name is Derek and I'm
calling from I'm calling from Virginia
um my question is that um I'm kind of
new to chess but I love you guys love
what you're doing uh watch the United
States Chess Championship every year big
fan um my question is do you think it's
time for feed day to reconsider the GM
title or even add another title such as
super GM with players such as Magnus
andaru and some of these other players
that are just getting way up there it
seems like there's a a clear distinction
between their level of play and maybe a
new grandmas um and so just wanted to
know what you guys think and I'll shut
up and let you answer now thank you so
much thank you for the question Derek
yes uh without question I agree at one
time the title of Grandmaster really
seemed to be something extraordinarily
exclusive I remember back in 19 um 87
when we founded Gary casparo founded the
Grandmasters
Association um there was
120 Grand Masters worldwide and about a
third of them a quarter of them were
basically retired so it was a very very
exclusive club today there's about 1,400
Grand Masters
and um there is a there's a quantitative
qualitative difference between the top
10 players that we're seeing here today
and the Thousand or so Grand Masters
whether you can use somehow super
Grandmaster really doesn't work for me
you know there could or should be a
title maybe that is the Providence of
those who playing candidates anybody
who's ever played at least in the
candidates deserves there's something
that's quite exclusive and well makes
them world class so yes I do believe
that uh the the title of grandm has kind
of
been reduced I have mixed feelings
because I think from the popular culture
people who don't really play chess
you've kind of reached the Pinnacle with
Grandmaster it has like such a it sounds
so great it Malu and it also like it
sounds really impressive so it's like
feel like it's a bit harder to do better
than that and since a lot of these
people who work so hard in their game
grandmas is that first step to becoming
more famous and like and to to showing
their friends and their family that this
this little game they're playing um
they've reached this this amazing status
So within the Chess World we already
have the 2700 chess website and we
always have we already have these like
readings and rankings whereas like to
the outside Chess World I think the
grandmas is so perfect it's kind of hard
to do better yeah no it's a perfect
title uh question is has has it
lost uh this Elite status that it used
to Me Maybe in the Chess World but I
think in the popular culture you're not
going to get better than that term
Maurice you can break the
tie well I you know sitting on that
question I do have mixed feelings as
well the main thing is that when you
think about it the top players they're
definitely way I mean I wouldn't even
want to walk in the same room almost
with guys like crom Nick and Carlson and
and Fabby and all those guys I'm I'm
happy to just sit and watch their games
that they even let me do it they're
they're so far ahead uh but I agree with
Jen at the same time that Grandmaster
title to get The Grandmaster title is
still hard work it's not like it's easy
to do and the grandm you see coming up
again and again these players are rough
I mean they're really like serious
hardcore players they're not the elite
of the elite and it's kind of like if
you think about sports in the NBA you
have your All Stars right you have your
LeBron James James your Steph Curry's th
the Dwayne Wades those are the cream of
the cream of the crop but everybody else
even all those Benchwarmers they pro
ball players and to get into the pros is
really something meaningful so you could
create like an All-Star kind of class if
you will but I think people know that
already that these are professional ball
players and then they're the allstars
and to to call them something different
may not make any sense except when you
know you have these All-Star
competitions uh what use will it serve
and also if you think about the PHD uh
for example the PHD title in education
when you're PhD you're PhD I mean there
are people who may be far and ahead and
been phds for years and have a lot more
knowledge than someone who's just gotten
that title but it's still a pretty
prestigious title so it's hard for me I
do see distinction the caller is making
for sure and we all are in awe of those
super elite players The Grandmaster
title does seem like a level you have
attained and a level that you can go far
beyond even after you've gotten that
title it's like the black belt in karate
you could be a black Bel about you could
be a second degree fourth degree fifth
degree I guess in karate you do make the
distinction as you go up along the way I
don't have the right name for it but
maybe super grandmas is just enough uh
for maybe players over
2700 I don't know if the tie was broken
I I didn't I my maybe you guys can
hashtag us at us chess Champs and uh
give us some more feedback we've getting
a lot of great tweets and a lot of great
phone calls we want to keep this
interaction going so we will be back in
just a few minutes just enough time to
come up with the perfect question for
the three of us as the game heat
[Music]
up you could fly to
Venice or
Paris or even
Copenhagen you could fly all over the
world but
why when you could just come to St
Louis your trip begins at explor
louis.com
[Music]
should
welcome back to the 2016 US chess
championships and US Women's we've
already got action packed round one here
including Bano carolana who confessed
that he has an undying love for his
manager or Lawrence Trent and might be
confessing too soon that he's executing
cruel and unusual punishment in this
game because he does look to be having
some fun here against bar no question
the game definitely heated up and he
said in his confession that he really
liked his position and I must say that I
did too uh when we left it and by the
way we were on break we couldn't help
but going over this game mace and I were
uh debating the uh position Knight H3
was played I had
you angled for an early F4 but uh Knight
H3 supported the move F4 and from all
appearances it looks great for white
this uh Bishop on B2 that Maurice had
said you know like how are you going to
Def diffuse the power of this bishop
which is hitting this Pawn on G7 well
black may be walking a tight rope here
but I'm spanking down the move Queen H4
and I'm going to turn it over to Maurice
because I think that's the most
challenging move you can't just sit back
and defend
Maurice yes yes you know unfortunately
these stupid engines they come up with
stuff you look at a nice looking move
like Queen to H4 looks like a
challenging move the only thing about it
is that black pieces do seem very
disjointed I'm telling that story of
course only after the fact but you can
somewhat see it still white is perfectly
developed except for this Knight this is
the only problem in White's position the
Bishops are beautiful the king is
castled he's got pawns theming down the
board black has only two pieces out the
third one just appeared on the H4 Square
far apart you look at the queen here and
the bishop here they don't look like
they're harmonizing but there's specific
tactics what's happening on the F4
Square the Knight is hanging what's the
deal how you going to hold all of this
together well there are certain
defensive moves you could play like
Queen F3 for example but the engines
give ignore a whole thing and play the
move Knight to G5 and bury this queen on
the H4 Square now this queen has nowhere
to go your argument now might be well
what's the deal what about Knight takes
on F4 isn't that attacking the queen and
attacking the Knight on the G5 Square
well here's the little tickle Bishop to
B5 check very specific sometimes it's
all about calculation it has nothing to
do with necessarily positional play and
all the niceties we're explaining
sometimes it's just does it work or
doesn't it and you have to look at the
forced moves and this forced move Bishop
to B5 check questions that King right
now at the moment and if black plays the
natural C6 and now three white pieces
are hanging the bishop here the queen
here and the Knight on G5 well black
plays the counter shot sorry white does
Queen to F3 hello now attacking this
Knight saving the queen of course and
pinning this Pawn to this bishop along
this long diagonal and this Pawn is on
heavy fire this Knight of course is
hanging how do you defend it off this KN
is also pinned by the way dare not move
because F7 is hanging to the queen and
that is all she wrote as far as the
engines are concerned you're busted as
black your pieces are silly and white is
just crawling all over black now it's
hard to even suggest the next move in
this position maybe maybe what let's try
Queen takes Knight just to show this
line Bishop takes check and you cannot
capture back you're going to lose your
Bishop in the line if you capture back
Queen takes and there goes your Rook so
that line doesn't work it's hard for me
to even suggest what you should do now
because it doesn't look as though there
are any moves to suggest it just looks
like white is completely crushing so
this position after Bishop to B5 check
this is the flying the ointment hitting
the king if the king let's say goes here
then suddenly the move Queen to E5 and
the only thing you're attacking is this
Rook but who cares c7's hanging there
goes the King two much Firepower in this
position yes Queen H4 better not appear
on the board or we're going to see a
miniature happen in this game I think
VAR will avoid that notice that his
pieces are not quite right but he's
studying the position now and the
do give the move Queen to E7 as the most
solid move here but I don't like the
fact after Queen to E7 you still haven't
solve this problem with the G7 Pawn the
Engel only giving a slight Edge though
only a slight Edge to White in this
position saying that white can't get
anything
going I I would just feel uncomfortable
if I had black in this position we'll
see when you play the French sometimes
you got to face him this comfort and
meanwhile we've got some really big news
in the Wesley so got a csking game we
talked about that Knight coming to F5
and we have a knight sacrificed on that
square we got to get to that game fast
you know you mentioned it that all of
the top seeds got the extra white and
Wesley so and Fabiano Carana are showing
what white means today because they are
coming at their opponents I mean look at
this Knight to F5 move if we go back
just a couple moves even though um Dak
kamsky took pains to um prevent the
Knight F5 maneuver um Wesley is is
hammering down in the age6 pawn and
trying to play it anyway and and that's
what happened well like you were saying
actually uh that when you play Blitz you
get your knight to G3 you put your
knight on F5 and the guy collapses well
there you go well truly uh White by all
three favorites uh notice that they've
sacrificed in every game hikaro
sacrificed a pawn
um uh well okay here we go let's just
get let's take a look yes so all of
these are pretty normal moves that you
might expect or see in a Brer Knight H4
telegraphing the obvious intent of uh
occupying the F5 Square as well as
releasing the F Pawn uh you see this
opportunities to play F4 in the near
future got came back Queen d8 by the way
trying to intimidate white and suggest
Oops I did something wrong boy yeah you
might be able to be trying to play like
takes on D4 and then Knight takes E4 and
embarrass the queen on H4 or something
like that exactly sorry I I'm going to
have to send it back to mauricea I hit
the wrong
key I sure did I lost my board oh my
goodness well what's interesting about
this position is you seem like you just
have a solid cool calm Brier like black
has gotten some Center nice calm Bishop
two knights unlike in the game with
akobian this game black has every single
piece in the game and has gotten
everything you would want with the black
pieces except the next couple of moves
Knight H4 starting to suggest some
action say okay will you break the
tension in the center the engines are
giving takes as the best move followed
by C5 very specific action take on D4
here and then follow with C5 and
suddenly that Hedgehog setup that black
has comes to life the Hedgehog means
that the pawn the position you stay back
a little bit and then if when the time
happens you explode out and in this
position it looks as though black is
fine according to the Ines the Knight
has left the center and that was the
recipe in this position that just seems
very typical however instead of playing
that way got to win for solidity with
the move Queen to d8 and now this
allowed this Tempo Queen to C1 hitting
the pawn still staying very solid not
trying to do anything funny and Bam out
of of nowhere Knight F5 appears on the
board it just shows that it just takes a
moment just a moment of hesitation for
you to go from equal or maybe slightly
better to worse that's just the nature
of our game folks chess is rough Knight
F5 and the engines are saying after gf5
Knight takes F5 that white is clearly
better down a piece for only one Pawn
the injes already giving white a plus
one advantage that can't be right when
you're playing black the black pieces
and the main point is that Knight on F5
the Knight Gary Kasparov uh used to be
his calling card sacrificing a pawn for
it here Wesley a sacrifice a piece and
what do you do about this Pawn hanging
on the A6 Square it looks as though you
don't have enough five power after the
move Knight back to G8 but the problem
is this D6 Pawn Knight takes D6 and I'm
reminded once again Yasser do you
remember that game was it game two of a
match I think you wrote about the world
championship match that kaspar played in
New York kaspar of carpov New York Leon
was this 1990 1990 1990 right the world
championship match where Kasparov
sacrificed on H6 you made some bet that
the sacrifice wasn't sound only to find
out later that the sacrifice was pretty
good and it would and it involved a
similar idea that this well he didn't
get to he did actually sacrifice on H6
but later was this Fork this kind of
fork in the game that got him some
material back and showed that he had
real confidence and in this case I think
you wouldn't have made any bet in this
position this one looks even better than
the one Kasparov did back in that
classic game so this Pawn you either you
give this one up or this one up but
either one looks terrible and black
seems like he's in some bit of trouble
trying to figure out how to defend here
the engines are giving a move like Rook
to E6 and now white can consider the
move D5 a pawn you just don't want to
take because look at that Bishop open up
along the long diagonal
this position is rough it looks like got
is in deep trouble it's only moved 23 in
the game but it looks as though he's
running out of defensive resources and
got I think feels it right now Wesley so
hunting the great four-time Champion
gakamsky he looks like he's in a lot of
trouble that's right I mean this is why
we play the Roy Lopez dream come true
right yeah well you're supposed to play
the RO Lopez because you want to play
really solid and that single as Maurice
was saying that window of opportunity
opened up with the move queen d8 that
may be uh the big mistake instead of
capturing capturing playing
C5 um by the way black did play Rook E6
and I love that move D5 so beautiful
because the bishop on C2 not working at
all exactly so you really want to open
up uh the bishop on C2 so we have seen
the move Rook E6 Maurice did mention D5
and the whole idea of D5 uh this bishop
on C2 lurking in Ambush ready to give a
a spanking uh discover Che uh wow
five-time US champion godsky in serious
trouble in this opening round right and
we have a caller yeah let's take a call
so tell us who you are and where you're
calling from and of course your burning
question uh yes I am Joshua from
Tennessee and I've been a lifelong fan
of Gaz ever since I was little
thank you for writing the play winning
chess series by the way thank
you second congrats Maurice on getting
into the Hall of Fame thank you very
much sir yes and congratulations to you
Jen for being Hood at both chess and
poker did we pay this guy to
call yes we're all gonna write you a
right after the show this is where it
gets bad now the question but all right
anyway there was a previous caller that
was talking about grandm in the
disparity of the level of play among
people with the grandm title yes I was
watching on chess 24 and one of the
commenters there said something maybe
something like a black belt system would
work for it like say another degree of
grandm for every 100 points of C rating
so second third fourth like Magnus
Carlson h I was wondering if that would
be worth
consideration and the other thing is I
plan on actually coming to St Louis this
weekend to hit round three in person it
would be awesome to run into some of the
people up there especially you Yer I've
been wanting to beet you since I was
eight years old well there you go I
promise if you do make it to St Louis uh
we'll go we'll go out and have some
drinks together on me all right and
bring no on me sir a man thank you so
much one more thing and I'll hang up yes
where are you going to open your own
Twitter account what am I going to open
not likely I don't think yaser owns a
cell
phone all right I'll hang up and listen
thank you for the call thank you thank
you caller boy that was great boy we're
we're all going to get out our
checkbooks on this one you're going to
get a dogar copy of a winning chess
moves and you're going to have to sign
it degree grandmas third degree
Grandmaster second degree it's not a bad
idea not a bad idea bad idea one of the
best I actually have ever heard and it
comes off it trips easily as well yes
because people will still say so what's
a grandmas and then you'll hear first
degree second degree third degree and
like okay so what's a Grandmaster and
it'll still be the same kind of
description we always have to do what
what a Grandmaster is I think it's not a
bad idea yeah you we have to get used to
it but I think it's a pretty good idea
interesting idea indeed and Dr jeie
singfield who's also a a uh black belt
and Judo I believe um has also talked
about that kind of like belted ranking
system for children oh yeah know because
it's cuz she's her idea is like it's
kind of negative to be like an e player
like that's not I hate the ABCDs of
Chess people don't really use it
terrible to be fair people don't really
use it anymore these days it's like it
exists but people usually talk about
their actual rating and about the the
upward trend of it exactly but then I
like the kind of positivity of like a
colored system yes the much much better
and uh oh somebody also wrote into our
Twitter um hashtag being us chess Champs
Larry War um Larry War he said that
Grandmaster Elite would be a good title
for super Grandmaster I do like that
that definitely seems less goofy super
Grandmaster sounds a little goofy right
I get the Superman comic thing going
there but Elite grandmas something very
nice
and cool about that I like that Maurice
you wanted to show was that Knight F5
sacrifice that Gary Kasparov executed
well it actually wasn't the Knight F5
sacrifice it was the pattern again in a
Roy Lopez something similar happening
with the pressure look at the queen take
a look we'll make some similarities I
pulled this up on chess Bas look at that
Queen on C1 that Bishop on this diagonal
see the queen here the bishop on the
diagonal the pressure on the 86 point in
this position it actually if I go back
one move to this position after C6 we
have it the same thing and if we switch
over to the board with Wesley so here's
that Queen and that Bishop along the
long diagonal very similar so now just
going back to the Gary Kasparov game
again look it's the bishop on B1 a king
on H7 we have the same idea so my memory
just flashed back to that game back in
1990 to this position where Gary played
the move Knight to G4 attacking that
pawn adding some pressure daring the
capture on this Square opening the H
file allowing the king to move over and
a rook to put pressure down instead kn
to G8 and it was in this position y that
you may that bet Bishop takes on H6 was
played he had other moves but he decided
to go for this line that Gary Kasparov
against his Nemesis karpov takes takes
takes takes and now Knight takes D6 a
fork on the D6 Square forking these two
pieces it was a tricky position Queen B6
Knight takes C8 Queen takes D4 check
King H1 and queen d8 trapping the Knight
white ended up getting a rook this
Knight has to go off the board so it was
a que a rook against two pieces against
a knight and a bishop you didn't like
this position YZ for Kasparov but he
proved correct after a few moves Rook D1
Queen E8 and queen G5 ker plunk and the
black pieces were to scattered they were
two separated with the Rook landing on
the d8 Square and it was just all Mayhem
for black to defend there were some
chances but it showed that White's
sacrifice was sound it was unclear to
the eye right away but turned out to be
sound in the long run if we jump to this
game now similar kind of idea the Knight
goes to F5 takes and takes maybe not
right away you see it you see the
pressure here but then you look over the
D6 Square we see a similar type of Fork
Landing on that square the threat to
maybe take this bishop and take this
Pawn as well the long diagonal bishop
and the move Rook to E6 was played in
the game and it's this moment that
Wesley so is studying he could just take
on 86 that's one way to go the engines
really like that move D5 is also another
move in the position but just strange of
those kinds of ideas ever present I
think considering all that you've got to
say white has a huge Edge right now but
what will he play will he go
for crunch and Munch take on A6 or will
he blast open the position with D5 both
look sexy and I have the feeling that
Wesley so is just studying the
possibility if he could go one and0
start the game the tournament off with a
bang with this kind of beautiful
sacrifice you know he's going to feel
good about his chances moving forward
thank you uh Maurice and I would ask you
to bring up that uh chess based position
again that what you did with that Gary
kaspar off game for just a moment Jen
you're going to love this uh after the
well first of all it was embarrassing
for me what happened was I was doing the
live commentary for the audience in the
playing Hall and some of the grand
Masters had done uh VIP commentary so I
was saying that I really like karp off's
position and Patrick Wolf and all these
Grandmasters were making a bet against
me and I was taking karp off's position
and I was explaining to the audience uh
in the playing Hall that a sucker's born
every minute you know and
uh carp off lost I lost the bet it was
terrible but I had dinner that evening
with your father Mike shahadi at petan
and I said Mike I can't believe that
karpov were going to turn to Maurice
that karpov didn't play the move Knight
G8 here and it was your dad of all
people who cleared the cobwebs and he
said yes you're busted I'll play Queen
H4 check a move I had not seen King
G7 Rook d8 now against the immediate
Rook d8 I had Queen E7 but now when I go
Queen E7 your father took my night and I
started crying and uh well he picked up
the
bill that's such a great story and you
know what this makes me really happy
about because watching that little two
minutes is going to make my dad's year
and just in case he's not watching live
you know that all the episodes are
archived on YouTube yes they are indeed
so there you go I'm I'm be sending him
that time little gold star so you put it
on a loop and if I may close that Loop
yes I was in the audience watching you
give analysis as well of course it was
in New York City uh was a young chap
aspirational uh looking to become a
Grandmaster one day and hearing all this
uh talk and the craziness of the
sacrifice was a match I followed not
only did I follow that match I followed
them to the second half in France I went
to leyon to play in the a tournament
that happened right before that the
second half of the tournament just got
to just soak it all in the the glamour
of a world championship match between
those two amazing heavyweights so this
game certainly stuck in our memories
very vividly and we have some similar
happening of course and I'm sure they're
youngsters watching us now thinking wow
look how much I'm learning from all this
commentary look at how many times I'm
refuting yaser's
variations we have one uh we have one
comment um from Twitter um DJ rule J
points out that AKA Chandra is taking an
hour on a move he actually has just
moved but you know we we took a long
break from looking at Sam shanklin's um
enterprising sacrifice and we expected
to come back to a few new moves but
actually after Bishop C4 um a spent one
hour to play the move Bishop D7 so and
to remind everybody you start with 90
minutes uh for the first 40 moves with a
30 second bonus for each move so he
spent 2third of his time on this key
moment and finally he decided on the
Move Bishop D7 so clearly uh Sam
Shanklin has put his opponent under a
lot of pressure that he had to take
two-thirds of his time on a single move
that's bad bad bad bad time management
obviously well but for for player so
strong I mean there must have been like
a specific uh variation that he just
wanted to make sure he wasn't getting
completely busted in exactly cuz if you
were busted then all the time in the
world doesn't really change anything not
at all um we also have it we also have a
a phone caller as well yes please so
let's take that call or tell us your
name and where you're from and um what's
on your
mind hello this is Vince Clen from New
Jersey hello I played Jen when she was
about 16 and I've met both Maurice and
Jaz um I'm wondering if you can tell me
if there's anything finalized about the
Kasparov match at the end whether it's a
single or double round
robin very good well thank you for your
question the caller is referring to the
idea well what we're going to do after
the US Championship the top three
finishers in the open are going to be
playing a blitz match match with Gary
Kasparov as the fourth and it'll be
around Robin uh they'll play each other
six times three each day three each day
so there'll be a two-day Blitz playoff
featuring the legend himself Gary
Kasparov against the top three finishers
uh immediately following uh the US
Championship so
be Gary wants to mix it up and that'll
be then the 28th and the 29th and we
will be doing commentary for that as
well well so that's exciting I mean BL
is just so much fun assum I mean come on
this will be so much fun we got to share
that so we're going to have a lot of fun
with that and thanks for the question
and for the plug for that super exciting
event of course Gary casprov is a big
supporter of the championship and the St
Louis chess club um and the grand chest
tour so it'll be great to have him here
um throwing some patties as yaser likes
to say exactly um do we got an update on
one of the games Maurice there are lots
of updates lots of updates I'm going to
go through one at a time the ones I'm
looking at and throw it at you and you
throw it back to me let's just play uh
catch football right now because there's
some heated action on a lot of boards
remember this board where shabalov
sacrificed a pawn against Ray Robson to
say hey I got some funky action my
knight is on your B7 Square we'll take a
look at how this game proceeded he took
on B5 and then brought his Knight back
out to the D6 Square well Ray said go
right ahead you want this Pawn take it
please and after Knight takes on B5
Queen to B 4 giving back his pawn queen
to B4 saying I'm attacking the Knight
and I'm attacking the pawn on the B2
Square now that is a serious attack this
pressure right here is Meaningful he
played Knight back to D6 and he said bam
give me this Pawn on B2 and now the move
Rook A5 a very sharp move it you start
to feel whenever I see pieces starting
to stretch themselves away from the
other pieces you feel a little bit
concerned this rook and this Knight
they're separated from the rest of the
army that makes you want
is the the for are the forces tight
enough are they coming together in the
right way and now the move KN C3
spanking that down hitting the queen and
you've got to be careful where you put
this queen check out this line this line
is crazy Queen to A1 looks like a
reasonable move trading off the Queens
on this Square so you can play Rook
takes and then you've got some nice
pressure except check this out guys
Bishop to C1 I mean that constellation
is quite unusual in a game of course if
you take on C1 right away then uh crunch
a Munch again give me that guy and then
bam with the fork so this is the line
shabalov is going to have to be careful
about Knight on C3 right now and I think
black is on move at the moment sorry
Queen to A1 has been played and we are
expecting a very interesting move Bishop
down you can even play KN check this
Pawn is alive the C Pawn's alive
I don't think white has anything here
for his as far as compensation is
concerned but the engines are saying
that there is some life in this position
for black for white that is the move
Bishop to C1 apparently you can just try
to trade off in this line and then play
Knight to E1 I'm thoroughly confused but
this of course is threat and the A7 Pawn
is going but this line is sharp because
you can now drop the Knight back to D5
guys what's going on this is a crazy
position to assess clearly it has blown
up in this game and it is black on move
after the move Queen to A1 wow I think
that when we were starting the US
championships what we were really hoping
for was exciting hard fought uh dramatic
uh chess uh well if round one is any
indication the players really have
brought it for this US championships
this is this is a great opening
round fantastic fantastic I and I'm
looking at the games across the board
I'm seeing some really double-edged
positions and I'm just looking at the
game between Alexander onuk and Jeffrey
Shang and that game is ultra sharp just
across the board uh Maurice how did um
verian how did VAR handle fabby's move
uh night F4 so remember you talk you
talk about that game gakamsky game we
still have Wesley so on move trying to
figure out what to do next which move he
likes after F4 bar played the move
Bishop to D6 trying to get his pieces
out as quickly as possible but hey you
don't have to tell anyone I think
anybody 1,800 and up maybe even 1600 and
up a lot of players are going to play F5
as soon as possible it's on the board
and the engine's giving a real Edge to
White he did not take on G7 this is
maybe something VAR might have hoped for
this was better for white as well by the
way according to the engines after
Bishop to E5 the engines like this
position but Queen to E7 looking to
Castle this way with some counterplay
you could pray for okay you might say
it's possible Fabby said forget that I'm
going to attack you I still have all the
pluses G7 still hang e still hangs E6 is
under pressure this looks good for white
wow that simple F5 and a lot of tough
decisions for VAR here early I still um
attracted to that Queen H 4 Move I'm
sure it's going to get refuted as well
let's go back to this game where Wesley
so one of our top favorites sacrificed a
peace uh against gakamsky
and um he still hasn't decided between
these two compelling choices taking an
H6 or D5 exact yeah well again I would
probably rip off this bit this Pawn on
H6 myself just because well first of all
I'm getting rid of that Pawn Shi he's
done it Play Bishop takes he's Play
Bishop H6 and now got it in the hot seat
yet again wow I just I'm not even sure I
would like to make a suggestion here 98
was what it was played actually came
quickly 98 98 what so what what exactly
is the idea on knight8 that after that
it just it's it's uncovering the rook's
defense so after Bishop G7 Knight G7
you're kind of holding the fort together
since we can't sneak in with Queen H6
precisely so this move 8 uh opens up the
Rook for the defensive task of
protecting the H6 Square not to mention
the fact that there's actually a threat
now of of playing Rook H6 and taking off
some of White's powerful pieces so the
move D5 sneaking that in not possible so
instead white played a different in
between move play the move Bishop to G5
exactly just dropping back notice how
really cramp Black's position is um okay
white has two pawns and great attacking
uh possibilities but just for black this
is a very very uncomfortable defense
despite the fact that on paper
materially speaking he's ahead I just
see that this White's position just
looks really good for sure it's not an
enviable task but uh got a known for
defensive skill so what do you think
black's going to play right now Knight
on D to F6 Knight on D to F6 maybe Queen
B6 I'm a little bit afraid if uh Wesley
didn't play the move D5 earlier I'm a
little bit afraid that uh when it comes
it's going to really really land maybe I
have to play F6 which I don't like I was
hoping you wouldn't say that I can even
play Bishop to B3 just the direct thread
of The Rook because it's actually
trapped on E6 right and you would
basically forc me in case of Bishop B3
to play the move D5 lots of tempting
possibilities for white but I'm sure
black has defensive resource
Mars the engines love these kinds of
positions and um what are they saying
what are they telling us uh they love it
we love it everybody loves this this is
a a dance uh in the park in the sunshine
when you get to sacrifice get two pawns
and then the guy has to start to gravel
with his pieces looking absolutely
ridiculous in this position he's going
to try to hold on the lines that you
guys are discussing the engines already
showing very compelling reputations for
these lines for one one example is the
move F6 looks like you know logical type
move the Rook is trapped the main
problem is The Rook no longer controls
the rank the bishop just goes back to H6
and just we just want to trade bring the
queen into the party and you're in huge
trouble this line is extremely
compelling virtually lost according to
the injuries if you play King to G8 as
one move then the move Queen D1 is
playable maybe even stronger is Rook to
E3 uhoh that guy's coming into the game
Rook a Rover to G3 and this is busto
black is lost for space this piece is a
key piece you can pick the bishop up and
throw it off the board it doesn't exist
as far as the position is concerned and
also the Knight on D7 is looking like it
doesn't exist as well Bishop G5 I
thought about this move Bishop F6 but
the engines beat me immediately with
give me the bishop I want to get to H6
so be careful what you take with if you
take back with the Rook then guess who
appears into the party queen to G5 and
it's like whoa Rooks coming nothing can
move over here everybody's tied down
amazing position it's simply over that's
how crazy this position is you can't do
anything about the Rook coming up and
over let's say for example you try to
unpin yourself with this move the Rook
just simply comes into the game Rook up
and if you try to defend with this
position here then simply check King
back and now 97 we'll go get the Rook
we'll bring the rook in and it's like
the problems are just exponentially
expanding another problem here after
Bishop G5 is if you just move the queen
away I think I was analyzing Queen to C7
in this position now Queen D1 basically
what this position comes down to is that
Bishop on B7 and also tangentially as
well the Knight on D7 but especially
this bishop you're up a piece but you're
not really up a piece until you show
your up a piece if this piece is not
working if it doesn't get into the game
C5 is not happening anytime soon because
of D5 so this piece is not really in the
game so white can actually spend time
and say your king is denuded I'm just
going to going to bring my pieces over
there concentrate my forces and you
don't have enough space along these
three ranks to defend against my
continued expansion that's exactly
what's going on just the simple fact of
black having extra material on the board
doing absolutely nothing at all and that
is leading to a lot of compelling
variations for white and Wesley is just
studying it now like a hawk seeing a
mouse and just trying to figure out how
I come down there and clutch you up and
finish this off thank you Mai
and we've got a popular show we have
another caller hello caller welcome hi
hello
hello hi this is uh jary from Palmdale
California welcome Gary Terry Gary you
guys are doing a great job I uh look at
all your guys' show even if I miss it I
was watch it on the YouTube channel so I
never miss any of them thank
you uh my question was I believe in
round five it's going to be so vers
ovian
and uh you guys remember what happened
last year do you guys think that there's
going to be some kind of a tension
between them is there going to be a
handshake and if so they you know the
game plays out do you guys think that uh
aian has a real chance of beating so
again considering a so's caliber of a
Grandmaster that was my question but uh
I'll let you guys go but if you can
answer that it'd be pretty cool thank
you thank you for the question so the
question refers to an incident that took
place at last year's uh us Championship
where Wesley had written on his scor
sheet uh an inspirational word or two
like concentrate or focus and he had
been warned by Arbiter Tony Rich
eventually he was forfeited by the
Arbiter in the game between Wesley and
VAR varujan and how is that going to
affect their round five matchup I don't
think it's going to I don't think it's
going to affect it I really think that
both of these guys are two of like the
you know obviously emotions were
probably high in that particular game
but they're really nice and seem like
the kind of forgiving types yeah so
maybe like a little bit more fire inside
but I think they they want to win every
game and I don't think either of them
are holding grudges for that they just
really don't seem like the types to me
no they'll be holding grudges uh but I
think they're professional enough that
they'll definitely shaking hands there's
no issues there uh but yeah that one
really kind of stuck in Wesley's craw I
mean I spoke I was with Wesley in vikon
this year and some
conversations and um Wesley would like a
measure of Revenge oh so var's not on
his Christmas car list no not on the a
list not not yet not one bit not at all
but that's something we'll be talking
about come round five that's right yeah
but good on you to like keep looking and
and start a circling those days where
you need to watch the entire round that
that should be every round though right
Maurice your thought yeah after the
interview he said when I interviewed him
here he said that uh akobian wasn't his
friend anymore that was he just put it
very simply so I think that yeah he's
looking to to take some serious Revenge
here at this tournament and in this
round man he's making G look like he's
not his friend either because G tried
this move Bishop to F6 it is on the
board and the engines are saying white
is now completely winning but guys this
is so interesting to look at this one
the way white wins is basically based on
one piece the strength of one Knight in
the position this night on F five what a
dominating entity on the board and
Wesley has found the computer move
Bishop takes on F6 it is currently in
the game and the engine saying this is
the dominating continuation the queen
looking to go to the G5 Square so got
instantly played Queen takes on F6
stopping the cursion of the queen only
to face the monster move D5 that's just
a huge shot in the position this Rook is
trapped on the E6 Square nowhere to go
and check out what happens if you trade
immediately Pawn takes you're still
under threat and if you play Bishop
takes on D5 now Knight back to E3 this
bishop has turned into the true Spanish
bishop and this bishop is hanging going
to drop why's going to end up a Pawn
Plus the king is just miserable this is
going to be clear technique for Wesley
so so going back to this position after
D5 maybe since you sacrifice a piece you
can play this move Rook to E7 but check
out this computer find the move
G4 G4 with a simple threat of G5 telling
the queen to leave that Rook alone I
want to grab it for free G4 a huge move
winning instantly nothing to do about
this threat The Rook can't leave the
queen can't leave nothing can help
reinforce anything just a gorgeous move
and it looks as though Wesley so has
found this continuation otherwise he
wouldn't take on F6 or maybe you would
consider it again because it things if
you can't add pressure you may not play
the line you might have relieved black
somewhat but if you have G4 with the
threat of G5 it's bye-bye it's done
matter of fact just going back one move
here the engines give Queen E3 as an
alternative saying that that's also
better for white by by a couple of Pawns
even but G4 is already saying I'm a rook
up G G4 about to win a rook so if he
finds this line and it looks like he
will have no problem finding it and the
move is on the board sorry not G4 yet D5
Rook E7 played quickly by got and all
we're waiting for now is to move G4
played it played it and he has played it
amazing quickly knew he would find it G4
is on the board this is resign we would
not doubt it if gakamsky resigned right
now Wesley looking so calm guys hello
Wesley so don't you know this is a very
uh good congratulations to gotsky on
making the World Chess Hall of Fame he's
devastated this game was was was
brilliantly played and look at Nakamura
shaking his head
Nakamura like you know why are you
giving my rivals easy points look at
disgusted that looked in knock's face
like oh my goodness or maybe like I
thought Bobby was going to be my main
competition in this tournament watch out
he's in some good form and God looks
devastated God looks like he's in shock
shaking his head he missed this move G4
unquestionably and that's going to cost
him he has no defense to G5 we can you
pull that up in the boards because that
is such a stunning move G4 because I
feel you basically need two moves for
black you need to both protect the rook
and you need to get it out of take look
at guys but look at look at got look at
recogniz stunning can't believe he's
going down this brutally it's only 28 he
has to resign there's nothing to do it's
helplessness right now we talk about
Quiet Moves the powerful Quiet Moves
well this is a quiet move but it is a
really powerful one because again as
Maurice has been pointing out this Rook
is basically defended by one piece and
one piece only it's trapped on the E7 if
you can push away that Queen uh with the
move G5 it's really it's an entire rook
and this would be a good time for the
got csky uh in round one and Wesley has
gotten up on the board maybe not not
wanting to stand sit in sit in front of
his opponent that just gotta just resign
to the fact he's about to lose round one
of the championship there's 11 rounds to
in this tournament uh he's I mean he's
got a he's just black remember yesterday
I told you I was sitting next to him and
he was concerned about who he would play
thought it was Naka then he found out
that it was Wesley and he thought no
difference it's going to be a rough game
no matter what he could not have
imagined it would be this rough a night
sacrifice on F5 followed by this
beautiful move G4 just thematic Sicilian
just beaten up in this game absolutely
and he he's just got to digest the
disaster that has happened to him right
away in the tournament damatic Roy Lopez
in fact um and we do have a comment from
Walter first who says that he loves and
confesses his undying love for Knights
on F5 referring to Fab's Undying Love
Lawrence Trent earlier right just a just
a real da dazzling start here for Wesley
and well just to mentioned that uh as
aiv uh did for us uh how the players
match up
extraordinarily uh these players Wesley
and got played three times uh really
really close matchups but amazingly
Wesley has actually won 2 and 1 half to
half and this will be three and 1 half
half so is there something about
stylistically that God just cannot
handle what Wesley brings to the table
God has got his number just like so many
of you guys who keep calling us with
your fantastic questions yeah wow and
there we have and what happens if G were
to resign when Wesley was up from the
board you don't see that too often do
you actually that happens a lot that the
the player you know like when he's gone
you know the player understands he gets
it uh I've resigned at certain moments
when my PLS are from the board and I
just wait for them to return and
congratulate them but uh Wesley uh very
very confident looking great here in
round one also looking very interesting
we talk about night sacrifices we ought
to bring up this game of hikaro Nakamura
against um Alex Lenderman I can see all
kinds of night sacrifices about about to
occur guys that other game we should
keep we should stay on because he's
going to resign any second there's
there's no move to make there's just no
move to make he's
he's just got to accept his fate and
it's just barely two hours into the
broadcast let's think about that as well
it's barely two hours into the broadcast
and he's going to be the first person to
lose on either side either the in the
championship or the Women's Championship
28 moves complete disaster has happened
to him just that quickly one off move in
the opening that Queen d8 instead of
taking on e4 and playing C5 and taking
on D4 playing C5 and G is just I mean
you just you wonder where was my mistake
if he doesn't know where the mistake is
what did I do how did this happen so in
such a disastrous way and you can see he
can't compose himself he can't think
about what to do right now this is a
great Champion gakamsky he's already
been talking about retiring that he's
passed his time uh maybe he might have a
chance but look that that looks as it
all it's sure does well Maurice has
talked about The Grandmaster curse
before is there a Hall of Fame curse a
Hall of Fame curse the moment you get
inducted into the Hall of Fame you get
spanked in the very very next game yeah
I don't think there's that
curse sorry let's not start that one
right but uh yeah this this is a PR well
chess is a brutal game and this is a
particularly uh bad loss for G because
this is one of his number one defenses
against W E4 he plays the Brer to be
solid and you know if you're going to
grind him down you're going to do it in
60 you're not supposed to do it in 28
and it's amazing that at that one slip
Queen d8 that's not a bad move it looks
pretty decent right and then suddenly
Wesley uncorks this combination that
just hits home perfectly wow we might
see one of the best games of the
tournament in the first round and to be
fair to G it's not a Hall of Fame curse
I was kidding it's a playing very well
prepared wesle so in good form with
black curse which can pretty much affect
anyone right and maybe we'll see it
affect more people in this tournament I
mean it would be great to see um
somebody like Wesley in super good form
in this tournament so that it won't be a
two- horse race guys remember remember
Wesley so had what what kind of us
championship did he have last year wow
it was horrible roller coaster it was
horrible no roller coaster I mean he's
going down he he played a a very bad
championship in the end didn't he I mean
he lost he lost some game some critical
games in that championship and uh I mean
Wesley well this is the this is the this
is not last year's results since Fabby
didn't play oh I see so you're saying
Wesley came in third Wesley came in
third he won some games he lost some
games and there it is resignation has
happened but for Wesley Wesley lost
points last year he had the embarrassing
result this year he's clear on Revenge
and he has run over gakamsky in this
game one of the 2016 championships AB I
just wanted to say it it it felt like
Wesley had a very bad tournament last
year because of the forfeit because of
the brilliant loss he had with Hikaru
Nakamura those losses stand in your mind
the truth of the matter is taking third
wasn't so bad that's true
can he was on a roller coaster right and
then just a tweak a result here or there
and he would have been in gold medal
contention but certainly what a start
for Wesley uh in this round one and we
see a lot of uh Wesley fans chiming in
Wesley is on fire and uh talking about
the power of the F5 we got some
compliments to us welcome to Elite
coverage thank you uh Jim de wild and uh
we also um have a comment from Mike
Klein over at chess.com he says that
akobian played the Scandinavian as a kid
and his only loss was against Guk in the
1996 World youth under4 wow thank you
for the throwback man wow Alexander
grishuk as we know uh one of the world's
top 10 grand Masters in the uh the uh
Grand chess tour as well as the world
Blitz Champion yeah yeah I mean it was
great to watch him and hikaro play like
a a Time scramble I mean those two are
just super fun to watch play Blitz um
we've also got a comment from the St
Louis chess club which is actually being
taken over by Grandmaster Christian
Chilla throughout the tournament so if
you're not following them already you
probably are you want to take a special
consideration to it now um finally
Grandmaster Josh Ferell is uh I said
that the that the 2750 plus guys are
like Drunken Pirates and the white
pieces of their
cutl like I like
her
yes and um yeah the the women's section
actually St Louis justess Club pointed
out these games are more balanced a lot
of times we see the opposite that
there's crazy tactics and aggression in
the women's side and um we need to look
at those first and then go over to the
championship today we've been focusing
more on the championship because the
games are insane right but of course we
have a lot of love for the women and the
ladies championship and we are going to
be pointing back to that after some of
these tactics fizzle out well we
business means being blasted with
fireworks in here the first round and we
do have a very special guest who's
getting set up in our studio we're going
to go that's right got a csky World
Chess Hall of Fame in D we've got both
of them so congratulations to Maurice
andada that you got your your shot and
some good news bad news today right well
I've got to commiserate with my fellow
Hall of Famer today I'm glad I wasn't
playing but got to you got to make those
moves it was a really amazing sacrifice
the fact that Knight F5 works so
powerfully it looked like your position
was solid looked like you achieved
everything you wanted out of this Brier
but suddenly this night on F5 was
amazingly annoying and he and it was
just simply difficult to defend yeah I
mean uh I didn't see KN H4 knight5 idea
I mean in h side of course of course I
should have taken with the bishop on A8
but is is his mic working guys I'm not
quite hearing him um I'm not sure okay
all right it's working fine sorry go
ahead yeah so in h side I should have
taken n with the bishop but then after
Knight H4 it was difficult to see
whether the exchange well the P
sacrifice would work but it seems to
really work and uh because my king on H7
is really weak I mean um I really
blunder G4 of course at the end and I
thought that um any other move maybe
Rook takes F6 would
um more problems for white I mean he has
an advantage but he still has to work
for a win but I completely miss this G4
G5 which just shows one move blunder and
then it's over pretty incredible
remarkable in a game like this you know
it's the first round you do have black
uh Black's never easy to play against
such a star player anyway do you just
shake it off like one of those days at
the office well I Was preparing for a D4
but he surprised me was E4 all of a
sudden and you know I had no preparation
for E4 and I had to try to remember what
he was trying to to prepare for and then
I realized you know because Brer is my
main opening still that he must have
prepared for this but okay still it's
it's a little bit unsettling but okay um
you know I'm a jetl I just right like
yesterday and um I'll get into the
Rhythm and I'll try to show the skills
that I'm Not Dead Yet after getting Hall
of Fame elimination but okay we'll see
well I'll let those be the last words
those are great words reassuring to us
and your fans thanks very much for
joining us thank grandm got to come
after a tough loss in round
one thank you for go thank you to G for
coming and sharing what was a very
difficult start obviously for him in his
opening round uh I didn't get a chance
to mention it myself but finally I think
I I'm about
to um come on if I can draw the game
there oh gosh there it is so check this
one out um Jennifer we got this game
between Hikaru Nakamura against
Alexander Lenderman and we can see all
kinds of sacrifices that white is
planning uh on either F7 or E6 for
example one bad move that uh Lenderman
avoided was playing Knight D7 because of
this nice sacrifice you capture on E6
whoops sorry you capture first on E6 and
then you pick up this bishop and you get
the extra Pawn so that was that's a a
big trap that Lenderman avoided with the
move A5 but clearly uh now after Bishop
H3 uh talk about telegraphing your ideas
of sacrificing here's hikaro we're going
to see more night sacrifices and we've
got Wesley in our studio to explain his
night sacrifice he's with Maurice with
Maurice yes the number 10 player on the
planet Grandmaster Wesley so after a
culating game amazing crush with Knight
at5 Wesley when you saw the move Knight
at five did you feel like it was over or
did you just think you had compensation
no I didn't think it was over of um in
the worst case I'll get two pawns for a
piece and I thought this would be enough
I'm surprised that he allowed it by
going King H7 he could move his Knight
there instead Knight
H7 then uh you know I probably wouldn't
sacrifice back if that happen I just
play Knight F3 but uh when I played
Knight F5 I felt there was something I
for example I didn't expect he would go
23rd move Rook E6 thought he would play
something else but he went for
that and uh yeah I I think white isn't
risking much with two pounds and and he
bad Bishop on B7 you know it's funny I
often get asked this question I'm sure
you do too it's a typical question
people have how far ahead do Grand
Masters see they look 10 15 20 moves
ahead and you're saying well no I just
looked a few moves ahead I picked up a
couple of Pawns it looks like a good
attack I don't know what's going to
happen and you didn't even necessarily
anticipate all of his defenses I don't
think I would be a professional chess
player if I try to calculate everything
I would get too much headache especially
with 11 games here but actually even in
the final position this G4 move I only
saw it close to close to the end I mean
when he played Rook E7 in the worst case
I could grab the exchange and have two
pwns but then I spotted G4 which uh wins
easily enough amazing that definitely
shows you out there that grand Masters
even Elite ones like Grandmaster Westley
so don't look ahead 15 20 moves that's
not what the real strength is the real
strength is being able to assess the
current position based on the factors in
the board and to make sure you see
enough lines like a bailout line like
Knight takes E7 only the computer can
calculate everything and uh for example
in this game he has options in almost
every move starting on move 23 so
there's really no point I'm sure y sir
will explain more
that's CU yasa can't calculate two moves
ahead so well he played for the English
solid absolutely would you were you
surprised though you are able to win in
just just about two hours against
illustrious goam he's won the
championship four times yes yeah of
course he's a legend yeah even these
days when his rating is not as high as
it used to be he's still a very
considerable opponent and I didn't
expect to to win especially in two hours
this is uh just
you know this is a a a good a good break
for me I mean I was praying yesterday
for a good start and uh I think I had
two good days so tomorrow I don't even
know who I'm playing tomorrow it's
probably time to really don't ahe at
all one one game at a time but after
I'll I'll just close with this quickly a
quick question last year's championship
uh there were some ups and downs for you
is there anything on your mind want to
clean up last year's results and have a
great championship this time oh yeah
well you know last year I had 10
decisive results and only one throw
against saru so this year the people can
probably expect that I'll play more
solidly okay all right well we hope you
play some more fiery sacrifices like
this one and they work out for you well
uh as they say
um it it cannot happen every game unless
the opponent does something something
real bad yeah apparently we're being
told you play AA tomorrow so you get one
of the young yeah he's the he's the
youngest part isff no Jeffrey is but
he's 16 quite close was it going to be
like playing the Juniors you're no
longer a little baby yourself yeah I
have moved on from that for quite a long
time I realized when I turned 16 that
I'm getting older and there's no going
back so I uh look forward to playing
under 26 instead of
Juniors uh yeah aat is a very good
player tomorrow we'll be excited
exciting indeed well today was very
exciting you quite pleased us with your
sacrifice good luck in the rest of the
Championships thank you really
appreciate Grandmaster Wesley so showing
why he's one of the top 10 players in
the world a great win today thank you
Wesley thank you Maurice and uh indeed a
very very impressive win uh we've been
keeping an eye on the three favorites um
looking at the game of Fabi aariana
versus vuan acopian after the move F5
VAR has played the move que E7 and he's
trying to settle in and you know create
some kind of defenses uh in his position
he he is having trouble neutralizing
this bishop that can on B2 that can
still snap that pawn on G7 that still
looks like a very tempting opportunity
uh for
um for Fabby on the other hand the move
F5 you know it's all about you know
softening up a Target on the E6 pawn and
also very compelling move would be Rook
on H1 to E1 in both cases I really like
fabiana's position very much and I think
that uh VAR is not going to be pleased
kind of a boomerang a surprise
Scandinavian in round one um boomeranged
against him and white stands better
white stands better but let's just put
it this way it could have been a lot
worse I think a lot of players you know
that don't have aran's defensive
experience they would be like they would
be like got it in this position and
resigning already the idea like Bishop
D6 and queen E7 he's avoided immediate
catastrophe right and we've got a phone
call caller hello hello hello hello yes
hello Jen
hi my name is Rob I'm from Dela Georgia
and my question is what chance do these
youngest players have like Carissa Yip
and Jeffrey Jean I mean what are their
coaches telling them are they're looking
for one or two good games um you know
I'll hang up and let you guys answer but
you know what are these what are these
young players trying to accomplish at
their first US Championship well thank
you very much for uh your question I'll
be I'll take my first shot I really
think it's about experience I mean if
they got a couple of wins so much the
better but it's their idea that in their
careers thus far they've never faced
this type of competition at the highest
level for 11 rounds in a row so it's the
experience of playing really really top
players game after game after game I
think that's the number one thing that
they have to take away from it so really
lose win or Draw they are winners for
having competed in the first place I
don't know I feel like the the champions
of somebody who's done so well like
Carissa Yip or Jeffrey Jang at such a
young age I think they're able to hold
two things in their minds at one time
and the one thing is I'm the least
experienced and I have one of the lowest
ratings in the tournament and the other
one is who cares I am going to win this
tournament I think there's a little bit
of irrational confidence that is useful
for anyone who's going to become like a
true champion and you see that with
somebody like hiar Nakamura I don't
think he is ever going into a tournament
when he was like 14 or 15 and thinking
like yeah I can't win this there's no
way so I think there's just like some
kernel in their brain where they're like
I could just like start winning games
especially I think in Carissa's case I
mean it is is really hard when you're
it's hard for both but like if you look
at the rating statistically not a high
chance but I really think players that
talented have to have that like that
seed of irrationality what do you think
and well there's something to be said
about that again I'm just thinking that
the you know the enjoyable experience I
remember for myself personally uh my
first US Championship I really really
enjoyed and wanted to play because I was
hoping my opponents would think of me as
the Target in the tournament and really
come after me I'm a very provocative
player I like counterpunching and in my
first US Championship I was really
hopeful that the players would overstep
and take too many risks I'll turn it
over to Maurice uh your thoughts
Maurice I agree with Jen 100% here
actually I'll go even further you've
heard of names like Bobby
fiser Gary Kasparov when those guys are
young the hand of Destiny is burning
bright inside you you're thinking look
I'm going to be the US champion I'm
going to be a world class grandm these
are my dreams my my aspirations I've got
the talent it's been proven to me and
now I get the chance to play my
country's best players I know that some
of the players here actually are some of
the world's best players if you're going
through this competition thinking ah you
know it's going to be rough I'm going to
play against these tough players you're
not you're not going to be one of the
best I mean that's just simply not the
attitude you come in like like a Fisher
like a casparo get young players coming
into their national championships
thinking that I'm a star I'm maybe not
bighead in that way but like I'm focused
I want to win it's chess and I know how
to Checkmate you I know I can see
combinations if I just can get some
decent openings and not get tripped up I
will fight you tooth and nail Jeffrey
Jean we see on the screen here this
kid's a beast he's already won a huge
tournament in Chicago so he and he's
knows he knows exactly how to take down
Grand Masters and so he's always got
that hoodie look too he's got that hood
over it's not cold in the room but man
he puts it on to just get this focus on
and say look I want to fight with anyone
here in the tournament and I have a
belief in myself this is why I'm a
grandmas the kid's 15 and you can say
I'm a Grandmaster I know how to punch
super Grandmaster first degree second
degree whatever I still know how to hit
back so I think these young players come
in they're going to get experience a
story for us those of them who do not
succeed will be while they got the
experience but let one of these players
start hitting on a few GMS and we'll be
singing their praises for the future
that maybe we have a future star in the
works thank you Maurice and the game of
Jeffrey by the way has just exploded
I've been keeping an eye on that game I
really like how Alexander onook built up
the pressure uh taking more space these
Knights on e4 and F4 are extremely
powerful lurking dangerous attacking
ideas especially with his Bishop on B3
lurking against this King on
G8 in the Knight H5 Knight E6 so
recognizing that he was under pressure
Jeffrey captured upon offering a peace
sacrifice which was refu refused by uh
Alexander uh onuk who just simply
captured the pawn on E6 and Jeffrey uh
under big pressure by
the always always solid and good uh
Alexander onuk looking very powerful in
his first game and Maurice I'll send it
back to you that this game's turned
wild very wild and I got to admit I I'm
trying to keep track and I can't keep
track and so again you get the engines
who help us with the analysis because we
can just talk generally speaking but
until you look at the concrete moves
you're just blowing air we can give you
wild and crazy and and our general
estimations as strong players but some
positions just defy simple analysis and
simple breakdown and we'll be talking
for a long time before we finally
realize oh this is what's actually
happening the engines are saying right
now that this position is actually
almost equal I know it's insane but the
engines are like maybe white has a
slight Edge nothing much and you got to
look and say are you kidding me look at
the craziness that's going on on on the
board this Knight sack this Knight's
hanging well the engine is giving is
this move inter metzo before taking the
Knight Knight to D3 allowing the Knight
to die on the D3 square and after Rook
takes D3 now take on E6 now what this
means is that white can actually play
Bishop takes on E6 with check and now
after King to h8 White is currently
ahead by a pawn but the problem is that
black is now perfectly safe there are no
attacks you could do to the black
position that affect this King side and
this bishop is bearing down on this rook
and this queen is about to take this
pawn and if this Rook moves white will
not be able to Castle so it turns out
that white is actually worse in this
position white is in trouble The Rook
has nowhere to go and can't stop this
queen showing up on the A4 Square so
that is what Jeffrey should go for and
he has actually played the move Knight
to D3 check is on the board as we speak
the only move as Rook takes don't don't
try to move your king cuz you're going
to face some nastiness plus your E6
Knight is dropping anyway so you must
take this and now F takes on E6 and the
engine say do not take this Pawn play
the move Rook to E3 save your Rook for
the moment but now after King to h8
getting off the long diagonal when you
stare at the board you have nothing to
do for for white white has no way of
improving the threats somehow how do you
generate initiative you cannot Castle
anymore in fact the engines are trying
to shut the position down somehow with
Queen to E5 as the best move going to
some endgame and Black's not really
seriously worse here maybe after Queen
to E5 you'll get something after this
trade trade and now Rook a to d8 and yes
black is get getting out of the woods in
this position so this youngster has
calculated this line it looks super
sharp but this move Knight to D3 and
they're in that position right now and
Onish shu is still thinking about it it
looks as though
black is perfectly fine oners shook now
digging deep I tell you these youngsters
they are respectful but they're not
afraid that's right so I'll have to go
into the confessional booth and confess
I didn't see the move Knight D3 with I
thought Jeffrey was in real trouble
without that move but with the move this
is a six- hour confessional you can say
whatever you want it's all it's all one
long
confessional some like very very nice
very boring day we've had so far now
seriously this has been amazing so far
the only thing I've been disappointed by
so far is we've gotten such amazing
calls but what what do what does one
thing everybody has in common that call
what they're all men so shout out to the
ladies who are watching I know there are
some of you um one of you's got a call
in at some point but we do have another
call right now and I'm happy whether
you're a guy or a girl Hello
caller
hi hi oh sorry hi my name is Pablo from
Venezuela great broadcast as always guys
I wonder players like Nakamura and
kowana are uh excessively fatigued both
mentally and physically after a long two
three weeks of the candidates and will
they be vulnerable versus you know their
sharp tactical uh co- competitors thank
you Pablo very very good point fantastic
question yeah two of our players uh
Hikaru and Fabby are of course coming
from that
Marathon uh hardfought tournament the
candidates tournament in Moscow that
only was completed 10 days ago or
whatever it was that that they two weeks
ago that that that the event was
completed first of all the jet lag in
terms of return and after such an event
where they exhausted themselves do they
have the inner energy fortitude to come
and take a commanding uh position in
this us Championship I think we're going
to find out I mean I really don't know
they're youthful but boy those events
really zap you that's true I think it's
a great question I mean one of the
things is both Nakamura and Kon are so
successful we're all delete that besides
preparing for chess they don't have any
you know too many other responsibilities
like you know an appearance here and
there you know they both represent the
club and um he cars with Red Bull but
it's not like they're teaching lessons
on the side or like you know doing
videos and stuff like that so it it's
true that they do have that full two
weeks to rest is that enough is it a is
it a benefit or that they Al let's also
look on the bright side they've also
been preparing so much chess they
probably had some Novelties that weren't
even used in the candidates could easily
be executed against some innocent
bystander here at the championship true
that and uh great question we're going
to find out we will and cley Wesley is
here to say hello I'm fresh he giv me
even fresher he's getting he's got a
free day today like half a free day um
instead of you know slaving away for
four or five hours he's got his game
done in two two hours right and we saw
Hikaru who looked over the game kind of
shaking his head in disgust like gosh
you're just giving my my rivals a key
gift what's up with that that's right
it's a little bit of a of a a jealousy
there think no I mean you know how it is
yeah you're taking the taking the point
very
easily Nakamura loves to be on The
Winning Side of attacks like that so um
looking at his comrad winning sides
winning moves we've got our one of our
live commentators here Grandmaster Ben
fold on The Winning Side of a best move
tactic and we are going to go on a quick
break keep those questions coming both
your calls and your hash us test Champs
we're loving the interaction that you've
been giving us for the first two hours
of this broadcast and we can't wait for
the rest be right
[Music]
back Mr myy what's your favorite part
about this
sport I think the strategy how much do
you hate to lose I don't like it at all
what about being second guest I don't
like that either well if I were you I
wouldn't have moved that
Rook
Checkmate sorry whether you've played
chess for years or never before come
experience all the sport has to offer at
the world-renowned chess club and
Scholastic Center of St Louis
Mr mini what's your favorite
part
[Music]
e
hey we are back at the 2016 US
championship and US Women's Championship
it's been so great so far that thrilling
Victory by Wesley so you're going to
have to go back and Rewind if you didn't
see that cuz that was awesome and we
also have had such a fantastic um number
of callers we know that those of you who
have called in you've been waiting on
hold while we analyze some highlights
and we thank you for that because it
really does add to the show and we um
look forward to more of you um hearing
from more of you throughout the show we
have been getting lots and lots of
tweets including but from some top Grand
Masters like Josh fow who's played in
this competition before and he pointed
out that the women are maintaining their
sanity better than the men and most
games consist of solid and objectively
correct chest well you know what they
say about men they so emotional is that
what they say about men yeah of course
I'm going to talk to Dan your husband
about
that Josh also says the pirate trend is
catching on he says that the ultra solid
ownership forgot to Castle and goes on
the immediate assault awesome to watch
wow so indeed we've got a a a lot of
excitement here and more to come and by
the way we got to solve the question uh
that the puzzle right from Grand or Ben
fold you were challenged to find the
best move and Maurice Ashley will clue
you
in I know you keep saying Grand Master
Ben fingo but actually Ben got slapped
in this game so let's switch it around
this is actually shaba doing the right
thing also all of Famer is shabra
grandmas shabalov and he had this
position against Ben and unfortunately
for Ben it looked like he had made a
good move let's just go back one move to
this position what is the most natural
move on the board hey just simply double
Rooks right looks pretty good what could
be more natural than that the problem
with the move is now The Rook is a
problem on that square and those of you
who found it found this really delicious
move Knight to E2 check complete
surprise in the position the Knight if
captured he resigned In This Moment
actually if the Knight is captured then
simply Rook takes check King moves and
then the other Rook comes down and
checks and that's going to be all she
wrote after Rook E1 either Rook or queen
can take and that's going to be
Checkmate the main problem of the move
however is you actually have no response
to it because for one thing if King 2 H1
in this position let's make that the new
main line in this position if King to H1
well you could play Knight G3 check and
pick off a rook that looks kind of
simple I believe however that this move
is also kind of delicious this Rook is
coming down so after Bishop takes we can
just sacrifice Our Queen on the Square
and that's going to be all she wrote
after Rook takes here we have a nice
little back rank Checkmate so KN to E2
check by shabalov such a natural move
Rook a to F1 but uh it proved to be a
disaster in that game meantime shabalov
is facing off against Webster's Own St
Louis St Louis's own Ray Robson who just
seems like how many national
championships for Webster has he won has
he won all four since in his tenure
that's absolutely an incredible record
to win national championship Collegiate
Championship Time After Time After Time
After Time he's like the Yukon women
winning four in a row absolutely
incredible feat by that University and
Susan Paul gar kudos to her developing a
world class program absolutely and I
just wanted to bring mention the women's
game because in the Women's Championship
we have this game between nji and Anna
zatonski Anna again welcome back to the
US Championship but Anna is in really
bad shape here I just love White's
positional domination with his Bishop on
E5 this bishop on E5 could go anytime
she likes to the D6 square and uh that
would skew an exchange over here and it
seems to me that uh if white were just
to move her Rook uh for example to the
D1 Square eventually this Pawn is going
to move up to the B4 Square allowing The
Rook to come back to the E1 square and I
think Anna is in
really difficult uh shape here in her
first round and what kind of form is she
going to show at this tournament because
she's been absent from the game for a
little bit she may be very Rusty as one
of the pre-tournament favorites in big
trouble in this first round still the
highest rated and I do think we have to
give a lot of credit to uh Nazi who
shown her medal with white in this
tournament before last year she actually
defeated the champion Arena Crush in a
really undefeated herself in a really
nicely played game with why you guys can
go back and go over that that was a
great great effort and uh she came very
close to winning the championship last
year against Arena who's won four in a
row did we just say I mean what is it
with Ray Robson and Arena anyway we do
have a caller that's right we've got a
caller hello welcome to their
show hello
hello yes I'm uh my name is Ernest and
I'm calling from
Oklahoma um I was wondering if all three
of you guys Jen I know you play a lot of
hoola chess with five minutes uh yaser
bear Grandmaster om on ICC uh 2500 Blitz
rating on the auto pairing that's pretty
incredible and of course Grandmaster
Maurice Ashley uh none of these guys
apparently can't touch you in Blitz
chess so I was wondering if uh you could
offer like I don't know maybe three tips
on how to improve uh Blitz
chess well thank you for the question
erns I'll take that because uh I I've
all my life played Blitz I started chess
as a blitz player and it took me a long
while to stop playing Blitz at the
tournament games CU I played it so
quickly I enjoyed Blitz a lot uh for me
uh Blitz is a kind of a training and a
relaxation and what I try to do when I
play Blitz is uh to get the positions
that I'm the most familiar with so I'll
play systems that I really feel
comfortable in and I'll repeat those
systems um when I'm playing sessions I
enjoy that a lot secondly got to stay
ahead on the clock you just can't afford
to get uh too far behind and finally the
third and most obvious one is play
higher rated players take this as an
opportunity to train yourself and don't
shk away don't uh decline challenges
from higher rated players but rather
really play u the strongest players you
can find I actually just read an article
about hiar nakam more about 7 bullet
chest and there's some cool ones there
never resign I never resign and I like
the one where he said keep the clock in
your peripheral vision I really like
that because he's like always keep it in
Vision but don't like stare at the clock
that's going to take too much attention
from the board so I think that's a good
way to think about it that there's
actually like this nth file if you will
on which the chess clock lies and you
got to keep that in on your eye um and
uh great question thank you we've also
got Maurice Ashley with an update on the
Jeffrey Jean game um that's gotten
pretty heated quite a few games now we
need to hurry up because a lot of things
going on and particular guys you guys
are going to start to appreciate the
time disparities in some of these games
simply stunning as a matter of fact but
first let's look at this one Jeffrey
Jang did go down a line that we said uh
let's back that up that the computer
said was good for black because in this
position here he did find all the moves
right here he played the very nice
Knight to D3 check forcing Rook takes D3
F E6 and then after Rook to E3 he did
find King to h8 it's almost as though he
was watching the broadcast he found All
the Right Moves takes takes and then
Rook ad8 he also said I'm not defending
the E6 Pawn he could have defended it
dropped his Bishop back he said are you
kidding and let the guy Castle you can
take that pawn please and of course
Bishop takes on E6 now and the engines
are giving this as equal position triple
zero a surprising assessment given that
white is up a pawn but it's not a clean
Pawn in the move Rook to D4 is what the
engines are giving in this position this
this King has a problem and this bishop
is very strong you look at this lineup
on the eile this E Pawn could come under
some danger quite shortly so that's a
bit of a challenge here a very unclear
position but the injes are saying just
fine for black enough counterplay with
the two Bishops and the dynamic play and
this King stuck in the middle of the
board just the markers we need to be
able to say you know what this is kind
of interesting we don't know what's
happening here very sharp game now more
importantly let's take a look at this
game we've been staring at this one for
a while Fabiano Carana has been pressing
vuja niobian and a critical moment
happened here VAR said Bishop D6 F5 big
time move on the board Queen to E7 and
Fabby said uh give me that I'm going to
take the pawn now the injures weren't
too thrilled by it they thought he
should continue to play positionally by
taking but a pawn is a pawn after all
and Bishop back to B2 not saying that
this was a bad position for white just
maybe taking a bit would have given
black a little bit less because now
black was able to Castle and after Rook
hf1 Rook D2 E8 now this move the injes
are not too thrilled by and giving an
advantage for white but forget about
that for a second I don't need's wide up
a pawn you want to check out these clock
times 24 minutes for fabbi 2 minutes and
59 seconds that's under three minutes
with 22 moves to go okay they're 30
second increments but guys 22 moves you
talk about bullet I hope VAR has been
practicing some bullet chest because
he's going to need it and he's going to
feel the tension in his body for the
next 45 50 minutes of play and you see
he's trying to stay cool but this is a
dangerous moment for him if Fabby comes
up with one move that's just one move
that has some trickiness to it that has
some tactical complication that has some
new some Nuance he's going to be in
trouble in that position now that one
and he's getting up from the board dude
I make a move you might lose 15 seconds
of your time so that's quite challenging
to see him there I think that's a bit
irresponsible getting up right now and
just casually looking at other games but
talk about time issue this other game I
was looking at Sam Shanklin versus AKA
Chandra the kid has played beautifully
the youngster refuted everything kept
the his opponent at Bay all right his
rookie sitting on 87 right now that move
I did not see a couple of moves back but
now it's on the board the engines are
giving him equality because he's got an
extra pawn and the injes have not
figured out how to win with white
although to be this is full compensation
easy compensation you think that block
is much worse by my assessment but the
engines just is saying nope we could
defend this position but forget about
that for the moment wi pieces are all
active 35 minutes on the clock for Sam
41 seconds 41 seconds left for AKA
Chandra and he's gonna have to make 12
moves with his opponent won a he won a
gold medal for the US team in the
Olympiad did Sam Shanklin you know he's
going to figure out a couple of tricky
moves and boy he's in bullet mode
already okay you get your 30 second
increments but even so wasting all that
time in the opening spending an hour on
a move guys that was not responsible and
he is in deep trouble no matter how
equal he is in this position he's going
to have to defend some kind of tricky
tactic and I think he's going to blunder
into a loss in this game if he does not
lose on time he's just going to make a
horrible move that costs him in in the
worst way and he will take a lesson from
this game don't waste your time like
that in the open no matter what these
guys will make you suffer and the only
problem for Sam is kind of saying you
know what I got a lot of time let me sit
for as long as possible instead of
playing quickly you see him doing it
right there moving his Bishop back will
he play too fast and allow his his young
opponent to come up with quick moves but
hey shandre is down to 35 seconds right
now he's got to move let's keep our eyes
on this game indeed so Bishop D4
obviously at some point it would be it
would be beautiful if Sam could make
something about this long diagonal but
that's the one thing that Shandra is
well equipped to meet right like even if
we create a battery on A1 and B you you
can simply Play Bishop G7 well the nice
thing from shander's point of view is
despite his time deficit and it is
really bad time management of course uh
we are always prepared for the direct
threat so move like Bishop D4 should
have been immediately answered same move
faster was better uh Shandra took a few
seconds but he did did F and play the
obvious Queen C6 about a 30 seconds
exactly because he had the same amount
of time as he had when he started so now
now Sam presumably he's going to back
back up his Bishop right say I don't
know like Bishop to D2 well just a
second Bishop to B2 is in baby and and
notice that the queen on B6 was holding
down the the Ed Square exactly so that
that's that's that's the difference and
again um Queen G4 doesn't seem like a
threat at first because you can play
Bishop G7 but that we can meet Bishop G7
with uh roof to d8 which could get a
little sticky exactly this back rank is
really uh right suffering I mean he may
have to just simply drop back with his
Queen and not to allow that Invasion on
the back rank trying desperately by the
way to set up for a trade of Bishops
with Bishop G7 maybe black could crawl
with his King to H7 and on a good day
activate his Rook I mean basically black
is doing his best to hold on here is
what I'm saying yeah and just an amazing
defensive piece there on Rick H7 that's
not a stopping Queen D4 and queen h8
made right not something you see very
often but surprisingly
effective and by the way just turning uh
the page for a bit it looked to me like
for for a for being a pawn down uh that
he Hikaru had a dominating position um I
just trying to find hi Caro game I think
it might be up top I this is the
carolana
R managed to get his queen king over to
the queen side and this is the game of
hearo uh essentially I really like
hikaru's pwn sacrifice and you know me I
love being a Pawn's ahead but Black's
pieces all on the first
rank white has an enormous Edge in space
uh lot of opportunities and of course uh
for the moment uh this D6 square is uh a
very juicy square that the night uh
could possibly land in the very near
future so I see Alexander Lenderman as
being under a lot of pressure against uh
the defending champ that dark that light
squared Bishop nothing to write home
about indeed and we do have looks like a
big Pawn doesn't it stuck out here sorry
we do have a let's move to AKA Chandra
because he's down to 12 seconds oh my
goodness he need to keep he needs to
keep that keep keep it moving and uh Sam
did in fact play that Bishop B2 idea and
aat has decided to respond to that with
F6 so creating some weaknesses but
making his Rook on H7 a little bit more
sensible indeed and the engines do like
that move they give him equality still
this is a move that Sam's going to have
to study really carefully and there are
no lines actually absolutely no lines
the engine gives that that pose any real
problems I'm talking about a tactical
move that you go wait a minute you have
to think about that one you have think
about that one it looks as though black
will be able to slowly get his game
going maybe bring the Rook over to F7
get the king to H7 and just
play blocker and say hey you're not
coming to get me anytime soon so if he
could add a few moves together string a
few moves together where he's just not
losing then he can catch up on that time
add a bit of time on the increment to
pad himself a little bit and he should
be fine the move Rook to d8 has jumped
in on the board and the injes are saying
that this is actually worse Sam playing
quickly and maybe trying to take
advantage of the clock but the injes are
saying this move is bad for white the
move now being to just trade off and
after Queen takes just play this move
Rook to D7 and it seems as though you
cannot capture a pawn back happily we go
into this end game thank you very much
bring the king up easy game for him now
his rook's coming down and that's that's
just no problem for him so this Rook to
d8 and it has the trade has happened so
he needs to find the move Rook to D7 now
and his pieces will be well connected
Queen to E8 will also be a move but
suddenly the move Rook to
C7 like is that for real beautiful
tactical idea check this out if Queen
takes now Rook to G7 and suddenly it's
white who loses the game whoa will he
find those moves will anything like that
happen is amazing variation but he does
have the move Rook to D7 he did not find
it he played the move Rook to F7 saying
solid this is one of the problems with
not having enough time on your clock you
can't find tricky moves like Rook to D7
he just played the instinctive one Rook
to F7 guarding his Pawn the engines now
give Rook to E8 and say the position is
more or less equal maybe though slightly
better for black it seems as though
black is out of danger black will always
be able to bring the king to G7 and be
protected so it seems as though black is
out of danger even here he has to move
B4 so the youngster defending well and I
think Sam played quickly a typical
problem when you're when you have time
pressure for the other player to play
quickly to try to take advantage of it
it looks as though Sam has done so and
the youngster is getting out of the
woods thank you Maurice and we have a
caller uh Jennifer that's right welcome
to to the show uh give us your name and
uh what you're curious about hi I'm Tim
from South Dakota hi Tim and uh Hi and
um I've got a question about overall
chess principles I've been playing
online and um what I have found works
for me is to um lock up the positions
with all with the ponds all locked up
and so I've got a close position then I
treat off my weakest piece and and I
find when I when I get in those close
positions am I the only one that thinks
that it's easier to calculate uh tactics
in a closed position rather than an open
position I'd like to hear your
discussion on that tactics question
about tactics in a closed position
versus an open position well as uh the
the entire nature of uh chest positions
that are open is You're simply going to
have a lot more Tactical play when
you're playing closed positions um
normally you're not as vulnerable to uh
tactics I always like playing closed
positions because those were more of a
maneuvering games and I felt that that
was my strength so um for those of you
who are like tactics you love the open
positions
Maurice absolutely love those open
positions full of tactics and then those
semi-open ones better are on balance
also intriguing tactics close one
definitely much more about maneuvering
and in this position we have nak
Nakamura against Lenderman it is
definitely one of those semiopen if you
will that's about to be totally open
Nakamura in this position with white
starting to build his position more and
more and queen C7 was played and Naka of
course found the shot D5 and after e
takes D5 of course the C Pawn is pinned
he now dropped in Knight to D6 hitting
the rook and the great thing for his
position is uncovering this diagonal for
his Bishop The Rook has very few places
to go to if you play a move like Rook to
d8 then suddenly Bishop takes D5 anyway
and the F7 Pawn is under threat you
can't just start grabbing stuff here
because of course Bishop takes F7 check
and The Rook is suddenly on the queen
and that's going to be all she wrote so
D5 E5 Knight D6 Lenderman now studying
this position and the engines are saying
he's busted by the way let's just make
that point if the Rook goes to f8 in
anticipation of Defending against Bishop
takes D5 look at this atrocious position
for black you just got to look at the
pieces The Rook on a8's doing nothing
the night on B8 the rishop on A6 three
black pieces absolutely out of the
action this Rook is passive and start
looking at WISE pieces they just lording
over the chess board no surprise that
there going to be some tactical kills in
this position don't forget this bishop
on this diagonal great position it looks
as though Hikaru showing his stuff
starting to cruise right now and a an
exchange sack has occurred in the game
he has decid Ed instead as we see the
board to sacrifice an exchange in this
position instead of playing any Rook
move he just moved his Queen off the pin
with Queen to D7 allowing takes and
takes uh this looks really bad for him
given that he has no pieces yet moved
out still on this side and no surprise
the engines looking to open up the game
blast open the game with the move E4
just to keep hunting this position looks
like totally in the favor of one of the
top five players I'm not sure maybe he's
number six but at same difference in the
world Nakamura really showing that he
wants to follow wesle so and win with
the Y pieces and win in style likewise
we
did beautiful principles uh I must say
when you're when you have better
development uh control of the game uh
we're always told open the position up
don't let your your opponent catch up
with development that uh look for those
sacrifices and that move d4 D5 is going
to be a textbook example of what it
means to have a superiority in
development to open up the position very
impressive uh game thus far by hikaro
Nakamura he looks great I'm also looking
at the game of Fabiana Karana uh because
of the time pressure that's going on in
that game between V varac Cobian after
this bishop takes G7 it looks like
Fabiano has a very nice position still
well he's always had a nice position but
uh looks like he's in improving his
advantage against opponent who basically
used all of his clock burned um what did
we say he just a few minutes Al oh I
think I think he could have easily
gotten crushed if he hadn't used that
time I think his position got like he
had a lot of pitfalls he could have
fallen into like 10 minutes ago fact
like he's just a manage a castle that's
a big complishment you want to say right
you know get your King on a Dodge I get
it no but but having said that he really
really uh it's a terrible position for
him and all of our favorites looking
great here in the first rounds uh
Maurice yes just to throw out a point
because his position looks so good right
now but it's worth just mentioning it
looks like Carana may have missed a
bigger opportunity in the game according
to the engines anyway like I said his
moves look very human and natural and
what we would normally do but the
opportunity here was to move Queen to H5
this apparently was a very strong move
but it involved understand in something
really bizarre and I'm looking at it now
and I still am wondering why you would
do it after takes takes the move Knight
F4 in this position remember he's up a
pawn right now to sacrifice The Exchange
to say okay I'm willing to give you this
guy so I can crack your Pawn on F7 and
now this Pawn on F6 is super strong and
blacks
pieces they they still look not that bad
but it's bad enough because this Pawn is
such a bone in the throat and he's going
to bring his night back out and make you
suffer with this Pawn forever so this
line by the engine a bit
counterintuitive needing to sacrifice
poy probably said you know what I don't
have to do that let me go into a
different line but according to the
engines that was very strong but he went
to a very simple line the engines are
not giving him that huge an edge as he
had before here but here's the problem
this guy's only 36 seconds left on his
clock does VAR uh akobian so he has to
find All the Right Moves Rook to G6 was
the move by the engine instead he played
Rook to h8
and that move like I said when you're in
time pressure you face tons of problems
trying to play The Right Move each time
this move the engine says curse Splat
you're dead you're done if Fabby now
finds and I have no doubt he will find
the move Knight takes
F7 beautiful shot now you're in big
trouble after takes Rook Landing down on
the board and suddenly you're running
out of moves this F Pawn is turning into
a Beast will run down the board very
quickly let's just follow a line for
example like Queen to H H5 trying to
trade off this F Pawn is saying hello
I'm coming I'm coming I'm coming fast
too you're in trouble here what can you
do this is all protected if you move
your Rook over to the G8 Square the to
the d8 square then we grab this as well
look at that F Pawn and problems still
continue this bishop along this diagonal
has exploded great play for him and if
the Rook tries to stay then it doesn't
work work of course because if Queen
takes Queen and then this Pawn will
become a queen in one move so what to do
here after Knight F7 it just looks
terrible has he found the move yet he's
going to take some time I'm sure he sees
it Rook to G7 if you try to stay in the
position with this move then F7 is still
going to happen and again Rook to E7
trying to defend cool calm Rook over to
G1 preparing the move Rook to G8 and you
can't take this Pawn on F7 because of
Queen takes E6 check terrible position
for black and again the time pressure
will derail him we are waiting to see if
Fabiano Carana finds this move and guess
what guys he didn't find it wow he
didn't find it it was a crushing blow
completely crushing blow it looks like
uh and now he's played the move H3 in
this position instead of taking on F7
he's played H3 and I'm somewhat
surprised here that he didn't find that
move maybe he saw something surprising
in that position evaluated it instead he
just played the move H3 and blitzed out
is the move Rook to
H6 and uh it's it game continues thank
you Maurice no for me that move H3 by
Fabby is a clear indication that he
still doesn't have his energy batteries
that are fully charged because I'm 100%
the Fabiana Karana we saw at the uh SFI
cup where he went on the streak would
have played Knight F7 uh and the move H3
is just a soft reasonable move but it
but it misses the instant tactical blow
Knight F7 and Rook G7 that as beautiful
A variation as this all was again this
all comes from this night takes F7
sacrifice for a player of Fabiano's
caliber that's not a difficult find this
all I mean it's just it it plays itself
there's a flow it's so easy for him to
to find that and I I'm going to
attributed that to simple tiredness now
over in the Women's Championship we've
got a couple of games where it looks
like they could be over soon tatv
abrahamian and one of the pre-tournament
favorites is really just all over um her
opponent who's a newcomer to the
championship Wild Card AATA um by cop
Sev and she's up material and basically
every single one of her pieces is better
than our opponent so I think that game
will end soon I'm not not you vers
esaron which seems a little bit closer
although Jennifer you still on top but
um no this thisam vers looks like it
should be over pretty soon I mean what
does tatv have here she's got a pawn
she's got the monster on D6 she's got
two Bishops MH sorry I'm just having a
little trouble with my getting the
current position yeah okay there you
have it this uh game of I the The Rook
is just ready to invade on E7 as well
and then the bishop can come to D5 so
this just totally agreed uh better minor
pieces and extra material for white so
this is simply a game over minor and
major minor and major pieces uh I I
thought things were unclear uh just at
this moment Agatha had uh tried this uh
Queen uh pardon me Ace A6 A5 attacking
White's queen and I thought uh tatf
found a very nice solution uh giving up
the A2 Pawn
but getting this winning middle game end
game position this looks great for tatf
and meanwhile Carissa Yip against um AA
Gori so we've got our our youngest
player in the tournament Carissa and AA
our second youngest I believe yeah um
so this
one we also have a material advantage
here for
Carissa um she's up a pawn and it looks
like if if she her her pieces also are
better so as long as there there's no um
trick tricky here as you like to say out
there um this should also be uh quite
strong for white just a queen that's
invaded a nice Rook on C5 ready to take
on C7 and even the Knight on C3 um has
some greener pastures yeah and I was
just going to say our defending Champion
is Pawn down against Kate so Arena's got
some issues uh Maurice what's going on
well just a quick update on another game
the game between another pass Champion
ano zatonski and nazzi pitzi Nazi's like
I Bel not only do I belong one day I'm
going to think about winning this thing
and she's definitely one of the
favorites to winning the tournament Nazi
pidy against Anna zatonski that's a big
game we see a different game on the
screen there but this game I'd like to
show you this position the way she
handled it we saw Great Dark Square
blockade this bishop was very strong she
played the move Queen B2 did Nazi and
this move interesting move it's very
positional the engines don't like it but
when you look at it you feel like that's
how humans would play this position get
the dark Square control and now you
can't take the pawn on C5 because of the
move B4 and that's going to be all she
wrote so instead Bishop C7 was played
now a trade on C7 and then Rook E1
guarding the dark square and now the
move Rook F to E8 and then F4 got
control of the file D of the square
excuse me E5 Square now D4 Rook to D5
Rook to E5 and now you're looking at the
position you realize a complete dark
Square dominance D3 now Rook D2
controlling every dark Square Black's
Pawn looks Dead on Arrival Rook to B8
was played and now Queen to C3 Queen to
B7 on the board the engines feel like
this is just a random demonstration B4
will happen this Pawn's going nowhere
will it be enough of a consternation to
White I don't think so Bishop to E4 is
coming this Pawn looks dead she's
completely outplayed her guys and she's
ahead on the clock so Nazi kidy once
again showing she played the
championship last year didn't lose a
game now playing this year and pressing
a former Champion four time Champion
Anna zatonski right out the gate that's
rightful game by niji so far I told you
I liked it earlier I really like it now
yeah I mean Alejandro was on our
broadcast and he's friends with niji and
one thing he pointed out last year is
that he admired her professionalism he
thought that she came prepared and she
didn't get into as much time pressure as
some of the other women so just a bit
more of a professional approach he
thought and that maybe that's something
we're going to see from her like some
good opening preparation and not leaving
herself with one minute on the clock but
to be fair it's not just the women who
get in time pressure as we see we see a
massive time pressure in the
championship absolutely I think like in
previous years when the women weren't as
used to like the prestigious competition
we saw more extreme time pressure
because it was like so nerve-wracking
and now they know like St Louis it's a
big deal and they seem to like just be
more prepared for the clock management
right which is huge yeah disciplined
approach by Nagi for sure but in this
game Anna looks bad she's definitely uh
been caught and her position's just very
very unpleasant she she uh is being
positionally dominated as we speak uh
I'm very curious as to what's happening
in the Open Championship in the game of
Shandra versus uh Sam shankland uh Sam
had a big big Edge on the clock but the
position has Chandra made the time
control I see that Sam's up from his
board so um I'm wondering if uh the US
Junior Champion has survived he did make
the time control wow well first of all
kudos for that that's an accomplishment
but it looks like but he made some
errors but he made some errors along the
way unfortunately for him he did not
play precisely in that position and he
he opted for this game he should never
have taken on C2 in that position there
uh and he did and unfortunately for him
taking on C2 allowed this maneuver B4
takes Queen C1 Rook back and now he
offered a trade of Queens which Sam
gladly obliged the trade of Queens in
this position forcing this line with a
rook to E8 and after Rook over now hello
the A6 Pawn is dropping by force and
he's made time control but now facing
two pass pawns getting ready to steam
down the board this is going to be hard
if not impossible to save this position
is four pawns against two on the other
side mean just about nothing because of
the double pawns on the file wow uh yeah
that's the the advantage is really
really turned in this game and we
understand absolutely why because of the
time trouble this was the crucial moment
as Maurice was saying grabbing the pawn
on C2 was simply helpful uh for Sam
Shanklin had he played B5 before I think
all three results are possible here
because you're going to play King G7 or
queen takes C2 next and this
demonstration of this pin on the eth
rank isn't that meaningful black already
has a rook on F7 so this is where the
game starts to turn right here and um
here this move Queen C7 is really wrong
egregiously wrong probably he had to
play the move Queen to F4 attacking this
bishop trying to provoke that trade
but I'm just wondering how bad this is
it's bad don't get me wrong this is
really bad but how bad is it for example
after I play G5 on a good day I'm
dreaming that I'm going to play F4 G4
put a Pawn on G3 let's say we go B4
looks right I'll bring my Rook I'll
activate my Rook do you want to go B5
what do you think uh J yeah let's just
go for it let's just go for I can let
you demonstrate your evil plans well
exactly and I do have some evil
intentions of course
but my evil intentions involve trying to
utilize my pawns on the king side um
let's just continue the game for a
second like something like this like
this and here's where you you're getting
your little counterplay a little
counterplay maybe I could have defended
a little more accur I think you could
have but and should have but I'm just
saying this is going be there's still
some kicking chances this is going to be
a long one so we're going to keep our
eye on variations like that for the next
couple hours meanwhile a game that could
end any moment or could last a long time
um Fabiano Carana versus veran aobi and
Maurice has an update Yes again quickly
varujan in horrific time pressure still
he hasn't made it out the woods there's
no way he's trading off all these pieces
quickly as much as he would like to and
so he had to Blitz out some moves and
take a look at what happens to a
Grandmaster a strong one as vuan niobian
is when he is just a poodle with time
pressure on his mind look at his moves
it's crazy Rook df1 Fabiano said look
I'm just going to guard that pawn I'm
not going to do anything X just keep the
pressure on you A5 coming out of nowhere
it's just a move it's like flick the
pawn there's no way to really improve
the position King to B1 cool calm in
this position I don't do anything you're
move again King B8 leaving the center I
just need to make a move what am I
supposed to do next Rook to G4 building
slowly improving the position Rook d8 I
just I'm not sure what to do leaving
this E6 Pawn alone H4 still building
maybe not even the optimal move King A7
just he needs a move he has no real plan
he's just moving his King away and what
do the engin say now there's a big blast
that could be played Knight takes E6
it's bizarre though because fabbi is
refusing to play any of the winning
moves the sacrifices that are possible
Knight takes on E6 F takes and then Pawn
up I'll show it on the board Knight
takes and then F7 and this position is
really difficult to hold because of the
Rook G8 threat and he's completely
winning but fabbi he's it's almost like
he's somehow transfixed on
varian's poor time situation that he's
just continuing to play solid move after
solid move so in this position instead
of sacrificing it looks like he played
the move Bishop to
E5 yes he did Bishop to E5 and the
engines don't like that one but Rook to
D7 was not the best respon now the
engine saying bring the bishop back to
B2 and let's get back to the business
again so it's funny watching it happens
to all of us your opponent's in time
pressure and you're thinking if I just
play fast enough fast enough fast enough
I'll push him over and you miss the
decisive shots it's like he's waiting
for move 40 to really think about the
killer blows is Fabiano and not playing
the Right Moves so again Bishop to B2 is
the engines move don't trade off pieces
when the guy is not doing well in terms
of space instead find the blows Fabi
with 8 minutes on his clock now he's
starting to lean into some time pressure
issues he's got to make 11 more moves in
the next 8 minutes so he's feeling it
too this game gly going Topsy Turvy guys
one game that's not Topsy Turvy though
is ew this one this is squash City
Happening Here we saw this back here
after Queen takes E8 E4 did happen
opening up the game with Advantage well
D4 you tried said no way in the world
I'm continuing with my March down the
board to to keep the position sharp F4
F6 Rook takes D4 he got to trade this
off and here comes this Rook trying to
get down into the position this move
Bishop to C8 and this is just terrible
the bishop look at these pieces they're
all on the back row Bishop D7 trying to
keep the pieces out not a chance Queen
takes G6 and this one's uh as bloody as
the one that got had to face just
complet you know when you play a game
and you're rook and your knight it's
move 30 5 The Rook on A8 has not moved
yet it's moved 35 and this piece has not
moved this Knight looks like it hasn't
moved either just a disaster for
Lenderman uh certainly a game that he
will likely want to forget really soon
because he did not equit himself well
and he's at move 35 with 11 minutes to
go Nakamura is the one who's in heavy
time pressure with two minutes on his
clock two minutes and change but I think
Naka could handle this one what do you
guys think oh a beautiful game by hikaro
totally dominant game if you forget
about the clocks for a moment it looks
like one of the most one-sided games
since Wesley so and got's game so the US
the defending US champion sure looks
good in this opening round I'm a little
bit surprised for the second time that
Fabiano has missed that night sacrifice
that looks so decisive but Hikaru
Nakamura cruising and I don't even see a
move uh for uh Lenderman at this moment
he really
suggestions uh there are no suggestions
uh yeah B AG three we can play Oh So
Many Many lovely ideas here for white
exactly all white all White's entire
dream is just to take this rook and plon
it down on the d8 Square and Black's
King is toasted so this looks like a
very one-sided game for hikaro Nakamura
as his campaign to retain his title
appears to be going very well that's
right he's off to a great start start
here and by the way there's also Bishop
E4 there's another uh very very simple
idea in the position for white bring
your Bishop to E4 too many wins and uh
set up for Queen H7 check he chose
different I think he he played Bishop uh
let's see what happened
after okay just a second I have to
refresh my board I apologize and let's
see so he just played Bishop C3 I was
trying to see ah so sorry so Bishop C3
in this position no no no when the queen
was on E5 with the idea that if Queen
takes C3 you can just take on d uh was
the idea Queen takes C3 so the queen was
on E5 and he played Bishop C3 no the
queen was on E5 and he played Queen F5
it was lerman's move oh oh sorry sorry
now Bishop C3 okay and now Bishop C3 I
thought he was like sacrificing some
idea Bishop B4 or something but um in
any case yeah this just looks this looks
pretty kapoot so we're going to see this
be over soon another game that looks
like it might be over soon Maurice is
over already in fact big results tatev
abrahamyan has won her game and taken
the lead in the woman's side at least
for the moment she did have this great
position against young Agata and she
played Rook to E7 a a dominant move and
it turns out that Linderman has also
resigned in his game so we knew that was
coming but this one let's quickly get to
the results Knight to C5 was played and
now Bishop to D5 look at those Bishops
is lording over the position the D6 Pawn
way too strong Bishop to E6 and she just
played D7 a monster blow releasing this
piece everybody's guarding this D6 this
D7 pawn and something's going to land on
a C7 Square The Rook just has nowhere to
go what do you play here it's just a
miserable position a completely crushing
ending to this game by tatev abrahamyan
who's still looking for her first
championship what a way to start very
very nice indeed and again uh we're
seeing some real aggression in this
round one I mean uh any games looking
drawsh do you you mentioned that the
defending Champion Arena Crush was down
upon but it does seem like she has very
good champ of holding that she has a lot
of activity so in The Rook ending yeah
if you want to pull that up while we're
waiting for some of our special guests
absolutely so yes the
neova um putting the pressure on Arena
crush and you know neova also a very
strong candidate I think in this
Championship You Can Tell She's really
serious about her game yes um she like
I've mentioned the professionalism with
Nazi because you see that same
professionalism in mova I have the
feeling she prepares quite hard for this
tournament and she also is a Webster
student absolutely well I I saw uh her
playing in the bill wri open here in St
Louis a few weeks ago and uh she played
um some very very good chess she tied
for third uh with three wins one loss
and a draw I believe um I think uh she's
she's yeah one of the favorites uh for
the title I I see uh Arena and Anna is
the big favorites but neova is one of
them who can really um
challenge but I feel that uh Irene is
going to hold the balance here but let's
uh um go to our Our Guest uh the first
winner in the US Women's just
Championship tat abam and she's with
Maurice
Ashley indeed thank you guys one of the
women who You' absolutely say has a
clear outside chance to win this
tournament but of course it's only round
one TV welcome to the show you had an
interesting game today it seemed very
sharp kind of the kind of style you like
when did she go wrong I thought she went
wrong with night A3 but I was just told
it's a good move she just didn't play
well after um well I was really focused
on taking on D6 Pawn but at some point I
realized even if I take that pawn it's
not anything special but after she
allowed me to play5 I think I'm just
crashing there had a great position
finished it in good style uh how
important was it that you win this first
game you have an extra white in the
tournament what was your attitude going
in I it's always nice to win the first
game first game and the last game is
always nice to win um I mean playing one
of the low low rated players it's good
to start a win your chances people have
talked about this before you've been
very close to winning this tournament
before what are your thoughts coming
into this tournament you know there
there's so many chances what do you see
for yourself this year I mean I'm not
sure I just had such a bad tournament
this year but I think this year it's
going to be a different tournament
because previously it's been a race
between Ana and Irene and I don't think
that's going to be the case this year I
think it's going to be very close and
it's going to be more like a real
tournament than just uh two people why
do you say that cuz we have a lot more
stronger people playing with n Pak I
mean a lot of people don't know her in
the US but she's a very impressive
player she's a she has a very impressive
resume she's one came in second last
year she did but I mean she hasn't
played a lot so I think a lot of people
are not familiar with her but she's a
well-known player and n has been I think
she's been studying more and been
playing better so I think it's going to
be more level even though crush and
zansi are much higher rated than the
rest of the field I think it's going to
be more even this year so a tough feel
well we thank you for joining us and
wish you the best in the rest of the
games thank
youan after a flying off to a flying
start uh looking good so far thank you
uh Maurice and thank you tatv uh finally
we've been waiting for this for a long
long long time when when was the when
was F be going to strike with Knight
takes F7 and again we've been talking
about var's uh time trouble and after um
Bishop B5 Rook went back to d8 look at
this
one now he did it Knight takes F7 now
it's just a straight up score yeah like
one that you would see in the the
tactics books right exactly and one you
would find in Blitz Jess uh
automatically after Rook G7 you find not
I mean because because your eyes
geometrically you would be drawn to this
idea that the there is a an in an issue
of skew on the seventh rank so geometry
and remember the peripheral vision on
the clock as
well would would give you the seven tips
that's right and here is Champ hiar
Nakamura with the second win in the US
CHS championship and we are seen some
really impressive wins by the favorites
with white he's with Mari
Ashley
well we're with the reigning Champion
Hikaru Nakamura one of the top players
in the US certainly one of the best
players in the world and iaro today's
game it looked like you really put on a
positional Masterpiece there before
exploding tactically yeah uh I think
overall it was a pretty straightforward
game for the most part I think for me
the only difficulty was at some point it
looked like there should be a uh some
sort of tactical shot something that
would win on the spot and it wasn't
there so I kind of had to just go back
and try and grind a positional Advantage
um but but yeah overall uh it was pretty
pretty easy on on my end I mean it was
much harder to defend than it was to
play as white white down the pond but
with a lot of compensation absolutely
the move D5 was certainly scintillating
what are your thoughts about we saw you
when when Wesley was playing against
Gada you you seem to have a little look
on your face there that was like oh whoa
did a car run over somebody what were
your thoughts when you looked at that
game uh yeah I was kind of just
surprised that got lost so quickly I
mean obviously Wesley at least nowadays
is is is definitely considered to be a
better player than got but I was just
surprised to see how quickly he lost uh
because especially when got tries to
play solid positional chust um usually
he doesn't lose that quickly but uh
Wesley played a great game so I mean
that just I guess the the correct result
any fatigue from playing the candidates
you just played a big tournament there
any any let down from the CH from the
candidates are you looking at the US
Championship very seriously and
everything's in the past um I think uh
well well not not to speak negatively of
the tournament but I think if uh every
single player here was as strong as they
were in the candidates it would be uh it
would be very tiring but fortunately
some of the players perhaps aren't
aren't aren't as strong as some of the
players in the candidate so on in that
sense it's a little bit easier to play
but still uh mentally it's of course uh
I'm definitely tired from the candidates
it was a very long tournament and uh and
very stressful compared to a tournament
like the US Championship but still I
mean there are a lot of good players
here so I'm just looking forward to uh
to trying to have a good result is it a
three- horse race is it just that simple
it's going to come down to the top three
players who plays the best uh
objectively I would say that I think
that's true I think the only player who
who who could possibly uh shake that up
would be uh Ray Robson he's he's quite
capable of playing extremely good chust
when he's on form so I think he also
might have a shot but for the most part
I think uh there there is a reason that
three of us are so much higher rated
than everyone else and uh and I think
most likely one of us will win ter well
thank you so much enjoyed your game and
best of luck in the rest thanks
hikaro Nakamura four-time Champion
current defending Champion he's the one
to beat here in this tournament yeah
hikaro you didn't go into the
confessional Booth but if you had gone
into the confessional Booth would you
have had made a con confession about
this game was there any point in the
game where maybe things didn't go your
way uh well well first of all I mean I
think I would State quite clearly that I
don't think the confessional box is a
good idea um I'm I'm not a fan I I tried
it during Norway chess and also the
singfield cup and if anything I think
it's a distraction because you have to
be focusing on the game and when when
you go into like the confessional box
you you tend to have uh more normal
thoughts I would say that are not
related to just and I think that's uh
that's not a good thing when when your
mind is uh thinking about too many
things at once so so for me I mean I I
don't intend on using the confessional
during this tournament all right you
well you can always use it well you can
always use it when your opponent's like
almost about to resign like that's what
I would recommend like if it's it's like
if you know sometimes when people are
just keeping to play a couple moves just
for the fans like if literally it's like
really like uh completely Kut for
somebody who doesn't like it to get out
of their game though that's that would
be my suggestion to them or or like or
conversely you could go like like the
second move or something but that you
don't really want to give up any time
right the best time would be like
literally before your opponent resigns
well one of the things that hiar was
just saying right there is we take a
look at the confessional made by uh favy
he's being quite witty yeah right so
it's taking him away from the game
because he wants to say something
that's cute funny interesting right and
when you know hikaru's got his game face
on you know like he's super super
focused he he doesn't want to don't want
to be thinking about the lawrences and
the alexandras exactly of the world you
know you put that to the site but I was
gonna say Fab Fabby by the way is really
closing in what I think is a winning
game and I don't know if they've made
time control yet so the confessional is
working out well for him in it game yeah
it has you know some people like to get
out of the zone for a minute because it
helps them clear their heads so just uh
teach his own um let's keep our eye on
this game because it does look like it's
going to be finishing up any second we
see that we we've seen lots of classic
tactics in this game you know you
mentioned the skewer and now we've got
the pin well let's see how that uh skew
did actually work out it worked out
brilliantly of course for Fabby as he
did play this move Rook G7 and picked up
this night by the way not note that the
king went to A7 didn't have to go there
a long time ago there's really no
purpose to putting the King on A7 it's
just that he needed a couple of quick
moves and that's what cost him later in
this in this contest after this this
exchange now suddenly the king if it was
on B8 would still be defending the
Knight on C7 exactly King King turned
out to be worst plays uh on few moves
were played here though we should keep
going and after Rook takes Rook takes uh
and there we have seen the handshake as
Fabiana Carana all three favorites
looking the first to win dominant I not
only winning their games winning their
games in nice style and winning the
first three games of the round right
this is real power chess and these three
gentlemen uh looking great in round one
I mean they're they're beating opponents
who are tough players and they making it
look easy now Fab's going to find that
the only pain that he's really going to
feel in today is um getting quizzed by
Maurice on Lawrence and Alexandra
yeah what bet did you lose that you had
to state that um okay after uh Queen
takes E6 this killing blow Bishop to D5
The Rook on C7 obviously pinning the
bishop on B7 to the King on A7 and
that's a terrible absolute pin after
Rook uh B8 Queen F7 a few Spike checks
before uh Bishop
recognizing it's all over C2 C3 and the
bishop on B7 is lost and this is where
that's right and I can't I can't take
your your Bishop on D5 because of the
pain no this is we do have some some
listeners are varying levels and what I
like about this game is even at the
super Grandmaster level you see these um
basic tactics that are coming up in the
game there's the pin there's the skewer
it's all the same tactics it's just on a
higher level AB oh absolutely and uh
double attacks and things like this so
VAR not happy with the outcome of his
opening experiment today I think he he
had a decent position um just missing
this move H5 was practically decisive
and Maurice more thoughts on this first
round well lots of thoughts on the other
games we should just quickly go through
them guys
this position inen Crush looks like
she's going to make a draw in this kind
of rook and pawn ending in this position
Anna Zony managed to get Queens off the
board so even though she's still in
trouble it's not as bad as it used to be
and it looks like she's trying to steer
it into one of those kind of drawers
positions with Rooks on the board so she
looks like she might have a chance there
there was a clear result in the game
with Sabina fer and Alyssa meina we
didn't get into this game too much but
those two strong players ended up
drawing their game and it looks like
it's going to be all over Karissa Yip in
her very first US championship game the
12-year-old is should win this position
look at that Deepa and she's about to
get a queen that's going to cost at
least a piece in this position uh this
this position is losing this trick
Bishop to F3 looks quite nice but after
a check and a queen check she's going to
be able to pick up this bishop with
Queen to D3 so very strong moves here
for white the key being to play this
check and then promote and then come
back so you can show that line uh
because I know my board usually does
something funny when I do that I want to
risk it but that's a great line to show
how she could win this position but the
12-year-old is going to win her very
first game and she's looking quite
confident right now it's got to be a
great start to win your first game in
the US Women's Championship so I guess
that 10 minutes of extra prep before the
game really paid off but yeah let's look
at that that tactic because I did
mention varying levels one of the things
I often tell to my students is that when
you're getting attacked you know look
for ways to trade the queens and and um
in this position the pursuit variation
that Maurice mentioned by playing
Pursuit isn't that like that's that's
more like a looking for like looking for
a Perpetual check the pursuit variation
heard that ter Queen H so Bishop Bishop
F3 and you're threatening the check made
on G2 right yeah which is pretty
annoying because we don't really have a
lot of ways to stop it you well Queen D2
but okay so then the queen G8 check the
king is uh obliged to capture King takes
we make a
queen ah this is where Maurice says that
his uh whenever he promotes there a kind
of a hiccup and and he and he wanted to
point out that after King H7 Queen F3 D3
and queen D3 check picks up the bishop
on F3 and would win the game and yeah
this um and actually this variation did
start on the board and Chris I mean
sorry gorki has played Bishop F3 so a
really key battle here between the uh
the two youngsters and here I think the
problem is that we're going to
anyway somehow get that uh same tactic
with like Queen D7 check if you go to G6
we have um Queen D3 again and if you go
to f8 we have Queen F5 Jack so you keep
getting got um but we do have um another
star Fabiano Carana who was the star of
the confessional Booth he was actually
the only victim so far nobody else has
done anything
we we've got questions for Fabby what
was the bet that he lost that he had to
make that confession and he's with
Maurice a yes with Fabiano Carana who
had us all in heart palpitations at the
candidates when he had such a close
chance he down to the final round to be
able to qualify for that I know Fabi you
don't want me to bring up bad news uh we
just had to bring it up momentarily I
promise I won't bring it up again in the
rest of this tournament anyway but Fab
you got to tell us your undying love to
Lawrence Trent that sounds like a lost
bet what happened and you do that in
confessional it wasn't a lost bet at all
it was a genuine outpouring oh come on
seriously seriously there must have been
something that he's but he's got you not
being able to confess what it was right
now was not as
bad all right that's terrible we're
gonna have to work that out I'm G to ask
Lawrence what it was and get the real
deal behind that one anyway let's get
back to the real chess you played a game
today where he tried to surprise Uris
you in the opening did he yeah I didn't
expect him to play scam Navy and I don't
know if he's ever played it before but
he hasn't at least in the last couple of
years and I checked this line maybe when
I was 8 years old wow yeah kn6 I I
couldn't remember anything and um yeah
I'm not sure if Knight C3 is accurate or
B G4 first is supposed to be played but
in any case I liked my B3 move
um it was pretty bespoke
okay and so you got you got this
position but then the time pressure went
nuts I mean it was just like he had so
little time on the clock and it looked
like you had shots everywhere Knight F7
Knight E6 it's like you you just kept
saying n I'm going to wait and wait and
wait I saw there were options like that
but I thought I should win without any
complications maybe I should have gone
for it though um I mean kn7 was a
blunder but already at that point I
think his position is basically hopeless
well he played this move A5 and the King
marched over to A7 it seemed like he was
just trying to catch up on the clock I
think he wanted to have the option of
Bishop A6 in case I played Bishop takes
D5 and E D5 and then maybe bishop A6 um
which trying to make logical sense of
moves that that really didn't make too
much sense uh so tell me you are one of
the top three players in the tournament
is it a three- horse race we asked
Nakamura this question he said it's a
three- horse race it looks like anyway
maybe Robson gets thrown in I I don't
think it's necessarily a three horse
race I think it's too early to say uh
anything can happen the tournament
someone can uh rise up unexpectedly or
someone could just run away with it um I
think that after one round you really
can't say well we're not talking after
one round we're talking before the
tournament even started okay um yeah in
that case it's even even earlier um yeah
it's it's um I mean let's wait a couple
rounds before we draw any conclusions
did you get a chance to look at the
other two games between
Nakamura his game and also Wesley's game
were you shocked by that result in
Wesley's game after night of five it
already looked awful for black in in
Wesley's game uh I was just surprised
how
quickly the opening went South for G and
how quickly he lost after that I thought
maybe he could drum up some resistance
but I guess he missed G4
and um I'm not sure if he had better
chances to defend all right so what are
you going to do now to Pledge Your
further undying lovees to L Tren um not
sure maybe I'll take him out to
dinner I want to know what the BET was
bit and who's this Alexandra you talked
about a close friend of mine close
friend huh you got some Secrets man
quiet Guy The Quiet Ones always have
some
Secrets he's zipping up guys I can't get
it out of him all right well indeed
congratulations on your Victory and best
of luck in the rest of the games Fabiano
Carana one of the top players in the
world number three on the planet right
now as a matter of fact and trying to
get some rating points maybe go back up
to number two uh with a great Victory
today thank you Faby thank you Maurice
and we have a caller we did do indeed so
uh tell us uh who you are and where
you're calling
from hello hello hello welcome to the
show oh hi yeah hi my name is Atari and
I'm from Ventura
California
um when you guys first off great
commentary and Jennifer shahadi uh you
bring so much to the game thank you um
when you guys did the candidates
coverage you had like this off report
where you guys just talked about stuff
and Alejandro Ramirez and everyone was
talking about ways to modernize the game
one was really impressive I felt which
was to have no uh draws per se and just
have a either a win or a loss mentality
and I was hoping to uh suggest that the
St Louis chess club and maybe
millionaire chess as well commit to that
type of format so that they can
modernize the game um there was a time
when and queens only moved one space uh
it's time to get the game more sexy uh
thank you so much thank you very much uh
basically what the caller was explaining
was that during the today in chess show
uh we had a fireside chat we were
talking about um draw offers and what we
should do should we just replay replay
the game uh immediately thereafter um
lots of radical and good ideas I just
wanted to say that we do have here here
at this event no draw offers before move
30 so it's not quite Sophia rules
players can offer draws after black has
made his 30th move or black can offer a
draw with his 30th move but essentially
we want the players obviously to fight
yes no question this is a great and you
see so many great games but I do agree
with the caller that to make chess more
sexy as he pointed out it'd be fun
especially for tournaments that are
don't have as much star power we really
need to make sure that there's lots of
decisive results in those to keep the
interest in chass so I think experiment
and other events is an absolutely great
idea and I I believe we are going to see
more of that I feel like people are
starting to like put their heads
together and really think let's uh let's
let's go even more extreme than the 40
move or the 30 move Dr and just like uh
try new things what's the worst that
could happen we'll have one event a year
that's not the same as the other 40
right wouldn't that be that that we
don't try again think wouldn't that be
terrible yeah of all of the suggestions
I must say that km janov suggestion
still makes the most sense to me that
you know you start the the game with X
amounts of minutes on your clock and you
just play and if the game is your draw
then you play a second game with the
love it and that's been experimented
before in fact I think in Nashville and
also in the extreme Chess Championship
so but we do have a result in actually
and this could be a historic resolve
because Carissa Yip and gordi I mean I
really think these two women are are
likely to follow in the footsteps of
somebody like Irena Crush who got the
overall grandmas title I mean they're so
young Carissa did win the game um she
had a little uh she did a little long-
winded U maneuver there if you want to
like take a look at that uh the van that
was the Oney simping variation exactly
so she's the youngest player in this
competition she put her first
Grandmaster when she was nine years old
now she won her first game in the
Women's Championship at the age of 12 so
um just a great I mean some people uh
would say you know you shouldn't be
preparing for the game like 10 minutes
before but and you should not but some
different things work for different
people you know karnick said that he
likes to just worth the last minute
really he bad bad bad yeah can't help
himself but by the way is this the
youngest win ever uh by I mean obviously
their first because I think I played
even younger I we we can double check on
it but I think Irena might have played
in one in even younger age but we'll
double check on that um but let's just
go take a look at the uh the because
remember used not to be as competitive
so like even 2100 would get you in and
enena was uh was uh 2100 very young so
um Chris actually had to wait longer
than you would expect to get invited to
this tournament she broke 2200 a couple
years ago but she never actually
qualified till this year I see so and
and here she is indeed and this is the
pursuit variation as you mentioned that
it was a the first the first iteration
she actually played Queen h8 so she had
to actually double track because that's
not as accurate right because after
queen h8 king
G6 now there's um there's everything has
to be with check because is facing
Checkmate in one right and so she
retracked she retracked and now the idea
is if King G6 now you can always play
Queen E6 check and queen H3 defending
the check made in that manner exactly so
I think the lesson there is just because
you made a mistake well in these types
of situations where you have total
control just go right back do it again
exactly the Queen H chick uh in in fact
well it's you can't go back to H7 cuz a
queen F5 check as well and if you do go
to H H5 you mentioned that well now we
can defend G2 with Queen H well we still
have Queen F it's over a lot of winds
here but uh she did take the queen and
then it was just simply a very nice
textbook finish and hopson's choice go
to F7 or H7 and it's Queen F5 wins and
here he is Carissa Yip is with Maurice
Ash to talk about her first Victory here
at the US Women's just Championship the
youngest player on either side of the
Championships young Carissa Yip who beat
a Grandmaster at the age of nine Carissa
it must be something exciting to be in a
tournament like this you're only 12
years old yeah how does it feel I was
really excited when I got the email and
all for the year my dad and I we were
like trying to make into the top 10 wom
and we would like check it every every
day to like see where I was like
standing
and I didn't really want to get in by
like a wild card so my parents and I
were like really happy when I got
invited by rating oh it's fantastic you
earned your way in and now you're here
at this stage you're in St Louis how do
you like your stay so far it's really
nice the hotel's great
and I yeah that's it you had a chance to
eat at any of the restaurant so far yeah
the sushi place nearby is pretty good
okay and we came to the thae once when I
was here for a chess
Camp pretty good fantastic great eats
around this this area now your first
game you have won your first game at
this tournament that's got to be a throw
yeah I mean I was expecting to play
Someone Like really high rated and like
maybe lose my first game but now here I
am did you feel it was a tough game what
what you think were the difficulties in
the game um like in the opening I feel
like I messed up at some point because I
wasn't really sure about the Knight C6
line and the
French and then when I got into the
middle game I think I like made my way
to equal and she just messed up at some
point I got
advantage and then in the end when she
played Bishop at free I was like oh I
missed I'm going to lose you thought
this was a mistake on your part yeah and
I was like wa and I just like calculated
out the whole Queen G8
thing in the end I realized that I could
get the bishop and I was like oh never
mind I'm not lost absolutely that's
great now your thoughts about playing we
asked this question earlier as a young
player do you have any expectations at
all in this tournament that you feel
like maybe you might have a
chance
um well I'm hoping to like get into the
US Olympia team for the world World
teams in the top five ratings
so I just want to like do my best here
and hopefully get top three because my
mom said she'll get me a new
phone well that is a new one absolutely
well we hope you get that phone and more
thanks so much for joining us and best
of luck in the rest of your games thank
you Karissa Yip everyone a new star in
American chess we look forward to her
playing for many years to
come thank you Maurice thank you Karissa
we uh Jennifer and I would both like to
share our congratulations to you in your
start your first start in the ladies
championship in your first
Victory keep up the good work well Yas
thinks that you shouldn't prepare 10
minutes before the game I said whatever
works in this case it worked very well
indeed wow uh we have a hearu mentioned
Ray Robson by the way as a dark horse as
somebody who is capable of winning lots
of games and putting pressure on the top
three uh players today he is playing uh
Alexander Alexander sh shabalov who is
white and Ray is actually a pawn to the
good in this particular game um the
three top players have all won with the
white pieces and uh Ray is doing his
best to show Black's not a bad color to
have uh in a chess game as he's a pawn
to the good uh any chance es here
Jen for him he's just um he's just
enjoying the extra Pawn he still has a
lot of work ahead of course yeah indeed
no I think he it's true white white does
seem to have like some some nicely
placed pieces that kind of keep Black's
activity at Bay most especially these
night this night on
D6 uh is superb oops excuse me and I
can't I I want to figure out a way to
get my knight perhaps to D to
F2 this night
coming sorry to D1 to F2 well that would
be sweet but and now of course it's
pinned
right so it looks like the white swing
oners of course doing a good job of
Defending but another player who doesn't
seem to have done the defensive task
that you had hoped for like shot Shandra
versus Sam Shanklin I was actually also
looking at that game and it looks like
Sam is really on top so we're going to
have a massively decisive day today in
the US Championship which is something
we often expect in the women's field
yeah but it looks like we're going to
get five perhaps uh decisive games here
today is possible real a real treat
indeed um I mean of course the the
results not in yet but uh we do have a
guest uh Katarina mova is with us and uh
she's here to talk about her draw
against the defending champion in top
seed um she's with a crush that's right
she's with marce
Ashley well Katarina mova from Webster
here in St Louis
uh welcome to the show first of all
thank you it's a pleasure to be here you
had an interesting first round you get
the top seed well at least the the
defending Champion four time Champion
four time straight anyway seven time
Champion Arena Crush what were your
thoughts when you got that pair and you
said she's the first one I get right out
of the game yeah I was like it's going
to be a rough start but I played her
also in the championship in
2014 uh in the first round and that
didn't go so well so I wanted to improve
on that well you absolutely did this
time around and you and had her under
some pressure in this game looked like
you had some chances at some point yeah
I thought that I have some Advantage
after before but then it slipped away
there was nothing so I don't know if I
misplayed it or if it was just okay for
black right well she played very finely
to maintain her position there what are
your thoughts about this Championship
itself you got Anna coming back to the
tournament you have Nasi who just seems
like a Powerhouse somebody who's going
to be around for a while and then all
these young kids in the tournament it's
like a 12-year-old already winning and
taking the lead lead in the tournament
what is that I think it's really
exciting to have a strong field you know
to to play uh the top field in us and to
have these young girls that have a huge
potential so I do think that they're
going to be very dangerous your thoughts
about coming into this tournament for
yourself are you thinking I can win this
thing well you have to come with this
attitude otherwise why do why do you
want to play so I I do want to win I do
want to play my best but it's a very
long tournament and it's going to be
dangerous every single game is going to
be difficult well put well
congratulations on today's results a
good start and best of luck in the rest
of the games thank you Karina mova
certainly one of the dark horses in this
tournament I said maybe one of the
favorites she could put together a fine
result guys love the attitude though you
got to believe of well for sure and uh
Kate uh should have the ambition of
meddling or even going for the gold and
today she played a very nice game she
kept uh Arena under pressure and in in
the very end uh she was uh a pawn up in
The Rook ending as well okay uh Arena
was always well within the margin of a
draw but still it's always nice to have
your opponent Under Pressure right
especially when it's arena crash seven
time champion and defending Champion um
of course you want to get the most out
of white but feeling like you at least
put her to the test right oh without
question and let's just go to that game
for a moment because uh uh I'm thinking
of the game of r Robson by the way uh
not Ray Robson um Sam Shanklin I
apologize uh Sam shanklin's game because
I was trying to get uh for Chandra uh a
little a little bit of pressure uh by
utilizing the pawns and by the way they
followed our line to a little uh to a
bit of extent where Sam Shanklin played
the move G3 I was trying to get in this
F4 if you remember um
Jennifer to you know get a little mating
net going if I could put my Pawn on G3
and this move by by Sam in particular G3
appears to be very well timed here I'm
wondering what do you think I'm
wondering why Chandra didn't play F4 I
thought that was his best maybe his only
chance right with the same idea that you
had before right and if you do play B7
well okay now I'll get behind the pawn
you'll go protect your Pawn I'll get out
of the discovered check and if you go A4
well again I've got
these got these ideas of uh harassing uh
White's King a bit and well okay I
thought that it's not that easy to
prevent yeah yeah I thought this was
maybe we could have played F3 the move
before or something um before before we
started before we started all this yeah
we're s of A4 A5 that is okay so if F3
and we do have a special guest so we got
to get to our defending Champion just a
second you're trying to play H5 I I'm
trying to play H5 and so again uh it's
just a
much you don't when you're winning you
don't want your opponent to get any
chances and this looks a little bit more
Awkward uh it's not as smooth as what
you may want so some enterprising ideas
here for aot but I think he might have
some in the game too we'll have to see
but right now we've got our defending
Champion Arena Crush she's with Maurice
Ashley indeed we're with a seven time
Champion Arena Crush Arena welcome to
the show thank you Mars uh this game was
a tough one your opponent really sort of
put it to you in the game there were
some chances for her but you seem to
neutralize it and get into an ending
that made everything okay um it was a
good fighting game it was interesting um
I don't think I had any problems there
because right from the opening if I
wanted to I could have taken the pawn on
C2 and just traded off all the pawns uh
it would have been a draw immediately so
I I just you know I had a big decision
there spent a long time and I decided to
play The Rook end game down upon uh
because Karina didn't have a lot of time
and I thought you know I was active and
if things go well um if she makes some
inaccuracies um in time pressure you
know might have a chance to win she
actually played that part of the game
really well
and what was the worst case scenario for
me happened where I had to just uh hold
a rook end game down a pawn but always
with an active Rook so it's not uh very
difficult now coming into the tournament
you have a Target on your back I mean
you've had a Target on your back the
last several years how do you manage
those expectations for yourself knowing
that anything short of a win for you is
not really a successful tournament
that's true that's really the only
result that feel successful um well you
just come in and you try to do what you
what you have to do to win you do your
best
and that's it what else can you do is
there there magic recipe that I don't
know about morries I'm asking you you're
the seven time Champion you come in you
play your games you do your best you
take it seriously you give it what you
can you try to you know I I think today
um I was I'm pretty happy with the way
the game went because yes it could have
been over in 30 moves um I took a little
bit of a risk but the more time you
spend at the board uh during the first
game the more um you sort of find your
your form right um and uh you kind of uh
get some practice by staying at the
board a bit longer so I'm I'm happy with
the way that worked out I didn't really
have any winning chances today as turns
out I don't know the opening it's uh all
comes down to that and I would have to
take a look at that let's talk a bit
about Anna zon's return to the
tournament everyone uh appreciates
having the best players in the country
participating how do you feel about her
now coming back does it make it
a bit more of a challenge do you reflect
on her presence in the tournament in any
way you know um I just feel like
everything is normal because I'm used to
Anna playing here I mean she's played
here almost uh I mean every year except
last year so it was more like of an
abnormality when she wasn't here last
year so now I just feel like things are
back to normal is it less pressure on
you or more pressure on you that you
know seeing that she's she wasn't here
last year there was a lot of pressure on
you to definitely close that one out cuz
your main rival wasn't here you feel any
less pressure cuz she's here to just
play chess no I mean nothing changes uh
whether you know she's here or not I
still want to win so
um yeah nothing has changed from last
year speak to the youth movement in this
tournament it's incredible five players
16 and under in the tournament I mean I
remember you won your first at 14 how
strong were you how young were you when
you first played in this tournament I
was 11 the first time I played in it in
1995 in Modesto California did you win
any games in that tournament I think I
scored two and a half out of nine did
you win any games that's a good question
I don't remember maybe it's possible I
made five draws um I'm not sure but I
think the way it went you know it was it
went from Two and a Half to four and a
half to eight and a half right well
we're trying to remember because Karissa
having won her game today may be the
youngest winner in the tournament
history but you you may be the one who
actually did it yourself at 11 years old
but still the youth movement here is
absolutely I think it's great to have
all these young players here and they
add a lot of interest to the tournament
and you can see you know how beneficial
this experience is for them you know
playing um well generally higher level
players and getting that experience of
playing around Robin preparing for the
games it's it's a great experience for
them so we've got 10 rounds to go what
are your thoughts about the rest of the
tournament I guess I can guess at it
already but yeah guess what I'm going to
say morrice try to guess you're going to
say I'm going to you know you're going
to do your best arena and yes that's
exactly what you know I'll try to do so
try to play H good games I've got um I
have three out of four black games the
first four rounds so you want to try to
get past those with a decent number of
points and then uh make use of your
white color absolutely well thank you so
much for joining us and best luck in the
rest of the games Arena Crush seven time
champ uh decent draw just to start it
off and of course she's always saying do
my best one game at a time yes we have
heard that before but of course Arena
shows us that she comes to win every
game but we might have one of the moves
of the tournament that happened while
they were chatting actually it is
getting really really hot in here let's
take a look and see what Ray Robson
played after this move Knight E8 by um
Alexander shabal sure we thought that
Ray had a lot of work cut out for him
obviously he's a pawn up but uh black
pardon me whites pieces both The Rook on
A6 as well as the Knight on D6 gave him
uh sign significant compensation for the
pawn then um Shabba played the move
Knight E8 which looks okay you're ready
to reroute the Knight you're attacking
The Rook on C7 the pawn on A7 is under
attack and it's almost like a puzzle uh
black to move and Seize the Day car
beautiful just a beautiful move night I
mean you guys probably already seen it
this gorgeous move kn2 which combines so
many different tactics right
discovered attack on The Rook on C1 and
there's also a um a threat of just
Knight to G1 which is a pretty pretty
mating pattern indeed Knight to G1 check
King has to step up to H4 but then the
important Knight F3 check you're not
going anywhere come on back come on back
King H3 and then suddenly Rook takes H2
Checkmate literally out of thin air and
Ray Robson uh with this move Knight E2
basically wins it's over let's look at
the other variation where the Knight
could take on C7 instead cuz that's also
an unusual I mean of course then you
could take the Rook but of better than
that you've got um the same checkmating
pattern well I want I want to do it with
the bishop though the bishop there's a
bishop coming to E7 oh oh you like oh
that's a
nice how about that one right I mean
that one's like is so unusual just
dropping that Bishop back to E7 to give
the Checkmate um got to love it and wow
he Carl seems to be right about stuff
he's like yeah you know Robson might be
on fire 10 minutes later Robson quickly
uncorks 92 I mean I don't think he took
very long to play it I can double check
to see the time stamps but um I think he
anticipated that opportunity in case uh
Shabba made that error wow uh we we are
really getting a a treat as the players
uh really a lot of blood on the board in
this the opening round my goodness uh
gorgeous we're spoiled spoiled the move
I mean I you got to love this move this
one is one the one I love about this is
it's it's Democratic like you can show
this to a super high level player and
they're going to be this is stunning
yeah this is I show this to somebody who
learned who's like not who's kind of you
know 1500 1300 and they're going to
think it's gorgeous too yeah so I I love
it ni and we do have we have a draw in
the game between Alexander onos shuk and
Jeffrey Jang um
impressive was pressing a little bit in
an end game but um young Jong managed to
hold him down uh upon behind he he
played very very well indeed I mean and
Alex onuk is used to pressing and um
winning these favorable endings so a
very impressive save or hold if you want
to say by Jeffrey in his first US
Championship so I got to ask you put you
on the spot 92 2 or D5 what's the move
of the round I mean this you mean this
D5 move by Hikaru that was pretty good
too but I like the sacrifice night F5 by
Wesley none of the above none of the
above I mean look I mean come on uh
you're playing gotsky Five time US
champion and you go bam Knight F5 and
sacrifice of Peace followed by Bishop
H6 that that's that's impressive stuff
that's really good stuff it's a good
rounde I mean you could say you we could
be the Midway through the tournament and
say what was your favorite move in the
tournament so far we're not even all all
the way done with with game one and
right still games in being played I me
in terms of like the entire game I think
you got to go with maybe nakamura's game
because one of the funny thing about
nakamura's game is that you know I was I
was terrified when Maurice asked him
about the game like I I was sure
Nakamura was going to say it wasn't a
very good game cuz remember he remember
he said that last time like last year we
we were like Wow E car played really
good today and he was like yeah average
game but today he was like yeah this was
pretty good game I thought it was a
master class I really did I think
thought he played very well but that's a
little bit of the problem I thought it
was a bit too one-sided whereas I
thought the position that got to camps
he played he played this move Queen d8
looks looks reasonable looks reasonable
Queen d8 and you just had to play
beautifully as Wesley did and the uh
final move was quite a blow G4 as well
and we do see on our webcam that uh
shabalov has lost to Ray Robson as Ray
Robson the only winner so far with black
animal instincts I got to love that move
that might be my favorite because you
know four hours into a game finding
those tactical resources like that just
pouncing um that's what makes CH a sport
yeah opportunistic and that is quite a
nice nobody Taps you on your shoulder
during the game and says now now you
have the combination and he was he we
saw 92 and the Beautiful checkmating
patterns that we showed and we do have
Jeffrey Jang who's with us and he has um
held Alexander ones to a draw today in a
very interesting game he's with a
Grandmaster Marius Ashley well with the
youngest player in the US championships
Jeffrey Jang Jeffrey welcome to the show
thank you you had an interesting game
right out the gate you get to play
against Alexander Onish sh first time A
one- Time Champion already of this
tournament how did it feel going into
into the game uh of course when I drew
the uh Lots I got a little bit of an
unfortunate uh number I basically start
the tournament off with two blacks and
then here against ownership absolutely
great player very strong and I was just
trying to come into the game and play
solid so how' you feel when the game was
going on did you get over the nerves did
you like get up starry lights I mean the
US Championship after all or you feel
like you know what I'm just playing
chess uh at the beginning definitely
there were some nerves but you know as I
started playing then it started to feel
more like chess and I got comfortable
did you ever feel at any point in the
game that like you might lose this game
like your heart Yes actually uh in some
moment yeah I thought I was at risk he
got quite a promising attack and played
some really strong powerful moves but uh
was fortunate enough to save it when you
come into a tournament like this one
there's there some of these guys are
Must Be Your Heroes I mean great players
who's your favorite player by the way
are there any of the American players
who you you patter your style after or
you follow as as a favorite when you're
watching them play in World Class
stage uh pretty much all of them to be
honest I mean I don't have any specific
uh guy that I uh follow his his uh style
but uh yeah the top three players in the
world they all have uh I learned so much
from them so studying their games now
you're getting the chance to play
against all of them you will get a
chance uh did you come into this
tournament like a secret wish maybe I
could win it all do you think like that
at all uh no not I'm trying to avoid
thinking too much about results just
trying to play good chess and learn as
much as I can man these kids learn young
already answering the question in a
professional way right well we really
appreciate seeing you here and we look
forward to seeing the rest of your games
thank you Grandmaster Jeffrey Jong all
of 15 guys what were you doing at 15 me
I was barely I barely knew how to move
the pieces then I'm trying my best to
graduate high school I wanted to ask
Jeffrey a question uh Jeffrey because it
was a great shot that you had in the in
the game it was a just a on the 18th
move you played after Knight takes E6
Knight D3 check I would like to confess
that I didn't see that move and that was
a critical move without that move you
would be in deep trouble
uh how long had you anticipated that
move had you seen that move well in
advance yes I saw it after I played uh
Queen A5 actually basically this was all
pretty much forced and even this
position afterwards I think I'm still a
little worse but of course it was the
only move at that point great move
absolutely great move in the position
we're used to seeing you play great
moves uh and again we wish you the best
of luck in the rest of the games thank
you very impressive you you saw after
Queen A5 a whole series of moves leading
to Knight D3 check calculated it very
well Jennifer very impressive I yes uh
very very what can I say just very
impressive yeah who was talking about
calculation earlier in the tournament it
was Fabby or something they were talking
about or Wesley was talking about um how
many moves ahead they see and how a lot
of times it's more looking at the
different options and then then seem
very far ahead I think that was Wesley
yeah but it's a it it was judgment too
right he just had this sense that two
pawns very powerful knight and this
bishop on B7 is just his nose just told
him that position's got to be good for
him even if he didn't see all the
resources are analyzing it's just great
judgment right exactly that's really a
true sacrifice I mean when when people
no sacrifice yeah and you sacrifice the
queen and like a couple moves later you
win back the queen well that's not
really a sacrifice shamp yeah a fake one
fair enough um we do have Alexander onuk
with Grandmaster Maurice Ashley but with
a former US Titleist he's won this
championship before Alexander oneschuk
multi-time representative in the the US
for the US team in the
Olympiad these kids are good I know yes
what was it like playing against young
Jeffrey Jang today 15 years old playing
in his first championship what are your
thoughts going into the game before the
game I thought ideally I should trade
Queens at some
point and and try to squeeze in the end
game but you know actually he he I think
I was much better out of the opening but
then then he played a very good game
it's incredible the youth movement in
American chess has really come a long
way hasn't it yeah yeah uh we have so
many talented kids like uh Sam San
jeffre and Kaden trough and and and many
more so it's you know it's a good sign
when you came into a tournament like
this one you you're sort of not uh
you're not one of the favorites anymore
like one of the tip top favorites Anyway
by rating do you think of it maybe I can
show something though and maybe win the
tournament you know I I realized today
that I'm not one of the favorites I mean
this three top guys they they won so
easily incredible it's incredible yes um
so so I guess my goal in this tournament
is to finish
fourth well we're expecting a little bit
more than that from you but we
appreciate your cander there thanks so
much for joining us thank you Mar
Alexander onuk one of the gentlemen of
Chess absolutely one of the finest
Representatives we have with the US team
maybe his wife will buy him a new phone
if he comes in the top four there you go
what did Clin would say a man's got to
know his
limitations uh aspiring for fourth no
don't believe him
he Alex will look for his chances if
they present themselves but uh boy when
you play a 15-year-old Jeffrey and you
played it so well uh turning a a slight
disadvantage and held it throughout very
impressive or but I mean even more um
just like looking at how the top seed's
played today just three gorgeous games
right it's really looking love it yeah
why they're all star and and we have
another special guest yes good
sportsmanship of course by Alexander
shabalov um inducted in the Hall of Fame
last year playing the tournament by
virtue of winning the US Open this year
about a little disappointment today he's
with marce
Ashley well let's not forget that he's
won this Championship four times he
knows how to win this tournament but
Alex coming out the gate today you
played enterprising chess sacrificed
upon fing k j Knight on B7 even uh in
the game at least in the White Knight
what happened though what turned us
around yeah it was a lot of fun uh uh
pretty long it went uh along the
preparation you know along all the lines
and uh then I couldn't remember exactly
how to uh get computer shows the
advantage but I just like uh and then I
thought uh what I did was pretty good
until realized that I miss Bishop C1
Bishop C1 was certainly a stly move
right I'm kind of suspecting now then
instead of Rook A5 Queen B1 was much
stronger but well I don't know got to
look at it when a move like that lands
on the board you notice you didn't see
it what are your thoughts uh my first
thought is was like okay I didn't see it
but now it should be a draw cuz you know
I thought it was much better and then I
realized that
no
no it's kind of too late and then I
believe uh Ray uh was not really
convincing in time trouble and let me
back in the game and well until the
second wonder I mean in this tournament
you blunder twice I me that's enough I I
would say so really nice movie play
though playing that move KN to E2 that
must have just come as a shocker when
you saw it yeah I I looked at all kinds
of a checkmates I understood that H5 was
was the idea of you know some tactical
checkmat just 92 like completely you
know uh it weighed me
like for some reason uh it was a square
I never considered interesting people
think that grand Masters see everything
for some reason but we do miss moves
like that one uh looking at this
tournament you've won so many times but
you you haven't uh gotten to to grab
this one this title for a while do you
have some real aspirations coming into
the tournament
I I hope so you know certainly not out
there beginning like this but uh uh yeah
I took it really seriously I uh since I
qualified already in August at half time
I I knew what's coming you know so uh I
prepared really really seriously I mean
hopefully it's not going to go like this
till the end so well we know you play
extremely enterprising chess always
entertaining for the fans we wish you
the best of luck and not miss any of
those 92 moves for the rest of the no
not again Alexander shabala one of the
great gentlemen and chess back to you
guys thank you thank you Alex yeah that
was that's that's good some real
definitive answers there not one game at
a time just like no way none of that
anymore I love it um we do have a couple
of uh feedbacks and uh questions coming
in so um let me take one from um
somebody who left a message actually um
Tom from Pennsylvania oh another PA
listener um he said that um what advice
he asked that rather what advice would
you give to other cities in the US to
try to emulate St Louis success in
making chess so popular well of course
um you can't just copy paste people in
the the S fields are are so instrumental
to the massive success here and at the
St Louis J and it's not just the sing
Fields really uh at the opening ceremony
I was really once again uh hit uh by uh
the mayor Francis slay here he's come to
every single of event one of the very
best Mayors in the country he supported
chess he supported chess in the schools
he's been really one of the great
cheerleaders and you
can't but you know thank graciously
thank uh when you have the political
support of the city council and the
mayor I think that that is like you know
step one and then got the year of course
and the the chess history in St Louis
but not to be negative there is a lot
you can learn from the example here of
course there is just the respect that
they give to the chess players and
treating chess as a profession and the
positive atmosphere that they cultivate
both here right and um you know uh Rex
shared with me a rule that um he has in
business and it's called the the no um
exploit of role and you you definitely
see that here that everybody is just
nice yes and that really helps Foster
this environment um I do I do hear that
there's
more um action in a lot of other cities
in America like um North Carolina
they've got like the Charlotte chess
Center and they also have a grandmas and
residence program there so it does seem
like it's uh spreading to other cities
this idea that chess is a sport and
chess is popular and hey we're even
going to have the world championship
here in the United States city we can't
looking forward to that but we have a
special guest in our studio that's right
we have a Grandmaster Ray Robson um he
is with marce Ashley about the first win
with black in the whole competition
yes and first of all we would be remiss
if we didn't remind our viewers that Ray
Robinson has won uh in the Collegiate
level four years in a row people talk
about the University of Connecticut
women in basketball being a dominant
Force Ray you have been on a great team
so far congratulations on your on your
college team winning the championship
again thank you but on to the US
Championship the national championship
this game you yet to play against a
four-time former champ but you played
him before what was it like playing with
the black pieces and this by a line he
chose to play yeah um yeah I've played
Alex many times and usually if I get
caught in the opening I get crushed and
if I survive then I do I do okay so that
was my goal but um I think I was kind of
caught in the opening and um probably he
was better somewhere but I felt after he
played A4 and I played Bishop H6 and was
able to keep my dark sored Bishop I
thought I was fine although maybe he
disagrees and after that when I was up a
pawn um basically I thought I'm playing
for two results and um no matter what I
can always get to like an end game with
a pawn up where I can try to squeeze
that move Bishop C1 he said he didn't
see that one coming and he suddenly
realized the danger of it when did you
see Bishop C1 it's funny because I
actually Bishop C1 was kind of a last
resort I thought um when I played Knight
C3 and he played Queen A1 I thought I
could just play Knight E2 check King H1
C3 and it looks like my Pawn is marching
really quickly down to C1 but then I
think he has a really strong move Rook
A2 which I had missed so basically I was
kind of upset I thought I was almost
winning and um then I saw some ideas
like with KN coming to C1 then I
realized I could play Bishop C1 and I
figured it's still the best chance to
keep some some Advantage oh interesting
people always say we we mentioned this
before Grand Masters see everything and
sometimes it's like no we don't but we
come up with something at the very end
you won with the black pieces you seem
to often win with the black pieces is it
because of your opening choices with BL
um
maybe my opening choices and my style I
mean in this game I you know Alex is
known for being a very combative player
and um this was like a pretty um
aggressive line that he played and I
could have chosen a more solid option
but I also wanted to go for um uh kind
of all three results in this game so I
guess it's my opening choices and also
just my my style absolutely we love your
style we love the fighting CH fighting
openings you play we we knew we have a
top three here in this event no question
about it you just have to look at the
numbers and say these guys are the
highest rated players what do you think
of when you're coming in a tournament
like this you played what is it your
10th time already is it has it really
been that long oh I think it's my ninth
ninth time still you're baby and you've
been here nine times already do you
start thinking you know what I've got to
win one of these does those thoughts
start to cross your mind now that you're
really a veteran of this event yeah I
played my first US Championship when I
was um 12 or 13 then uh I played here at
the club the first time when I was 14
and I would have thought then that every
year I'd be getting stronger and I'd
have a better chance to win the
tournament and I have been getting
stronger but um fortunately the
competition has also been getting a lot
stronger Wesley came last year and then
Fabiano joined again this year so yeah
um yeah hopefully eventually I'll I'll
get my my chance but uh I mean even last
year you know I was close to at least
getting to a playoff with the aru um
this year it's going to be even more
difficult but um still just try to do my
best but when we said to Hikaru is it
about three people in the tournament he
said sort of but is also Ray Robson to
consider so great praise there we look
forward to seeing you continue in this
trend and best of luck in the rest of
the tournament thank you Ray Robson big
Ray four-time Collegiate Champion you
can't do any better than that unless you
know you stay a long hang out in college
too long like I did but he's definitely
off to a scintillating start Ray Ray I
got to ask you a question about just the
final move when your opponent played at
Knight
E8 uh tell us your thoughts as you
relish the opportunity to play night
E2 that's also funny because I had
obviously seen when I played H5 I have
kind of all these mating ideas and I had
seen Knight E2 but I hadn't realized
that it's mate because I thought Knight
E2 and then I he takes my rook and I
play Knight G1 check King H4 and I see
if I play Rook H2 check he can still
escape with his King and at some point I
realized oh I can just play Knight F3
check and it's mate so maybe knight2 is
just winning because before I had I
thought if I just move my Rook I'm still
much better but after he played 98 I
realized 92 is just completely
over so once again not necessarily
seeing it all but playing good enough
chess positionally that made it work for
you certainly a nice finish one of the
moves of the tournament that we'll
remember indeed we will thank you Ray
and congratulations very nice so have we
seen four men's victories yes four
victories in the championship where
where do we stand at the moment in terms
of the matchups and uh what has happened
only one draw un sh was the only draw
and it looks like it's going to be the
only draw because Sam changlin um oad
didn't manage to find the counterplay
lines that we were trying to find for
him yeah I mean what he's drummed up
seems like it's going to be too little
too late I see but we can take a look
but so this is the current position that
we have with the uh sole remaining game
and we've just seen a move by Shandra
what has he played not quite sure I'm
just going to he's played King to F5
okay very good
yeah so I just had to refresh the board
and there we have it King
F5 and he's just trying to play he's
trying to play like some kind of H3 and
then Rook takes F2 check trying to get
in into some counter BL
I see but I see what you're saying in
terms of probably being too slow I could
play for example move like Rook here
push King and I think I'm just getting
this guy before you
can well wait a minute have I really
blown it maybe I I blew it I thought I
was winning The Rook which I am but this
is not the way to win the uh tour win
the
game uh
yeah because you're getting in a little
bit too close let's let's let's try this
with a little bit better
technique okay good enough sorry you bet
no I just wanted to say there's still
some tricks there don't give up all your
pawns if you don't have to King F5 King
F5 Rook h8 what was this that we were
looking at we're looking at H3 check but
can we so if we play King
G3 um Rook
check yeah now and now and if you go
there Oopsy Daisy and if we go H2 and if
you go to H2 well then I'll go back with
the with the Rook to B2 and I'm still
harassing the pawn if I get Rook takes
Pawn check in
well it's going to be fun I suppose or
maybe it's not going to be fun maybe
this is where you go A6 yeah it seems
like you're a mve behind in the
variations we just looked at cuz your
king is so much further away right
exactly so if you play Rook takes F2
check here we just play Oh King yeah we
can just play King G
G1 and I think that uh the pawns are
going to win yeah because G3 we can
always just play Rook takes H3 the fact
that your King's not as close seems like
it's kind of a problem right yeah H that
looks good enough yes uh should be
winning for white and Sam's the guy to
calculator yes yes indeed know known as
a very strong calculator meanwhile in
the Championship the women's chion we
got a couple games left we've got one
between Jennifer y Andria swar which we
haven't paid a lot of attention to um
but it does look very very balanced with
the three pawns for each side and Bishop
first Knight both of these young women
have played in the tournament before not
not amazing results by either of them in
their in their debuts but I think this
this time coming back with a lot more
experience and this you're Jennifer you
just like Carissa she qualified by
rating not by wildart exactly and uh
well they're growing into their stature
of having qualified and becoming
veterans I'm looking at the Anna
zatonski game I thought Anna was in
terrible terrible shape for a long long
time but it goes to show uh her level of
play that she's still resisting in a
position I thought it was really harsh
hard for her and she's I don't know
she's getting closer and closer uh she's
been trading a lot of PE uh material
down and um maybe she's no longer in the
Lost position I thought she had from way
back I mean I thought she was being
positionally dominated and she's fought
her way back close to equality yeah
interesting you know Anna's very well
known for her fighting qualities that is
that is really one for her Hallmarks you
know she's not the not always the
greatest with the openings just cuz you
plays so many different openings but um
you know you just uh you can't wear her
down she keeps her energy yeah you know
um and we've got Maurice Ashley with his
thoughts on that game well it's a big
moment in the game right now and it's up
to her opponent that is Nazi pitti to
play the key move if she's going to want
to keep some winning chances alive and
that move is a surprising one you see
the check here there are three different
ways to take this rook and the way that
the Eng love is to take with the king
the least obvious choice of all usually
you set yourself up for a discovery you
think no I don't want to do that that
looks too dangerous but by taking with
the King it doesn't matter there are no
great discoveries other than taking this
Pawn with check and you keep everything
in place with this move now the move
King to D4 and black has to be extremely
careful in this position maybe she'll be
able to maneuver her way into an easy
draw but let's take a look Rook to C1 in
this position can now be met by Bishop
cck on h s King over and suddenly King
to the Square E5 and the king is headed
to the F6 square and that's why you want
to take with the King to try to get this
one going so this is an intriguing
position to be sure the move C5 is what
the engine's going with right away but
this Rook will stay on this Rank and
start to get the king to F6 we've seen
endings like capablanca I believe versus
tarda showing the same kind of idea
bringing your king up ahead of the pawns
using your own Pawn as a shield this is
a very interesting position maybe some
drawing chances there but the key move
to look at after King takes D3 uh sorry
takes takes now this move Rook to H5
preventing the king from going into the
position but now you have to face Rook
C7 now is this two against one winning
hard to say y you're the endgame expert
let me know it looks to me that black
should be able to hold this position but
some kind of winning chances certainly
no losing chances for white in this game
yeah well again uh very good uh fighting
ch chess from a very difficult position
by Anna I suspect that's closer to a
draw of course we like white but that
was a nice move King takes D3 the active
King in these endings we've all had
those games where we've managed to bring
our King to G6 as white or King to G3 as
black and get the opponent into a
checkmating box even with reduced
material and the active King being the
decisive Factor uh I think Anna should
be able to keep uh naji's King out uh so
that I think her drawing chances are
higher and sometimes you just got to tip
your hat you know good defense is what
wins championships in in uh team sports
she played a solid move though instead
she played Bishop takes D3 not wanted to
go under that discovered attack and it
looks as though very human move by very
human much more human move that's why we
make this a critical point in the game
those kind of discoveries are the kinds
of moves you have to play in order to
win at the highest level you have to be
willing to walk into those kinds of
moves it's one of those moves that
strong players Miss often uh but the
stronger ones they go into it and by
taking with the bishop she has allowed
herself now with that Bishop on D3 sort
of under attack and The Rook able to
maneuver a little bit more uh in this
position it doesn't work as easily
anymore so looks as though she's going
to have more of a drawing chance that is
Will Anna but taking a look at the time
there there m it's starting to extend a
little bit 5 minutes and change for
zatonski but there she goes hovering
over that pawn she definitely can
capture it in fact ought to capture it
don't want to stay a pawn down uh in
this position although she does have the
option of Rook to
C3 looks a little scary uh to play in
this position she's looking at one of
the two but she certainly wanting to
play Rook takes on C5 and she should uh
what do you think uh Jennifer uh I
always loved it when my opponent's hand
hovered over the piece and they seemed
indecisive I like to see that
indecisiveness uh from my opponent yeah
it shows a little bit of a lack of
confidence sometimes but on other
occasions it's really irrelevant even if
even if it does show that uh you know
how it is in chess it's there's not as
much psychology as there is in a game
like fker right no exactly there's very
limited psychology in the game itself if
you play good mov it's an open game yeah
and that's why we see there such
differing attitudes from the players
like some are like yeah like I'm
probably going to win every game and
some are like no I'm not I don't think
I'm going to get more than x and it's
like in the end it does matter a little
bit but really what matters is what
moves you play yeah good moves beat
psychology every time agreed and we did
see the move Rook C3 by the way from
Anna which is kind of a surprising move
for my from my point of view Rook C3 uh
encouraging white to play the move King
E4 I don't see a better choice Bishop
takes D3 let me just put those moves on
the board Rook takes D3 and I suppose
it's this Rook ending that Anna feels
that she should be able to hold I mean
it's two versus two uh but again it's
about the active white king as well as
active white
rook and we do have a result in Jennifer
U versus sha swaran that game is a draw
two very talented young players here um
and very brightly dressed I love to see
that exactly the brighter the better um
we
uh exactly we'll be I'm always kind of
interested in see what what the players
are wearing new fashion trends here at
the US CH Championship um it does look
like shankland Shandra has gone along
that variation that we discussed with A6
Rook takes F2 and that uh Shanklin is
going to take this one down despite you
know some Valiant defensive efforts here
by by Shandra but just not not enough um
G so let's just play out the variation
um where we left off um to just try to
find some good technique here by white
if black plays a G3 in this position see
I think the simplest is just take that
pawn off the board oops excuse me and
then after King takes
that4 uh should do don't lose actually
H2 check I could probably take on H
nevertheless this looks the simplest
Rook takes King takes and let's just it
would take you a few Mouse lifs to lose
yeah let's just
uh oh wait a minute I don't yeah let's
make a queen right this looks like the
simplest and then do you know suppose I
play Rook
B2 yeah you just have unfortunately
you've got you've got the twofer here
right the twofer what's the T I mean
you've got two you've got two you got
two fast FS right I just have to avoid
one small detail that after King F3 so
maybe right so if I play so if I were to
play A7 for instance I would you would
play probably that Sila wins by the way
A7 is maybe the simplest one I apologize
A7 and in case of King F3 just take on
G3 and you're queening with check oops
Yeah always got to look for those Queen
with check variations it's kind of sad
that we could have made an A8 Queen but
the our Pawn on B7 was blocking it from
being checked so Rook B1 would be mating
right it's kind of like a little bit of
a visual trip there it's not a 5050 I
think this is b80 C Queen resigns so uh
important win for uh for Sam as he
doesn't tie the record mentioned
regarding Anthony S I think he has no
idea about that record of course he
doesn't Ian he's had some good US
championships like he got it the one
where we had it split 8 and eight he got
into that match against Robert H I
remember him qualif Ying being just
absolutely elated with his
qualification and uh now now we are
seeing this variation over the board
work H3 but instead of King to F4 we saw
King G4 instead so Rook takes H3 on the
board and now uh G so G3 Rook H3 yeah
and now King G4 instead of King F4 much
better chance for without question King
G4 uh very annoying when your opponent
uh isn't following the same script that
you're on uh let's see uh can I just
play for the queen yeah you just play
Rook G3 King G3 and B7 you mean oh no I
was just thinking I'm just play for the
queen play for the queen right right
away this way too yeah but well I
suppose after this there's still some
tricky in the position right it's
not that simple oh well maybe I can just
take the pawn and this is not the
technique that I want to to show you but
I mean if it wins it wins right I can
just crawl my way all over to the queen
side and basically it's these two pass
pawns versus The Rook that should be
enough for a win that's right and
uh those two pass pawns are probably
there's even better but meanwhile we
looks like we have a guest in the studio
and I'm trying to remember I can't we've
got it's Jennifer you I believe right no
I Sha esara I I only saw the color of
her shirt so I was like trying to
remember um she is with Maurice Ashley
and I I do love pink pretty and pink
ashria is We on in her second
Championship welcome back to the show
welcome back to the championship welcome
back to St Louis first of all what does
it feel like now you're a veteran your
second time in this tournament uh it
feels great to be back and I'm just
looking forward to playing better chess
than last time when you got the news
you're going to be in the tournament
what did you think prepare go win the
tournament we'll just prepare and play
like better games than last time so you
got this first round match up it could
have been at a world youth championship
of some kind uh what were your thoughts
about this game today uh I think it was
a pretty good game and I think we both
played really well was it uh a result
that's fine for you or or were you
looking for more uh it's an okay result
you have any aspirations at this
tournament uh when you look at when you
look at someone like uh like Arena Crush
she's won it seven times do you thinking
yourself maybe one day I can win seven
times or like what are your Big Dreams
for chess in general just to get the wgm
title in general yeah and are you
thinking World Championship one day or
anything like that in the long run maybe
how much do you play chess at home you
must be a good student um I like play
like maybe two hours each day but not as
much as I used to two hours each day but
that's not as much as it used to what
are you doing these days I have school
stuff so cuz I'm in high school now so a
big responsibility High
School uh two hours every single day how
long have you been doing that for this
like any special training for this
Championship yeah like I've been like
working harder for this Championship
yeah coach uh it's a like there's a lot
of people working behind it it's like
most of it is Dion and also like norel
and like some other coaches too pretty
cool you're in California yeah uh
anybody rooting you on they're following
every single move and ready to help at
all times like really excited for you my
dad who didn't get to come this time oh
no does he suffer while you're playing
these games I don't know oh you got to
know dad must be nervous I'm sure he's
proud you you got a draw today yeah all
right well thanks for joining us and
best of luck in the rest of the gam
thanks Ash we on High School school man
I I really was like a scrub in high
school you understand these these kids
are
talented wow thank you we've just been
uh keeping an eye on the webcam as we've
been seeing Sam shankman and uh Shandra
Shandra uh in this ending and it does
look uh like Sam has wrapped up things
very nicely with his last move Rook G8
check we've seen King H3 on the board
and finally there is the golden
handshake as Sam Shanklin wins his first
game in a extraordinarily bloody round
uh here to start the Open Championship
at least that's right this really shows
how exciting this us championship's
going to be five out of six decisive
games that's absolutely incredible wow
and what games they were yeah reeling
some absolutely great stuff by our three
heavy uh hitters uh by rating they
really showed what they're made out of
and um well Ray and Sam those were my my
two dark horses coming into the
tournament they look really good as well
big results and we've got uh Maurice
asley with Jennifer U she's won gold
medal for the United States and now
she's here to um add to her
accolades welcome well also in her
second Championship a veteran of this
tournament is Jennifer Jennifer welcome
back how did it feel when you first
found out that you were going to play
once again in the US Women's
Championship um I was actually a little
surprised cuz I wasn't sure if I was
going to qualify but I was happy cuz um
I didn't played that good last I played
really bad last year so I this is like
almost another chance for me to play
better like just yeah and you get round
one you play against another Junior I
mean you got a lot of juniors in the
tournament does it feel like a world
youth Championship that then less like a
US Women's
Championship yeah almost I like played I
think yeah I played every single one of
the Juniors so at least once or twice
maybe so yeah
almost now when you play in a tournament
like this one you you said you played
badly last year do you think maybe I'll
turn it around and maybe have a magical
run and do well really well at this
tournament um maybe I don't know cuz
last year I was really nervous and then
this year I'm like more experienced and
so I'm just I also practice a lot so
hopefully I can play better this year
how much how many hours per day do you
work on
CHF
um uh maybe three three hours every day
yeah how do you blend that with school I
know a lot of people are wondering how
how to do that
effectively well I do a lot of my
homework in class
so yeah that's just we I just do um it's
just mostly time management and things
like that wow I I certainly didn't have
it when I was your age I can tell you
that much
uh final question any of these women you
look up to as Heroes the top players in
this tournament and in the women's
tourament or in both you let's let's
talk both well they're both they're all
like um they're all really good Role
Models especially like
um especially for example Arena Crush
like U I think when I first moved here
to Virginia she was around I forgot what
her title was but she got to GM really
fast and I think that's really able how
much work and effort she puts in
fantastic you think you could ever win
seven championships one day maybe I
don't know good answer at least at least
it maybe but we look forward to seeing
more of your games and good luck in the
rest of the tournament thank Jennifer
you 14 years old 3 hours of Chess a day
homework in
class we won't tell the teachers that
very good and we I think we have one
remaining game if I'm not mistaken just
the the fighter on the we're used to
seeing her be the last player in the
tournament Hall that the one year Karu
is the other one and you can almost bet
on will be the last person to play and
Anna looking like she's uh much closer
now to a draw and considering where she
was uh a while ago it's been a a great
save a great save uh it's not over yet
of course and the players again I must
say do not have a third time control uh
they will be playing on their increments
for the rest of the game what you see
there on the clock is all the time they
get for the rest of the game with 30
seconds added for each move
played yeah so we're going to perhaps
see some excitement after our interviews
in this game um let's see na just saw
the move King
E4 uh I think was the last move we saw
by
Nagi but okay uh basically black should
just wait I suppose just say okay how do
you improve your position oh I think it
was a well let me refresh kind of like a
fifth rank filor you got going on here
well I'm waiting you for you to play G5
or something because that or actually
all the way to G6 oops I now I got the
wrong game but meanwhile we have aat
Chandra in studio with mauce Ashley he's
our a US Junior champion and uh he's
with
Maurice one of the great things about
Louis is how many tournaments top
tournaments the the city hosts so aot
it's not like your first rodeo here in
St Louis you've been at this club you've
had a great result winning the US junior
Championship what does it feel now being
in the overall Championship well it's
obviously a great experience I mean
getting to play the top players not only
in the country but in the world as well
so I'm just looking forward to competing
against these guys when you won the
Juniors you knew you're going to play in
this tournament you knew the kind of
caliber opposition that's in this
tournament how'd you feel what you think
what's your first thought like I'm going
to play the best players the country
yeah that's pretty much what it was yeah
I was pretty excited any part of you
thinks that maybe you know I might get a
run and win this tournament well I mean
that's probably looking too far ahead
probably just need to win a game to
start and see how things go then well
today was a tough game you played
against Sam Shanklin won a Gold Medal
winner uh for the for the US Olympic
team what was the game like yeah well I
mean I couldn't remember my preparation
it was really complicated and I ended up
spending exorbitant amount of time and I
was probably okay but then in time
pressure towards the end I probably
aired and The Rook end game was really
difficult but yeah I feel like if I had
more time maybe I could have uh found
some better defensive moves speaking of
time you spent an hour was it an hour on
one move what why were you thinking so
long yeah I
mean I I thought I remember there was
some idea at Rook H7 at some point but
uh I guess I just kind of got mled up
then and too many options so yeah an
hour though that's you got to fix that
cuz otherwise you get into troubl in the
rest of the game course yeah yeah it
shouldn't haveen yeah all right well
certainly uh let me ask you one final
question you look at the the top players
in this tournament who do you see as a
favorite to win it all barring yourself
you know making a run well I mean
obviously they're the top three guys uh
caran and Nakamura and Wesley but um I
mean everyone's capable of winning the
tournaments I don't really think there's
a clear favorite but but uh yeah
everyone's pretty good so anyone can
really win everyone is pretty good well
we look forward to seeing more of your
games yeah thanks and don't think for an
hour anymore all right yeah all right I
remember that AA chanra the US Junior
Champion you know tough games to start
with but he'll be back guys thank you
thank you
uh one hour I'm just I'm just thinking
what was the most time I ever spend on
my clock on a single move I can't really
recall going Beyond 40 minutes how about
you what was your worst Jennifer you
were a Time trouble addict you got a
little bit Yeah you you were on the edge
in some games so maybe you use more you
maybe you use an hour does seem like a
lot though I don't know yeah but uh we
do have a trivia question we had earlier
about Elena apparently in that Women's
Championship from 1995 she did have five
draws so she remembered she had two and
a half right wasn't sure how she reached
it and uh that answer came actually from
our friend Mike Klein over at chess.com
so thanks Mike thank you and that means
perhaps we'll have to confirm this but
that Carissa might be the uh youngest
ever to win a game in the US
championship and she's going to be tied
for first with only one other player
after this round well probably this
would be a draw and then it would be
just her and Tata that's pretty cool to
see her name at the top of the list oh
you bet how exciting another guy at the
top of the list but sharing it with
quite a lot of players more than you'd
expect Grand Master Sam Shanklin he's
with Maurice Ashley let remind everyone
gold medalist Sam Shanklin yeah it's
been a little while since then the
Olympics coming up quite shortly today's
game clearly the tournament is a wild
one so much blood being spilled did you
feel the need to like press in this game
as well yeah well I mean I'm playing
White against the lowest player in the
fields and when the lowest player in the
field plays this well you know you have
a tough tournament I mean it was I had
he played ccil in every game I'd ever
seen from him and then he played the
Frenchman move one I had to just totally
improvise could forget all my
preparation and um I I remembered this
line that uh I I think he just sort of
walked into this after Queen D4 Queen F6
the computer called it equal I knew but
somehow I thought that this Rook on ha
his pieces are backwards it's just like
and then he thought for like an hour and
10 minutes and I was just like okay he's
under pressure he's playing his first US
Championship ever and he's got like 20
minutes against an hour 20 he's just
going to crumbled Chuck up them defended
like a genius every single move and just
like I think it was funny I think a few
times he was equalizing he always played
well when he was worse but uh by the the
points he equalized I think he made a
couple mistakes here and there to let me
back in and well if if this is if White
against the lowest guy goes like this
I'm in for a a rough ride it's a good
point tell tell the fans what is like
what are you doing when he's sitting
there and it's like 30 minutes 40
minutes it's like dude when are you
going to move well I was actually I was
still sort of in my preparation I a very
complicated analysis but of course I
didn't review it cuz I expected this
Sicilian so I was just trying to
remember what was going on and I just
could not for the life of me and uh so I
was mainly just trying to recall what
the computer said cuz in such a sharp
position I have a lot of confidence in
myself but I think the computer's a
little better than me and uh I just
could not remember it and you know at
some point I was just like you can't
possibly be thinking this long even if
you think you're worse you just have to
make a move and like you know play a
worse position where you have some time
to defend but exactly you know uh he
just he just thought for forever and
then rattled off a bunch of good moves I
don't know I mean it's was clearly tough
were you spending any time were you
distracted looking at other games I mean
there were some amazing games going on
around you people were dropping like
flies not especially I noticed csky
blundered this G4 but apart from that I
I didn't really notice much I'm pretty
focused on my own game when I play um I
don't know I noticed there were a lot of
fighting games which is usually a little
which I think a little un usual for
round one of a tournament like this
where everyone is uh generally coming in
with new openings and people don't want
to take much risks against new stuff and
here that just completely not the case
everyone was going absolutely nuts and
well it's going to be a wild tournament
clearly you think it sets its own that
way the first round sets it own yeah I
mean it's it's one thing that uh
especially in the first round a lot of
the stronger players were playing white
seeds one two 3 five and seven all had
white which means that people like them
don't really have the luxury of just
making a draw in round one with white if
they were if colors are traversed maybe
we would have seen a a lighter day but
uh as is I don't know I mean it's it's
young every time I've always thought I
knew it was going to happen us
Championship after round one and then it
completely different so you know it's uh
it's how it goes let's hope it doesn't
go that way because we want to see an
exciting tournament yeah so I'm not
going to listen to you at all okay yeah
yeah well I hope I'm right but but we'll
see you're usually very hard on yourself
when things don't go well yes your
thoughts about this tournament you have
been here many times now you're you're a
veteran of the US Championship yeah you
come in thinking I'm playing to win the
tournament yeah well I'm always coming
in fighting uh you know so far I've had
you know I've had a couple good results
here for sure I got third one year I got
fourth one year but for the most part
I've underperformed and uh I'm always
trying to I guess maybe it's because I'm
willing to take a lot of risks and I
guess those have happened to backfire
but this time is I think the first time
in like six years that I started with a
white and my first time ever that I
started with a win so uh so you knew
that you were aware of that fact because
play somebody brought that up that you
you were trying to break a record not
winning in the first round well if you
give me enough blacks in a row then
maybe I'll do it but this time I I
managed although it was anything but
easy well absolutely you kept us here in
our seats and uh got the job done so we
look forward to seeing a good result
from you the rest of the tournament
thanks much Grand Master Sam Shanklin
always a fighter always Taking Chances
we love to watch him play guys congrats
to Sam very nice as he joins the winners
uh a tight for first uh where do we
stand with result wise uh in the Women's
Championship we've got one game going on
look like it's going to be a total draw
it's a total draw now she's just that
and I think I saw
Nagi uh making a draw offer but I guess
not otherwise they would have drawn
instantly uh agreed instantly but they
will soon very very soon um you want to
you want to pull up the board to explain
to our our audience why this is just a
totally dead draw exactly despite the
extra Pawn there's no way that pawn is
going to make it up the board make it to
the fantasy make it to the promis L the
promotion Square there we have it let me
just there we have it so essentially
blacks and there's the handshake there
is a allw but as explain yeah basically
black is keeping White's King at Bay by
just controlling the F line and if white
um tries
to
uh bring our King
over oops good grief I
could there we no what did I do oh I
have to make Black's move black Waits
and if she tries to build a bridge for a
queen well we just take
it and we're in a simple King and pawn
ending that's going to be stalemate and
a draw so a simple easy draw to hold but
quite a struggle as we finish finish our
broadcast of uh round one just before we
go let's take a look at uh the the
standings and uh where we are yes indeed
let's take a look at the standings in
the US championship and the US women
championship of course the big surprise
today was five out of six decisive games
in the US CH Championship wow and uh
we've got Fabiano Carana Nakamura Wesley
so Ray Robson Sam shanglin all winning
their first games and dazzling games if
you miss part of them don't forget that
you can check it out on YouTube and
Rewind the broadcast highly encourage it
um Alex and onuk and Jeffrey Jong the
only draw um meanwhile in the Women's
Championship there was actually quite a
lot of solid defenses so really it was
almost like things flipped a little bit
from what we often see with a lot of
draws in the overall and um more
decisive in the women's uh Kissa Yip
gosh um her parents who probably worked
so hard to get her to where she is
OPP just to see her at the top I'm not
sure by what criteria
over but maybe say random U but both of
them tie for First with a one point each
Arena crush with a with a draw and of
course all the rest of the field except
for AATA um BYOB and a gorti all drawing
their Gams um we are um going to wrap
shortly but uh Grandmaster Maurice
Ashley with his uh final thought of the
day well what more could you want from a
championship of Victories everywhere
blood spilling all over the board the
top players showing their stuff the
great players of our time prove that us
chess is really On The Rise and the US
Championship is something worth watching
all over the world I remember when we
used to watch the Soviet championships
you used to see those names you're like
man look at those guys now the world
talks about us the same way certainly a
team that could win gold in the
Olympians but first they've got to work
on this one and one of them is going to
try to win the national title so an
exciting first round to be sure some
scintillating moves in this round uh
definitely worth going over once again
just to take a look at the Artistry and
dominance off the play so a fun first
round for sure here at the at the 2016
US
championships thank you
Maurice and I think we are possibly
going to hear from the women um uh we're
getting we're getting confirmation on
that but uh just uh we were going to
wrap up there you go yeah but uh just a
very exciting day and U of course
tomorrow we're going to be back at one
Central Standard Time and um I think uh
I think we are raing sorry guys but man
it was a great day we loved your phone
calls very much so and Shout Out Of
course to the players who really made it
so exciting today they definitely
brought their aame indeed um and this is
Jennifer shahadi signing off with
Grandmasters yaser San and Maurice
Ashley and actually tune in at 12:50
Central Standard time so that you can
catch the uh pregame show as well and
that's 150 over in the east coast see
you guys tomorrow for round two of the
US championships and us
[Music]
women